GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE
GONNA OPEN UP THE UP. ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE-
WAITING FOR MEMBERS TO ARRIVE
IN THE MEANTIME- WE HAVE SOME
ABOUT CLERICAL DUTIES THAT WE
NEED TO DO AND TO BE ABLE TO
READ SO THAT- INDIVIDUALS WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY WILL BE ABLE
TO. AND OUR- ON OUR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND HEARING
LOGISTICS WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY HEARING DUE TO CONTINUE
TO STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASS BE WARNED AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFIED. WHETHER
HERE IN ROME OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A DIFFERENT.
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY.
FIRST FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM TODAY IN ROME FORTY TWO OH
TWO FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA. SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIXTY
OF SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITOL FOR THOSE.
HERE IN THE AND FOR THOSE HERE
IN THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCHED A
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
JUST FINE OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMIT LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO
ONE PERSON AT A TIME. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESS. WITNESSES MAKING USE
OF OUR ONE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL THE
CONFERENCING ROOM FOR OUR
HEARING. IS ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE.
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO ASKING QUESTIONS.
FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES WE CAN
ALSO BE ABLE WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH- ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX. NOT TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN.
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING.
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ONLINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO PLACE IN
Q. BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE A BILL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN POLICE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THIS SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL. WE REMAIN
ON A ON A LIFELINE IT WOULD
NEED TO BUTTE YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY TROUBLES WITH
THE MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT AREA
CODE NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE
NINE THREE SEVEN FOUR FOUR. AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR HEARING
WITH. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT MET
THIS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO
BEING MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL.
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS.
WE ARE WE ALL FACE. WITH WE-
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL
CONTINUE AS A SUB COMMITTEE- WE
DO HAVE SENATOR TOM LAUDER.
EMPLOYMENT ALLOW HER TO COME IN
MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION FIRST
WILL BOTH YOUR BILLS- WE HAVE A-
WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS PLUS ONE
ON CONSENT ITEM SO- WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO SO AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE BEGIN ON TIME. SO
WE'RE NOT HERE. ALL NIGHT AND
MAKE SURE MEMBERS TIME IS NOT
WASTED SO AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
BEGIN IS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
WHAT OTHER MEMBERS COME WE MAY
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND VOTE ON
IT- REPORT ON IT LATER GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- FOR
MAKING THE ACCOMMODATION GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU AND TO MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB ONE TWO
FOUR. JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS
THIS BILL IS A LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL.
AB ONE TWENTY FOUR WOULD
SUPPORT SURVIVORS OF VIOLENCE
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING. BY
REQUIRING THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO CONSIDER THE FULL
CONTEXT OF A PERSON'S RELATED
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND EXPERIENCES
THROUGHOUT THE COURT PROCESS.
THE IMPETUS FOR THIS BILL CAME
IN SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
WHEN I WROTE TO THE GOVERNOR IN
SUPPORT OF KIANA ALDRICH'S.
PETITION FOR COMMUTATION OF SAN.
AT AGE. KIANA WAS TO TWO YEARS
BE BARS. DESPITE LAWS THAT
PROTECT AGAINST VICTIM
CRIMINALIZATION FOR HER ALLEGED
ROLE IN THE KIDNAPPING AND
ROBBERY OF TWO MEN. THESE TWO
MEN POSTED AN ONLINE AD LOOKING
TO PURCHASE HER FOR SEX AND TO
MAKE **** AND YET NEITHER OF
THESE MEN FACED ANY CHARGES FOR
SOLICITING SEX FROM A MINOR
MINOR. KIANA HOWEVER WAS
CHARGED AS AN ADULT. PRIOR TO
HER CONVICTION KIANA LIVED A
LIFE FILLED WITH ABUSE AND
TRAUMA AT AGE FIVE HER FATHER
WAS CONVICTED OF SEXUALLY
MOLESTING HER. SHE SPENT TIME
AT JUVENILE HALL AS A YOUTH AT
SIXTEEN SHE WAS ARRESTED WITH A
FEMALE PIMP AND AGREED TO
TESTIFY AGAINST THE WOMAN
THOUGH SHE NEVER PROVIDED WAS
PROVIDED WITH COUNSELING OR
SAVE HOUSING. HAD OUR SYSTEM
SUCCESSFULLY INTERVENED AT ANY
POINT. KIANA MAY NEVER HAVE
LANDED IN PRISON. BUT WE KNOW
SYSTEMS FAIL FAR MORE WOMEN
THAN KIANA ALONG. THE ACLU
ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY 60% OF
FEMALE STATE PRISONERS
NATIONWIDE AND AS MANY AS 94%
OF CERTAIN FEMALE PRISON
POPULATIONS HAVE EXPERIENCED
PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL ABUSE BEFORE
BEING INCARCERATED. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
AND INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
AND OTHER SEVERE FORMS OF
TRAUMA ARE MORE LIKELY TO LAND
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
YES OUR CURRENT. LEGAL FRAME
LACKS CLEAR MECHANISMS TO
CONSIDER RELEVANT FACTORS AND
EXPERIENCES THAT CONTRIBUTED TO
THE COMMISSION OF THE OFFENSE.
AB ONE TWO FOUR ADDRESSES GAPS
AND FAILURES OF THE CURRENT
LEGAL SYSTEM BY ALLOWING THE
COURT TO CONSIDER HOW THE
DEFENDANT'S OWN TRAUMA.
CONTRIBUTED TO THE COMMISSION
OF THE OFFENSE AND OR
CONVICTION SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL WILL EXPAND ACCESS TO THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE. IT WILL EXPAND
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO AVOID
IMPOSING SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS
ON SURVIVORS IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT JUDGES GIVE GREAT WEIGHT
TO YOUTHFULNESS TRAUMA SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND VICTIMIZATION
THROUGH INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHEN EXERCISING. THEIR
DISCRETION AT SENTENCING STAGES.
IT WILL ALLOW THE COURTS TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THE SURVIVORS
EXPERIENCE OF TRAUMA AND OR
VIOLENCE WAS A CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR IN THE COMMISSION OF THE
OFFENSE. AND IT WOULD EXPAND
THE BACK TO TOUR LAW TO APPLY
TO CRIMES THAT WERE THE DIRECT
RESULT OF BEING A VICTIM OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. AB ONE TWO FOUR WILL
GIVE SURVIVORS A MECHANISM TO
SEEK JUSTICE THAT IS HOLISTIC
AND REHABILITATIVE. WITH ME
HERE IN SUPPORT ARE STILL
GRAYSON POLICY ASSOCIATE AT THE
YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER
AND KATE WALKER BROWN DIRECTOR
OF COLLABORATIVE RESPONSES TO
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL AT
EXPLOITATION. AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I THINK WHEN THEY
WITNESSES PRESENT MISTER CHAIR
WILL BE MISSED KATE BROWN FIRST
AND THEN MISS APRIL GRAYSON.
OKAY WHAT WHENEVER OPERATOR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. LETTUCES
AFTER COURT THANK YOU MISTER
CORK. JONES.
SAWYER HERE LACKEY
HERE. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN JONES
SAWYER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FIND KEEP WALKER BROWN AN
ATTORNEY AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE COLLABORATIVE RESPONSES
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
INITIATIVE AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW FOR A
DECADE MY TEAM HAS WORKED WITH
SURVIVORS A FATE UNIMAGINABLE
TRAUMA FOR TRAFFICKING ABUSE
AND VIOLENCE. FORCING THEM TO
CONTINUALLY FIND WAYS TO
SURVIVE THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM HAS ONLY EXACERBATED
THAT HARM BURDENING THEM WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS SEPARATING
THEM FROM FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
AND EXPOSING THEM TO FURTHER
TRAUMA AND VIOLENCE FOR TOO
LONG CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM HAS PUNISHED THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. OUR PRISON SYSTEM
IS FILLED WITH BLACK BROWN
INDIGENOUS AND LOW INCOME WOMEN
IN ADDITION TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRANS AND QUEER THE SAME
INDIVIDUALS HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPERIENCE
ABUSE AND TRAUMA AS CHILDREN
THIS TRAUMA MAKES THEM EVEN
MORE VULNERABLE TO COERCION AND
MANIPULATION THAT IS AFFECTING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE. ALTHOUGH
PICARD LEGAL SYSTEMS HAVE A
BALD RECENTLY RECOGNIZING
IMPACT OF AGING TRAUMA ON A
PERSONAL BEHAVIOR WE CONTINUE
TO CHARGE CONVICT AND
INCARCERATE MANY VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND VIOLENCE WILL
BEHAVIORS ARISING OUT OF WHAT
WAS DONE TO THEM IN A- WE ARE
BLAMING AND PUNISHING PEOPLE
FOR SIMPLY SURVIVING. AB ONE
TWENTY FOUR WILL BRING OUR
ANTIQUATED CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM INTO THE MODERN DAY BY
PROVIDING THE COURTS WITH
CRITICAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SURVIVORS EXPERIENCES AND HOW
THEY RELATE TO THE COMMISSION
OF A CRIME THIS BILL TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
ON ADOLESCENT DEVELOPMENT. THE
IMPACT OF TRAUMA ON DECISION
MAKING AND THE DEEPLY COERCIVE
MANIPULATIVE AND VIOLENT
DYNAMICS THAT ARE PRESENT IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE A MORE HOLISTIC
APPROACH WILL BE TO DECREASE
RECIDIVISM YOUR LONG TERM
CULTURAL COSTS WILL INCREASE
ARENA. THIS BILL IN NO WAY THE
JUDGES. NOR IT OFF ENDED OKAY
OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD. BUT
INSTEAD ENSURE THAT IT ALL
STAGE IN THE CASE. COURTS HAVE
MORE INFO. MORE TO. IN
GUIDELINES TO AFFECT JEFF FOR
ALL PARTIES. AB ONE TWENTY
FORGET SURVIVOR WHO HAVE BEEN.
UNSEEN BY. IGNORE AND THROWN
AWAY A CHANCE IT JUST. JUSTICE
B. AS BECOMES HAVE TOO LONG DO
NOT. I STRONGLY URGE TO VOTE I
TO ALLOW. TO ACCESS TRUSTED CAL.
THANK YOU. THANK NEXT WHAT.
HELLO MANY IS ABLE GRAYSON I AM
A PERSON WHO IS EVERY WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NEVER MY
FORTY THREE YEAR AS ANY GUY AID
ADVOCATED FOR OR DID THE ME I
ALSO WASN'T AWARE I CAME HOME
GOING YEARS OF. THAT WAS THE
DAY TO PROTECT YOU HAVE A FROM.
I WOULD WANT THE **** YOUR
SYSTEM AT THE AGE OF THREE MY
BOSS HOME BIRTH MY WAS MURDERED
SO NOW AT EIGHT FOUR HOURS A
DAY OUT A HOUSEHOLD THAT A PART
DAHLE IT WOULD NOT A QUICKLY
ITS MCCARTY SAID MENTAL AND
MORE WORDS HIS WHEN A. TO FOUR.
ABOUT FIFTEEN OTHER CHILDREN
HAD TO SIT OUT AND REFUSED TO
WATCH OUR ROOMS THAT DAY OUT OF
THE FIFTEEN FOR ASKING OUT ONLY
TWO WERE ARRESTED THE TWO BLACK
GIRLS THAT WAS MY FIRST
INTRODUCTION TO THE CARPOOL
SYSTEM THE OTHER YOUNG LADY WAS
ALLOWED TO GO HOME WITH HER
MOTHER AT THE FIRST COURT DATE
I ON THE OTHER HAND STATING YOU
HARPER FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS.
SHUFFLE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
JULIE TO EVERY GIVEN ALL CALLS
ON THE CALIFORNIA SOLELY
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO WITH ME ESPECIALLY I
WOULD COME. ALIVE TO BEING A
PARENT WITH A CHILD. BUT THIS.
EIGHT I LOST MY ONE ONLY SAID.
CAR CRASH THAT SHUT THROUGH.
FIVE TO SIX O'CLOCK HOMES AND
GROUP HOMES. I MET FROM THE
SYSTEM. THE TECHNICAL TERM KICK
OUT BECAUSE WITHOUT IS OUT OF.
A FEW MONTHS LATER MYSELF
SACRAMENTO SPEAKING KIDNAPPING
A PEPPERING TIPPING UP
PANDERING WITH TO HAPPEN. OUT
OF THE BY MASTERMIND BIG
EUROPEAN. WELL MY TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR OLD CODEFENDANT AND
TRAFFICKER WOULD NOT CONVICTED
OF ANY OF THE CHARGES. HE ALSO
WAS NEVER IDENTIFIED AS A
THREAT TRAFFICKER MY TRAFFICKER
I WOULD SET UP TO TWENTY YEARS.
EIGHT MONTHS. I HAVE NO BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS A- OR BEEN
ALLOWED BY GOING TO A BIG. I
WOULD COMPLETELY AT THE A OF
THIRTY BEFORE I AND I'VE BEEN
AS IS. OF MY. PLAY BY TO A FEW
FOR EVER ANY A TO ME. AB ONE
TWENTY BUT ALLOW. HOPEFULLY
SOME AT THEIR POLLY. PRESS OR
AGAIN WOULD BY. ME AS A BIG.
AND EFFECTIVE ME. REFERRED ME
FOR THERAPY. A TECHNICAL. TO
ALL SOMEWHAT UPSET IN A SENIOR
HAD NEVER HAD A CHANCE LIVE OFF
OF ME. THERE WASN'T I CAN'T.
WITHOUT FIFTEEN ADMITTED.
ADDRESS I CAN'T AGAINST SO LONG
THAT ENDED. EVER ME I TO BE.
NOT ONLY A- OF THE ALSO TRY. I
WANT INTO THE ABOUT BECAME A-
OKAY. THAT COULD HAVE HAVE BEEN
THE FIRST HELP ARMS. I WAS A
BIT OF SO MANY WAY AND IT WAS
BY CAN'T DECADES LAY. THAT I
GOT HELP FROM A- THE PER. WHO
SAID TO LOOK AT ME FROM WHAT OF
MY CRIME. THAT MORE THAN A. WE
NEED A PLACE TO LOOK FOR WOMEN
IN THE VIRUS THAT'S CALLED.
EXCELLENT BEING BEFORE WE
SECOND BENCH AT ALL. OR IN. I
NEEDED SOMEONE TO LOOK AT ME AS
A PERSON I WAS. NOT AT THE
CRIME RATE DOWN BLACK AND WHITE.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED A NEW ONE.
FOUR WEEKS OF CORRECTIVE STEPS
ENDING THAT USED TO PUT A
PIPELINE. SO WHAT THE BIG. LIKE
THANK YOU. I IN YOUR WITNESSES.
HERE COMMITTEE ROOM. ANY
WITNESSES ON THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING. OPERATOR YOU NOW
OPEN UP THE LINES TO AB ONE TWO
FOUR FOUR WITNESSES OF STATE
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR NAME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
FIRST COMIC COMES FROM MIND TO
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TO SIXTY
FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVING ON TO LINE THREE TEN
NINE THREE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
INVOLVED IN A CAR OUT OF WITH
THE YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM
CENTER WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR
THE AB ONE TWENTY FOUR AND ALSO
EXPRESS APART FROM THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS. SAID
NOBODY US INITIATE. LOS ANGELES
CENTER FOR LAW AND JUSTICE
MYANMAR CAN HELP THERE BEFORE.
MONARCH SERVICES INFORMIX
COUNTY POSITIVE WOMEN'S NETWORK
USA PUBLIC DEFENDERS FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE SURVIVED IN PANIC. THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM THE WELL PAST
TIME FOR CHANGE FOUNDATION
TRANSGENDER ADVOCACY GROUP
TREASURES. UNCOMMON LAW W. HEY
WOULD BURN AND KILL WOMEN
FOUNDATION. CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. AND MY THREE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS COURTNEY
TAYLOR I'M WITH THE- ONE TO
PREDICT AND ARE ALSO SUPPORT OF
THIS LAW. THE COMPANY'S. THREE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS AS FUNDING
AS WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
NINE THREE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MARK GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. IN TWO EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ANITA L.
THERM WITH THE BODY PUNISH IN
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSORS AND I WANNA- ALSO
SHARE OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO
SUPPORT THIS. THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ACTION CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CALIFORNIA PRISON
FOCUS CATALYST PROJECT CENTER
FOR COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CHILDREN
TO THE FENCE LINE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOME STOCKTON
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. CITIZENS FOR
CHILE'S CLERGY AND LAITY UNITED
FOR ECONOMIC JUSTICE COLEMAN
ADVOCATE FOR CHILDREN TO USE
COMMUNITY MEDICAL CENTER HELLO
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
EMPOWERING PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. MIND YOU TO A SEVEN YOUR
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JESSICA GALLAGHER AND
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWENTY FOUR ALONG WITH
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS AND
PEOPLE. CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE. CAN I
HAVE FOSTER ANDERSON FROM LOS
ANGELES HOUSTON MONDAY ROM
PLEASANT HILL LANE WORLD FROM
BERKELEY MADDIE MORE FROM
BERKELEY MEGAN DAL FROM SAN
DIEGO MEREST OF ALL FROM SAN
DIEGO NATASHA BAKER FROM
OAKLAND. THE CALL VOLUMES FROM
EMORY. NINO WOKE FROM MENLO
PARK REGINA EFFLUX FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CERVANTES PROTECTOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO RYAN PALMER
FROM OAKLAND RYAN LEWIS FROM
VICTORVILLE FACING BILLIONS
FROM SAN DIEGO. STUDENTS MET
CONSENT NO MARLATT CONTINUE
VALLEY JERRY SEKOLAH NOPE IN
FACT THEN CHOI BRITAIN THREAT
SAN DIEGO VALENTINO TOLD
WELCOME PACKAGE AND WENDY
HOWARD FROM. JANET CHOPPY THANK
YOU. NINE THREE ELEVEN YOU'RE
MY IS OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. MARIA
CRISTINA. FROM FIRE TRUTH
ORGANIZATION AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THANK YOU. HI
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MELISSA THOMAS I WANT FREE TO
THRIVE WHERE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF AB ONE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M
GONNA READ. A LIST OF.
SUPPORTERS THAT WE GATHERED.
OUR LOCAL COURSE ALL OF LOS
ANGELES. ABOUT CAP OPEN.
ADRIANA GRIFFITH FROM STOCKTON.
ALEC WHITE IN OAKLAND. A LEAH
HARDEMAN CONTENT AND JUST GO.
CAROLINA MARIN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. CRISTINA SEESAW FROM
LOS ANGELES. KARINA ANDERSON
FROM FONTANA. DEBRA CHILD FROM
SAN RAFAEL. FOTOGRAFIA FROM
OAKLAND YOU KNOW MORE FROM LOS
ANGELES. CHAMBER SHOCK FROM SAN
DIEGO. HELENA BURKE FROM
OAKLAND. HONORABLE SHAY FRANCO
CLAUSEN FROM SAN JOSE. JANET.
RIGHT FROM SAN FRANCISCO. KAREN
E. LOCAL FROM OAK BEACH CALIF
YOU GOTTA CONSIDER. CASEY HOW
FROM OAK. JOHN I'LL AND KELLY
WROTE ON FRONT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MANAGING THIS CALL WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLED IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS- MARY MORENO- CURRENTLY
WORKING AND FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES SIMPLE PARKS OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THREE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FIFTY YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS LOOSE FLOOR FOR
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. THANK YOU WILL GO ON TO-
STATEMENTS FROM OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE. ERICA GONZALES
SUPERVISING DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TULARE COUNTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT CHAIRED BY SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ERICA GONZALEZ WITH THE TULARE
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WHILE WE SUPPORT THE THEORY
BEHIND THIS BILL WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE IT BECAUSE
IT IS OVERBROAD AND VAGUE
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS THE COURT
TO CONSIDER CIRCUMSTANCES AN
AGGRAVATION AND OR MITIGATION
AND ANY OTHER FACTOR REASONABLY
RELATED TO THE SENTENCING
DECISION. THE RELEVANT
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY BE OBTAINED
FROM THE CASE RECORD THE
PROBATION OFFICER'S REPORT
OTHER REPORTS AND STATEMENTS
PROPERLY RECEIVED. STATEMENTS
IN AGGRAVATION OR MITIGATION
WHICH CAN BE FILED BY THAT THE
DEFENDANT'S ATTORNEY AND ANY
EVIDENCE INTRODUCED AT THE
SENTENCING HEARING. COURT
ALREADY HAS BROAD DISCRETION TO
CONSIDER RELEVANT CIRCUMSTANCES
IN DETERMINING THE MOST
APPROPRIATE SENTENCE THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE COURT TO
IMPOSE A LOWER TERM WHERE
TRAUMA USEFULNESS OR HAVING
BEEN A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OR INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE WHAT THE CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR IN THE COMMISSION OF THE
OFFENSE. HOWEVER IT IS UNCLEAR
WHAT EVIDENCE IS SUFFICIENT TO
PROVE ONE OF THESE FACTORS
WHETHER IN FACT A CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR AND WHETHER IT WAS A
MINOR OR MAJOR CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR. IF THE COURT REQUIRED
TO IMPOSE A LOWER TERMS IF IT
WAS IN FACT A MINOR
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO EXTEND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE
TO SERIOUS AND VIOLENT CRIMES I
WOULD CREATE A NEW AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE FOR VICTIMS OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. AS PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL THESE DEFENSES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO DEFENDANTS WHO ARE
COURSE TO COMMIT A SERIOUS OR
VIOLENT OFFENSES. AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF BEING A VICTIM OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. AS LONG AS THEY HAVE
A REASONABLE FEAR OF HARM. TO
HARM THE FEAR NEED NOT BE
SERIOUS NOR VIOLENT THIS IS
VERY CONCERNING BECAUSE THIS
WOULD CHANGE THIS. WOULD
CHANGE. EXCUSE ME THIS CHANGE
WOULD EXTEND AN AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE TO AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
COMMITS A SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
CRIMES INCLUDING MURDER AGAINST
ANY PERSON EVEN A CHILD. SINCE
THE HARM THE INDIVIDUAL FEARS
NEED NOT BE SERIOUS NOR VIOLENT
AN INDIVIDUAL CAN ARGUE THEY
WERE AFRAID OF A BATTERY AT THE
HANDS OF AN INTIMATE PARTNER OR
HUMAN TRAFFICKER. THUS ALLOWING
THE INDIVIDUAL TO CLAIM AN
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE FOR CAUSING
SERIOUS OR VIOLENT INJURIES.
EVEN MURDER TO A CHILD. THIS
BILL WILL LIKELY WERE IN IN
EQUITIES IN SENTENCING AS THERE
IS NO MENTION OF THE EVIDENCE
REQUIRED TO PROVE THE
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCE AND
WHETHER THE TRAUMA WAS A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR OF THEIR
CRIME. INDIVIDUALS WHO COMMIT
CRIMES MAY SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REQUEST A
MITIGATED SENTENCE. IT IS
LIKELY THE EVIDENCE REQUIRED
WILL INVOLVE EXPERT TESTIMONY
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH EXPERTS.
ORDER TO MULTI EXPERTS. ADMINS
ALSO INCLUDE ANY CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA IN ADDITION TO ANY
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE OR
SEXUAL VIOLENCE THIS EXPANSION
INTO CHILDHOOD TRAUMA WOULD
DRASTICALLY EXPAND
INVESTIGATION REQUIREMENTS AND
IN TURN DRASTICALLY INCREASE
COURT EXPENSES FOR CONDUCTING
HEARINGS REGARDING THAT
INFORMATION. THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE COURT TO RECALL
AN INMATE'S SENTENCE AND
RESENTENCED THEM UPON A MOTION
BY THE INMATE DEATHS WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN MANY
INCARCERATED INMATES MAKING A
REQUEST REQUEST TO RECALL THEIR
SENTENCE AS WE HAVE SEEN IN
PASSED MEASURES WHICH WILL
PROVE COSTLY FOR THE COURTS
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND PUBLIC
DEFENDERS WILL HAVE TO RESPOND
AND APPEAR FOR EVERY REQUEST
MADE BY AN INMATE. FURTHER AS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE PROOF
REQUIRED FOR THE COURT IT'S NOT
CLEAR. NEXT THE BILL HAS BEEN
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE MENTAL
DEFECT BEING A DEFENSE FOR NOT
ONLY SPECIFIC ANTI CRIME
STOPPER GENERAL INTENT CRIMES
THIS IS A DRAMATIC CHANGE IN
LAW THAT UNDERCUTS DECADES OF
CASE LAW. CAN THE DICTUM BUILT
VICTIMS BILL OF RIGHTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. LASTLY
THIS BILL MAY LEAD TO GREATER
VICTIMIZATION OF INDIVIDUALS BY
THEIR ABUSERS. IF THEIR ABUSERS
ARE AWARE THAT THEIR VICTIMS
WILL NOT BE PROSECUTED OR WILL
RECEIVE A LESSER SENTENCE FOR
COMMITTING A CRIME. A BIT MAY
BE MORE LIKELY TO UTILIZE THEIR
VICTIMS TO COMMIT CRIMES THERE
IS AN AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE AND
ARREST THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
VICTIMS OF CRIME CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR VICTIMS WHO
ENGAGE IN CRIMINAL CONDUCT
UNDER THE THREAT OF ANOTHER. WE
HAVE SEEN THIS TRAGIC OUTCOME
OCCUR OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
OTHER ARENAS. WHEN THE
PUNISHMENT OF ADULTS INCREASED
FOR SELLING DRUGS ACROSS THE
STATE DRUG DEALERS WERE PULLING
CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS TEN TO
TWELVE YEARS OLD INTO DRUG
TRAFFICKING CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE. WE HAVE SEEN MINERS
BEING USED TO COMMIT GANG
CRIMES IDENTITY THEFT AND
CRIMES AGAINST OTHER PERSONS.
CONCLUDING BEAMS ARE SED AS
RICH RECRUITERS FOR
TRAFFICKERS. AS STATED EARLIER
THE AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE AND
THIS BILL IS MUCH BROADER THAN
BE AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE UP TO
REST. THAT IS CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH IS VERY
CONCERNING FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SB.
FORTY TWO OH TWO. ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE VIDEO
TELECONFERENCING. YOU CAN NOW
OPEN UP OPPOSITION- AT&T AB.
ONE TWO FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB ONE
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISTER CORK. YEAH
FIRST A MOVE THE BILL. R. AND
THEN I'LL ASK TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU- SO I
HEARD THE OPPOSITION- MOST OF
IT I DON'T THINK. IS TERRIBLY
CONVINCING I MEAN THEY'RE
THEY'RE ALREADY USING THESE
POOR CHILDREN AS- TO DO ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE OPPOSITION SAID
I MEAN I DON'T THINK THAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE- AND WHILE THEY
SAY THAT THERE IS- WASTE
CONSIDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
THEY'RE CLEARLY NOT BEING
CONSIDERED. SO I THINK THE BILL
IS URGENT AND NEEDED. THE ONE
CONCERN I DO HAVE AN THIS CAME
NOT SO MUCH FROM THE SPEAKER
BUT IN THE LETTER THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE D. A.'S. IS
THE LARGE POTENTIALLY LARGE
COSTS AND YOU CAN ANSWER THAT
EITHER NOW OR IN YOUR CLOTHES.
BUT THE IDEA THAT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE EXPERT WITNESSES DO
INVESTIGATIONS- LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ASKING FOR RESENTENCING
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THOSE
EITHER NOW OR IN YOUR CLOTHES
IT'S UP TO YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK AND
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU ON
AS A CO AUTHOR. I ALSO HAVE
JEREMY THORTON ON WHO IS- THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER FROM THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AT SAN DIEGO
WHO CAN. PROBABLY ADDITIONALLY
ELABORATE ON WHAT I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU IN RESPONSE- THERE'S
STILL A THRESHOLD THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE MET- YOU I KNOW THAT
THE- OPPOSITION IS CONCERNED
ABOUT ALL OF THESE SORT OF SELF
REFERRALS. FOR THESE ELEVEN
SEVENTY DIS- BUT THERE IS
CRITERIA THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
MET- AND NOT ALL OF THE
REFERRALS ARE APPROVED- AND SO
THERE WOULD NOT BE- ADDITIONAL
CLOGGING IS OF THE COURT
BECAUSE I THINK THE ASSUMPTION
IS THAT THEY WOULD BE UTILIZING
PUBLIC DEFENDERS IT'S ALSO
REALLY EXPENSIVE TO HAVE-
PRIVATE COUNSEL FOR THIS- AND
AS I MENTIONED. THERE WOULD BE
THRESHOLDS THAT HAVE TO BE MET
THIS IS NOT JUST HEY I THINK I
WANNA A SECOND LOOK- YOU KNOW
AT MY SENTENCE IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO. I BELIEVE IT WAS SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN MISS
SKINNER'S BILL- ABOUT FELONY
MURDER THERE WAS STILL A
THRESHOLD THAT HAD TO BE MET-
FOR CONSIDERATION FOR THOSE-
BUT JEREMY THORTON IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE IF MAYBE YOU CAN
ELABORATE. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SO TO ADDRESS THE
CONSPECIFIC LEE AND SOME OF THE
CONTENTIONS FROM THE
OPPOSITION- LAW EXPERTS COULD
CERTAINLY BE USED- TO ADDRESS
THESE- FACTORS IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING THE
CONDITION AND WHETHER OR NOT IT
WAS A CONTRIBUTING FACTOR. THAT
IS NOT THE SOLE WAY TO DO IT
AND FRANKLY THAT MAY NOT EVEN
BE THE FIRST WAY THAT DEFENSE
LAWYERS OR DEFENDANTS CLIENTS
THAT SEEK TO PROVE THIS ONE IS
OUR RECORDS- CPS RECORDS POLICE
REPORTS- ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES RECORDS ANYTHING THAT
CAN THE STAFF WAS THE LEVEL.
THE EXISTENCE OF THE CONDITION-
THAT FALLS WITHIN ONE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES- ALSO INTERVIEWS
YOU KNOW A LOT OF TIMES THE
MOST PROBATIVE EVIDENCE OF
CHILD ABUSE CHILD MALTREATMENT
OR SEXUAL VIOLENCE IS FROM
TEACHERS AND TEACHERS ARE ARE
MANDATORY REPORTERS TEACHERS
OBSERVE CHILDREN ALL THE TIME
IN CLASSROOMS. AND SO AS A
DEFENSE PRACTITIONER WHEN I'M
ATTEMPTING TO DEMONSTRATE THE
LEVEL DAM OF ABUSE THAT MY
CLIENT IS SUSTAINED I WILL
ABSOLUTELY GO THROUGH- SCHOOL
RECORDS IN INTERVIEW TEACHERS
NEIGHBORS ALSO CAN ESTABLISH
THINGS LIKE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ABUSE- SO THOSE ARE
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE INTERVIEWED.
AND IT IS IT IS PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AS DEFENSE LAWYERS
AND MOSTLY PUBLIC DEFENDERS
FRANKLY WHO WILL BE DOING- THE
LEGWORK ON MISSION PRESENTING
THIS EVIDENCE IN GATHERING THIS
EVIDENCE- AND FRANKLY MOST OF
THIS IS ALREADY DONE. THIS KIND
OF MITIGATION IS NOT UNCOMMON
IN OUR PRACTICE IT'S JUST THAT
THE QUESTION IS HOW IS THIS
MEDICATION USED BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND THE COURTS AND
THAT'S WHERE THIS BILL DIRECTS-
HOW THIS MEDICATION SHOULD BE
USED AND- WHAT THE PURPOSES- I
ALSO. WANTED TO ADDRESS THERE
WAS- THE IDEA OF- CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR AND WHETHER OR NOT WE
NEED EXPERTS TO PROVE THAT AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
COURTS WILL DO AND THAT THE
COURTS WILL ADDRESS THAT
THEY'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT
STANDARD. AND CAN CERTAINLY. A
WEIGH IN ON THAT- AND THEN
LASTLY SORRY THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S AND IN HAVING TO
TURN OVER THE DISCOVERY- DATE
WILL CERTAINLY HAVE A BURDEN TO.
OFFER THE DEFENSE POLICE
REPORTS THAT INDICATE THE
CLIENT WAS A VICTIM- BUT THAT'S
JUST KIND OF. THE NATURE OF DUE
PROCESS IS WHEN THERE IS
MITIGATING EVIDENCE OUT THERE
PROSECUTORS HAVE A DUTY TO TURN
IT OVER AND THAT WILL CONTINUE
AND BE EMPHASIZED IN THIS BILL
PARTICULAR WHEN OUR CLIENTS
HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED. AND THANK
YOU THAT THIRTY INCHES MY
QUESTIONS AND- I AM STILL A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT COST NOT
HERE BUT IF WHEN IT GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS SO JUST THINK
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU%
MISTER. ALSO LIKE TO ADD IF I
CAN THAT- IN SOME. COUNTIES
RIGHT NOW DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICES ARE ACTUALLY
RESTRUCTURING THEIR
DEPARTMENTS- TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THESE KINDS OF
REFERRALS THAT COULD COME IN.
AND IN FACT WE TOOK OUT THE
SELF REFERRAL- ASPECT OF THE
BILL BEFORE SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THE OPPOSITION LETTER WAS
TALKING ABOUT COSTS IN GENERAL
OR COST OF SELF REFERRALS. BUT
THAT IS NOT IN THE BILL-
CURRENTLY SO I WANTED ALSO SORT
OF SHARE THAT. THANK YOU MISTER
CIERTA THANK YOU. SO IF THIS
BILL WERE NARROWED DOWN TO-
FOCUS ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SEXUAL VIOLENCE. FOR INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE. ARE I WOULD
BE VERY MUCH- INTERESTED IN IN
BEING SUPPORT OF A- THE PROBLEM
I HAVE IS THE PART WHERE. IF
THE CRIMINAL DEFENDANT HAS
EXPERIENCED ANY PSYCHOLOGICAL
PHYSICAL CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
BECAUSE- IN CRIMINAL WORLD.
THAT CONSTITUTES ABOUT 90% OF
THE CRIMINALS AND THAT'S PRETTY
MUCH WHY THEY ARE CRIMINALS IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND IT ALSO
YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S A LARGE
POPULATION OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DONE HAVE HAD ALL OF THOSE. AND
ARE NOT CRIMINALS AND HAVE NOT
DONE CRIMES AND A YOU KNOW
SERIAL KILLERS FIT INTO THIS
PARTICULAR- DESCRIPTION- I
DIDN'T GET THAT WAY ALL BY
THEMSELVES. THEY GOT THAT WAY
BECAUSE OF THE TRAUMA. HOWEVER
THAT DOESN'T MAKE THEM LESS
DANGEROUS TO THE PUBLIC AND IT
DOESN'T MAKE THEIR VICTIMS
ANYMORE A LIFE. SO YEAH I DID
THAT'S THE PROBLEM I HAVE WITH
THIS IS THEY OVER BROADNESS
THAT WAS POINTED OUT I THINK BY
ONE OF THE OPPOSITION PRIMARY
WITNESSES- AND THAT'S WHY YOU
KNOW IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
SUPPORT SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY ANY OTHER COMMENTER
QUESTIONS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR HI- AND THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR CONCERNS
YOU KNOW THAT WAS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT- I WRESTLED WITH
AS I WAS WORKING WITH THIS
BILL- AND THE AND THE ADVOCATES
AND HARING ALL OF THE STORIES
THAT HAVE COME FROM THE
SURVIVORS AND THINKING OF THE
STORY OF KIANA ALDRICH IT WAS
NOT JUST THAT SHE WAS- SEXUALLY
ABUSED AND THAT SHE WAS
TRAFFICKED. BUT SHE ALSO HAD A
HISTORY OF CHILDHOOD TRAUMA AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
ADVOCATES AND SURVIVORS OF
THESE KINDS OF CRIMES YOU KNOW
WANT TO HAVE NEED TO HAVE AND
DESERVE TO HAVE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO REITERATE THAT THIS BILL.
PROVIDES INFORMATION TO THE
COURTS. SO THAT JUDGES ARE ABLE
TO MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS
AND ARE ABLE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT LED TO THE CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR AND MANY INSTANCES
THAT IS NOT ALLOWED. THE BURDEN
IS STILL AND WILL CONTINUE TO
REMAIN. WITH THE DEFENSE. THE
BURDEN IS STILL ON THE DEFENSE.
AND THE DISCRETION STILL LIES
WITH THE JUDGE IN ALL OF THOSE
THINGS STILL REMAIN. THIS JUST
ALLOWS FOR THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
TO BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
IT KIANA AS STORY. AND
RESENTENCING SHOULD HAVE
ALLOWED THE JUDGE TO RECOGNIZE
AND CONSIDER THE FACT THAT SHE
WAS BOUGHT. THAT SHE WAS BOUGHT
AND THAT SHE WAS USED. AND IT
DOESN'T DENY THE CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR THAT SHE WAS INVOLVED
IN. BUT IT CERTAINLY PLAYS A
ROLE AND WHY THAT BEHAVIOR
HAPPENED AND THAT IS ALL THIS
BILL IS ASKING US TO CONSIDER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU JURORS
RECOMMENDED I WILL CALL THE
ROLL. AB ONE TWENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND CORK.
COURT AYE SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I
SEE OUR TO SEE OUR TURN NOW
WICKS LEE. I'D LI I. MEASURES
ARE CALLED EACH ONE MORE OF IT
JUST BEFORE YOU START- LET ME
NOT A WE HAVE A QUORUM- THE
FOLLOWING. ITEMS ARE OFF
CALENDAR- ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
FOURTEEN FORTY POWER K. HAND TO
CIVIL RIGHTS CRIMES BEEN PULLED
BY COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER FIVE
A. B. NINE THREE NINE CERVANTES
SEX OFFENSES EVIDENCE PULLED BY
AUTHOR. I REMEMBER EIGHT AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE GIPSON YOU'VE
BEEN OUT FACILITIES STORAGE AND
USE OF CHEMICAL AGENTS PULLED
BY AUTHOR. AND AN ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB ELEVEN NINETY THREE.
OUR MAYES RUBIO SOLICITATION OF
PROSTITUTION FROM MINOR POLL BY
FIVE AUTHORED. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE TO PROPOSE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SIX
TWO FIVE ARAMBULA- STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER INDIGENT DEFENSE STUDY
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWELVE FORTY
SEVEN CHAU PROMOTE CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE LIMITATION OF
ACTIONS. AND ITEM ELEVEN AB
SEVEN FIVE- JONES SAWYER CRIMES
PERJURY. ITEM NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB SEVEN SIX
OUT LACKEY PRISONERS FROM
FRICTION RIDGE IMPRESSIONS ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN FIREARMS. AN ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO AB TWELVE TWENTY
FIVE WALDRON THE DIGNITY OF
INCARCERATED WOMEN ACT OF
DIGITAL PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SECOND. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
JONES SAWYER. HI JONES SAWYER I
LACKEY LACKEY I PARA QUE HAN
CORK. COURT I SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I SEE ARE TOO C. OUR
TÁI WICKS WICKS I LI LI I.
AND JUST PART PERSONAL
PROVISIONAL WE WERE HERE BUT
THE COURT HAS MADE A DECISION
IN MINNEAPOLIS ON THE- DEREK
SHOEN TRIAL- HE'S FOUND GUILTY
ON ALL THREE CHARGES SECOND
DEGREE MURDER WHICH HAS A
MAXIMUM OF FORTY YEARS. OF
THIRD DEGREE MURDER MURDER
WHICH HAS A MAXIMUM TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND SECOND DEGREE
MANSLAUGHTER WHICH HAS A
MAXIMUM OF TEN YEARS- AND
GUILTY ON ALL THREE COUNTS YOU
MAY NOW. PRESENT YOUR NEXT BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT INFORMATION
MISTER CHAIR. I WILL NOW
PRESENT AB ONE TWO SEVEN TO
AMEND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PENAL CODE TO PERMIT AN
EMPLOYEE OF A PUBLIC
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE. TO PRESENT
A PROBABLE CAUSE DETERMINATION
TO A JUDGE IN SEEKING AN ARREST
WARRANT IN CASES WHEN THE
SUBJECT IS A PEACE OFFICER. THE
BILL. THE AIM IS TO REDUCE
PROCEDURAL BARRIERS TO POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND ELIMINATE
ONE OF THE BARRIERS FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
INITIATING PROSECUTIONS AGAINST
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. AB
ONE TWO SEVEN WILL CLARIFY THAT
A DECLARATION OF PROBABLE CAUSE
FOR AN ARREST WARRANT NEED NOT
BE PROVIDED ONLY BY A PEACE
OFFICER. THE PROPOSED CHANGE IN
LAW WOULD MAKE NO OTHER CHANGES
TO THE PROCESS OF OBTAINING AN
ARREST WARRANT BEYOND THE
EXPANSION OF POSSIBLE AFGHANS
BEYOND PEACE OFFICERS. IT WOULD
NOT CHANGE A PROBABLE CAUSE
STANDARD OF PROOF AND JUDGES
WOULD STILL RETAIN THE
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE AN ISSUE AN
ARREST WARRANT. AB ONE TWO
SEVEN WILL ENABLE PROSECUTORS
TO ENACT PROSECUTIONS AGAINST
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
REDUCE PROCEDURAL BARRIERS TO
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY WITH ME
AND SUPPORT. IS JUST APPROVED
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVALS READY TO HEAR FROM
THE WITNESS. MR BRITTAIN. THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU CHAIR JONES SAWYER THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU YOU
SAID ABOUT LEADING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY. FOR SERVING AS A
CHAMPION FOR POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY. COMMITTEE
CHANGE IN THIS CRITICAL AREA-
AS WE JUST HEARD- THERE WAS
HISTORY MADE IN MANY REGARDS TO
DAY IN. MINNEAPOLIS IT FACED
THE JUSTICE IN THIS CASE FACED
TREMENDOUS HURDLES PROCEDURAL
HURDLES POLITICAL HURDLE
PRACTICAL HURDLES. AND THE
HOUSE EXAM. IN SAN FRANCISCO
EXISTS ACROSS THE STATE OF CASH
OKAY WHEN THERE ARE ISSUES OF
POLICE USE OF FORCE. AND WHEN
THE PUBLIC DEMANDS POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY. ACTION GREENS
FOR NOT TO THE RIGHT AS WE
REFLECT ON THE OUTCOME OF THE
GEORGE FLOYD CASE AND FOR FAR
TOO MANY OTHERS WHO'VE BEEN
KILLED THE HANDS OF POLICE.
PUBLIC OUTRAGE HAS BEEN CHANNEL.
IT FOR GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
WHEN THIS UNLAWFUL POLICE
VIOLENT. BUT ALL ACCOUNTABILITY
HAS SURGED IT REMAINS RARE FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO INITIATE
PROSECUTIONS AGAINST POLICE
OFFICERS WHO VIOLATE THE LAW
WELL IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY THIS CASE IN MINNEAPOLIS
HAS CAPTURED NATIONAL ATTENTION
THE WAY IT HAS TO RARE. BUT
THESE KILLINGS OF BLACK MEN IS
RARE BUT CRIMINAL CHARGES BEING
BROUGHT IS RARE AND ONE OF THE
OBSTACLES TO PROSECUTION. OF
POLICE OFFICERS IN THESE KINDS
OF CASES USING. ELEMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER TO ASSIST
IN THE INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION. HELLO ONE OF. THIS
CAN LEAD TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS REFUSED. TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY QUESTIONS FOR.
TECHNIQUES TO SUPPORT AN ARREST
WARRANT. AB ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
IS A PRACTICAL SIMPLE AND
NECESSARY CHANGE. IT'S A COMMON
SENSE WAY TO ADDRESS BARRIERS
TO POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY AT A
TIME WHEN OUR COUNTRY IS CLEAN
HERE AND EVER BEEN ON THE NEED
FOR COMPLETE SCALABILITY. CLOSE
TO CHANGING THE LAW DOES NOT
CHANGE IN ANY WAY DOES NOT
CHANGE. BUT THE MAGISTRATE OR
JUDGE IT DOES NOT CHANGE IN ANY
WAY THE LEGAL STANDARD REQUIRED
TO INITIATE A CRIMINAL CASE OR
ARREST WARRANTS. THIS CHANGE
SIMPLY EXPANDS WHO CAN ATTEST
BEFORE JUDGE MAGISTRATE THAT
PROBABLE CAUSE EXISTS CORPORATE
WHEN THE SUBJECT OF THAT ARREST
IS A PEACE OFFICER. IN OTHER
WORDS. ELIMINATES DEFECTIVE
VETO THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS HAVE ON THE ABILITY TO
DOUBLE CLICK THE ATTORNEYS TO
INITIATE. CASES ALLOWING FOR
MORE THAN JUST A PEACE OFFICER
TO A TEST INTERESTING THE
EVIDENCE IN THE CASE. IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
CONSTITUENTS WORK PEACE OFFICER
IS THE SUBJECT OF A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION. UNDER THIS LAW
AS STATED BY SENATOR CALM WATER.
AN EMPLOYEE OF A PUBLIC
PROSECUTOR OFFICE WILL ALSO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SUCH A DECLARATION
OF PROBABLE CAUSE TO A JUDGE.
THERE WERE NOT STE WE- THE POST
CERTIFIED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER. YEP THERE'S PRECEDENT
FROM SEVERAL OTHER STATES FOR
THE PROPOSED CHANGE LAW THERE'S
NINE OTHER STATES THAT ALLOW
PERSONS OTHER THAN A POLICE
OFFICER TO ATTEST. AND ALL
BECAUSE EXISTS FOR THE REST
WERE. THE NINE STATES HAVE SUCH
LAWS INCLUDE. IN NORTH CAROLINA
SOUTH CAROLINA PENNSYLVANIA
MARYLAND OHIO TEXAS VIRGINIA
AND GEORGIA. IN SHORT THIS
CHANGE IS NECESSARY AND IT'S
COMMONSENSE WE'VE SEEN IT WORK
IN A JURISDICTIONS IN IT WE SEE
THAT IT'S- BUT- EXIST IN
CALIFORNIA LAW IF WE COMPARE.
WARRANTS TWO SEARCH WARRANTS
AND SEARCH WARRANTS ALREADY
HAVE SIMILAR PROVISIONS ANY
PERSON WITH KNOWLEDGE OF THE
FACTS. TO PRESENT THAT
INFORMATION TO A MAGISTRATE.
THE REASONS AND FOR THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE NEEDS.
COLLECTED PROSECUTORS TO- BE
ABLE TO INDEPENDENTLY AND
NEUTRALLY EVALUATE THE LEGALITY
OF POLICE USE OF FORCE FIVE
SPOT JOINT AB ONE TWO SEVEN-
DR- OUT TO REDUCE. TO POLICING.
ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR ATTENTION AYE OR DRIVE
OUT. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND- THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. ANY WITNESSES
ON TELECONFERENCING- EIGHTY TWO
YOU MAY OPEN UP THE LINE FOR AB
ONE TWO SEVEN FOUR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION IN IN SUPPORT OF
AB. ONE TWO SEVEN. YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE THREE
HUNDRED. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BANNEKER DONE
ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY COULD
GO PUBLIC DEFENDER AND TO COURT.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS MADISON DO COUGH WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS TERRY ANDERSON DIRECTOR OF
POLICY FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
IMPORTER AND SPONSOR I'M GOING
TO LIST AS NUMBER OF SUPPORTING
AGENCIES WITH THEIR PERMISSION
LARGE LOS ANGELES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY GEORGE GASC GONE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE THE
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND THE
OAKLAND POLICE COMMISSION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CURTIS LANE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE TWO SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU KNOW BRING YOU BACK.
OPPOSITION. I HAVE NONE LISTED
HERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
ANY OPPOSITION OF THE
TELECONFERENCING AGAIN OPERATOR
OR DO ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION YOU MISTER CHAIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT ON THE CASE BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
BEFORE. THE SENATOR. SEEN NONE.
YOU MAY CLOSE. I'M GONNA TAKE A
YEAH MY Q. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CHEERS
RECOMMEND AIBO CALL THE ROLL.
THE BILL HAS BEEN PROPERLY
MOVED AND SECONDED ON AB ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR CALM
UNDER THE MISSION IS TO PATH
JONES SAWYER ALL RIGHT GENSER
IRAQI. LACKEY NOT VOTING POWER
CAN. WORK BURKE I SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I FIGURE TO. THEY ARE TEN
NOT VOTING WICKS WICKS I LI LI
I. THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND- THE RESPECT FOR
THE CHAIR OF BUDGET ROW LARRY
MISTER KING. THANK YOU. MR
SANTIAGO WHO'S PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF MR BONTA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR BROUGHT
I HAVE A TWO BILLS WHAT ONE
WHICH I'M ALSO TAKING OVER FOR
MR BONTA. THE FIRST BILL IS AB
NINE SIXTY THREE MODIFY START
THERE SURE OKAY. FIRST MAJESTIC
THE COMMITTEE IT WILL BE TAKING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AB
NINE SIXTY WILL CREATE A
MEDICAL PAROLE PANEL AT EACH
CDCR PRESIDENT EXPLAINS THE
CRITERIA FOR MEDICAL PAROLE. AS
AMENDED AB NINE SIXTY PROVIDES
MEDICAL PAROLE IF THE MEDICAL
PAROLE PANEL DETERMINES THAT
THE R. COSTA RICA PERSON. NEEDS
HOSPICE CARE HAS THE ABILITY TO
PAIN OR DEBILITATING DISEASES
CHRONOLOGICAL AGE OR
COMBINATION OF THESE. FACTORS
WHILE WE HAVE OVER SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND INMATES. INSIDE CDCR
PRISONS IDENTIFIED AS MEDICALLY
HIGH RISK ONLY A FORTY EIGHT
PEOPLE WERE RELEASED FOR
MEDICAL PAROLE BETWEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
CLEARLY THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT PROCESS TO GET
THROUGH- WE ALSO SPEND A
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
THE INMATES WERE ON MEDICAL
PAROLE THERE ARE SOME OF OUR
MOST EXPENSIVE INDIVIDUALS TO
CARE FOR. US SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WILL STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND WILL ENSURE THAT.
THERE IS A- THE MORE THOUGHTFUL
PROCESS AROUND MEDICAL PAROLE
NOW HAVING SAID THIS THIS BILL
DOES NOT GUARANTEE MEDICAL
PAROLE- BUT INSURERS. THAT
MEDICAL PAROLE PANEL WILL
INCLUDE THE PATIENT'S PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN THE CIVIL
SERVICE PSYCHOLOGIST OR SOCIAL
WORKER AND THE DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES- I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- DR RONALD LEWIS AS
WELL AS- KELLY SAVAGE RODRIGUEZ.
YES WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWED ME THE
TIME TO SPEAK QUICKLY ON
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SIXTY I'M
ALSO VICE PRESIDENT OF THE U.
A. P. WHICH IS A CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL- MY NAME IS. DR RON
LEWIS AND I WAS EMPLOYED BY
FIFTY EIGHT THE EIGHTH FOR TEN
YEARS THAT ARE WITH STATE
PRISONS SOME VERY FAMILIAR.
WITH THE- CURRENT PRACTICE OF
MEDICAL PAROLE. BUT FIRST
CONTROL CURRENT WHO NOT SERVING
CARTS RATED PEOPLE IN THE WAY
TO JUSTIFY THE INTENDED. THE
CONFIGURATION PROCESS IS IN
EFFECT IN THE TAKES TAKES FAR
TOO LONG AND INVOLVED MULTIPLE
STEPS. AND IT SENATORS MAINLY
IN THE COUNTRYSIDE OF THAT
INSTITUTION RATHER THAN HAVING
MORE INVOLVEMENT OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO UNDERSTAND
IMPACT OF THAT PARTICULAR-
ELEMENTS ON THE BODY. AB NINE
SIXTY WOULD AUTHORIZE. AS
CHESTER STATED CREATION OF
MEDICAL PAROLE PANEL EACH
INSTITUTION CONSISTING OF THE
INCARCERATED. PERSONS AIR CARE
POSITION BUT SEVERAL THANK HOW
FOR EMMA VIEW AND A MEDICAL
WERE. OR FOR TO- FROM D. C. R.
T. C. A. THE. HELP YOUR BILL
YOUR CALL LIMITED AND- BETWEEN-
CHEF STATED BETWEEN TO THE
SEVENTEEN AND I ARE. EIGHT
PEOPLE WERE GRANTED MEDICAL
PAROLE EVEN THOUGH. SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND ARE TERRIFIED THAT
MEDICALLY HIGH RISK. EIGHTY
NINE SIXTY WOULD EXPAND THE
MEDICAL PAROLE SO BOTH OF THOSE
CONSERVE PASTAS CARE AND THOSE
ARE EXPERIENCING DELIVER-
DEBILITATING PAIN CAN'T BE
ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE AND
THERE'S REFERENCES IN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE THAT OUTLINED- PLEASE OF.
AND WHAT CAN- QUALIFY FOR
DEBILITATING PAIN- AND HARKLESS
CARE AT THIS EARLY INCARCERATED
SICK AND ELDERLY PEOPLE ARE
COSTLY. WE SPEND EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY TWO
THOUSAND EACH INCARCERATED
PERSON OF WHICH TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND IS SPENT ON USUAL
MEDICAL COSTS NOT HIçN
BECAUSE WITH THE USUAL DAY TO
DAY ROUTINE OF TAKING CARE OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. IF TWENTY
ARE RELEASED UNDER. THE SPELL
DURING THE FIRST YEAR. ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION COULD BE
SAFER CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. THE
NUMBER YOU CAN BE HIGHER GIVEN
THAT TYPICALLY COST MORE CARE
FOR INCARCERATED ELDERLY AND
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE PEOPLE. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE HI ALL A. B.
NINE SIXTY AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND ALLOW ME TO SPEAK
FOR THE FIRT TIME PRESENTER.
THANK YOU. MANGAVERSE RODRIGUEZ.
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY MY NAME IS KELLY
SAVAGE RODRIGUEZ AND I'M AND
FORMER INCARCERATED PERSON AND
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
I AM PROUD CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
NINE SIXTY I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A NEW COPY
NINE FIFTY BECAUSE IT EXPANDS
AND IMPROVES THE MEDICAL PRO
PROCESS. MULLIN CHRO SURE DID I
VOLUNTEERED MY TIME IN THE NEXT
IN THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
I PROVIDED CARE AND COMFORT TEN
PERFORATED INDIVIDUALS AT THE
END OF THEIR LIFE- I.
PERSONALLY WITNESSED THE
FAILURE OF THE PROCESS DESIGNED
TO PROVIDE RELIEF FOR MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS I HAVE
SEEN PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR RELEASE PASSED AWAY IN
PERSON. BECAUSE THE CAN.
PROCESS IS UNNECESSARILY
LENGTHY AND IT REQUIRES THE
APPROVAL OF TOO MANY
DEPARTMENTS THAT DON'T HAVE THE
MEDICAL EXPERTISE. I KNOW THAT
AND- THERE ARE MANY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO
STRUGGLE WITH DAILY TASKS. FOR
EXAMPLE AS BRUSHING THEIR HAIR
MAKING CUPS OF COFFEE MOVING
AROUND IN THEIR WHEELCHAIRS-
WALKERS CANES WHATEVER IT MAY
BE. THINK ABOUT TIMES WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO- SEND A LETTER
OR AN EMAIL TO SOMEONE AND
SOMETHING SO BASIC AND PERSONAL
CANNOT BE DONE ON YOUR OWN IT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO THINK
OF THOSE LITTLE. THINGS THAT
AFFECT OUR DAILY LIVES AND
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
ARE DEALING WITH AND FIVE ON A
DAILY BASIS WHO CAN'T GET THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED. MANY WHO
ARE AT THE END OF THEIR LIFE. I
THINK IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO MENTION THAT WE HAVE LOST.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE VALUABLE
HUMAN BEINGS TO THE COVER
NINETY- COMMITTEE. AT THE
DAMAGE AND- THE STATE HAS
FAILED TO PROVIDE ADEQUATELY
FOR THOSE PEOPLE I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES FOR AB NINE SIXTY
BECAUSE THE CURRENT MEDICAL PRO
PROCESS IS BROKEN IT IT LACKS
TRANSPARENCY IT D. PRIORITIZES
THE EXPERTISE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA IT'S HARD
TO ELIMINATE TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE RELIEF FROM MEDICAL
VIABLE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE TREATMENT IN A
DIGNIFIED MANNER SURROUNDED BY
INDIVIDUALS THAT CARE ABOUT
THEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION ON
THIS MATTER. THANK YOU. NOTRE
ANY OTHER IN IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE SIXTY BONTA. AT C. NOT IN
THE ROOM ANY ON THE
TELECONFERENCING. C. NONE AT&T
OPERATOR MAY OPEN UP TO AB NINE
SIXTY BONTA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. LINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON BEING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MY NAME IS KAREN MCDANIEL AND I
AM THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PLACE FOR GRACE.
AT THE PART OF MY DUTIES AT
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDER NAME AN
ORGANIZATION I'M SORRY. IT'S
JUST A MINUTE WE ARE HAD. SO
RIGHT NOW. CARAMEL YES TERRY
MCDANIEL WITH A SEPARATE. DAVID
ORGANIZATION NINE THREE
EIGHTEEN OKAY OKAY NINE THREE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS. SERRA
WRITTEN ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE A COCKROACH SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
VATICAN TO COUGH WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE THREE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FIFTY YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD OF. NINE THREE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME ONLY
CRANK I'M FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA NINE. EIGHTY NINE.
YOU. NINE TO EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MINUS COAL
QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL. NINE
SIX ZERO. NINE THREE SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS COREY
TAYLOR ON WITH THE YOUNG ONES
FREEDOM CENTER AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETY SIXTY.
THANK YOU. IN THREE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE TWENTY TWO YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NINE THREE HUNDRED.
CANACCORD ARE NOT ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS. THEY'RE NOT
ENROLLED CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE THREE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS NICOLE
KRAMER FOR ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE VISIT COULD BE A
RIGHT FOR THE BOTH OF US AND
ORDER IMPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
NINETY. NINE TO SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY TO SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. UNTIL.
NINE THREE FIFTY NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD OH SORRY THEY
DIDN'T GIVE US A Q. NUMBER HI
MY NAME WITH MATH SCORES AND
THEY WERE POLICY FOR NADER AT
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER.
NINE THREE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES
MY NAME IS GINA HERNANDEZ AND I
AM CALLING IN FOR SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY NINE NINETY. YEAH NINE
THREE TWENTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE S.
FUNDING AS WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION COLIN IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET READY FOR
CALIFORNIA. NINE THREE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON WORK OF
GEORGIA ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND FOR. NINE THREE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHRIS. CALLING FROM STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA NINE I AM IN SUPPORT
OF. EIGHTY NINE NINE. NINE
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
VICTORIA FROM LOS ANGELES WITH
PRIDE INSURANCE AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE NINETY. THIS IS.
THE SIXTY BONTA NINE SIX ZERO.
IN SUPPORT. NINE THREE SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIX THIS IS A LITTLE
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE THREE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE NO LONGER HAVE TO EIGHTY
NINE IN Q. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE ON THE WITNESS LIST
UP WHO. GO TO ANYONE IN A ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. C. NONE ANYONE
ON A TELECONFERENCE. SEEING
NONE NOW OPERATOR GOING TO
OPPOSITION FOUR A. B. NINE SIX
ZERO BONTA. OPPOSITION YOU
MISTER CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE
SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU SEE
AND THEN BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANYONE WITH ANY
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS TO MR CORK
AFTER. OKAY I'M HOPING
ANOMALOUS THIS YOU'RE NOT THE
AUTHORED THIS BILL SO. BUT
MAYBE YOU COULD JUST SATISFY MY
CURIOSITY- CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW
SIGNIFICANT A MEDICAL CONDITION
MUST BE TO QUALIFY FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT THEY USE THE TERM
DEBILITATING DISEASE ORINDA
MILITATING PAIN. THAT SEEMS
RATHER VAGUE FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS QUALIFY.
LET LET ME ASK DR LOUIS TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION TALK TO
THOSE SYSTEM PHONE. YES I AM I
THOUGHT I'D LOOK AT. THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THAT
INCARCERATED PERSON- OKAY ROOMS
ARTHRITIS BUT IF THAT ARE
TOWARDS KIDS TO THE POINT WHERE
THE ADL'S THE- OR IMPACTED THEN
I WOULDN'T- THAT DEVOTE PAYING
ARE INCAPACITATING. SO YOU HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE RANGE OF WEATHER
THAT THE CURSOR PERSON CAN
ACTUALLY FUNCTION WITH THIRD
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING A.
D. L. DOES THAT HELP YOU WERE.
WHILE MEET YOU CAN ADD- BUT
STILL SEEMS QUITE THEY ARE.
IT'S GOING TO REMAIN VAGUE-
YEAH WELL ON THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH SAFETY CO THERE ALSO
OUTLINED SOME OF THESE-
SITUATIONS AND I THINK THE BILL
REFERENCES THAT SO- BUT I THINK
THERE ARE GOING TO BE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS TO FINE TUNE- YOUR
CONCERN. MAYBE OTHERS OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A LOT OF
WORK YOU HAD A CALL. I'M IN THE
ANALYSIS IT SEEMS VERY CLEAR TO
ME THAT THIS IS FOR PEOPLE WHO
REALLY CAN'T GET AROUND AND DO
THINGS FOR THEMSELVES SO IT
SEEMS CLEAR TO ME BUT IF THERE
CAN BE- CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
IT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL- SO I WILL
MOVE THE BILL. HOW DO WE
GUARANTEE THAT THESE FOLKS WHO
OBVIOUSLY NEED A LOT OF HELP
WILL GET THAT HELP ON WHEN THEY
GET OUT DO YOU HAVE ANY.
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT IS THE POLICY
OF DOCTOR LEWIS DOES I HAVE
SOME SOME IDEAS BALLOT THIS
YEAR DR LEWIS AS A- SALES. YEAH
I'M HERE SPELL- GLAD TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION- THERE ARE A HALF
WAY HOUSE. OUT IN THE
COMMUNITIES. WHERE IT'S- ALMOST
LIKE THAT SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY OR BOARD AND CARE AND
WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH. THAT
TERM- AND- THEY WOULD GET THEIR-
TREATMENT IN THOSE FACILITIES
WITH A STAFF. PHYSICIAN
MONITORING AND SPEARHEADING
CONSULTATION- FOR THAT
INCARCERATED PERSON RIGHT NOW I
THINK THERE'S ONLY SEVEN THERE
EIGHT OF THEM IN CALIFORNIA YOU
CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT
THERE WOULD NEED TO BE MORE AND
THEY WOULD NEED TO BE STAFFED
APPROPRIATELY TO DEAL WITH
THOSE INDIVIDUAL PRODUCT FOR
HER HEART WOULD THEN GO TO A
BORN CARE FOR- END OF LIFE-
CARE- THANK IS THAT HOLDEN.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A JOB FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU. WELCOME
I'M NOT I WOULD JUST ADDS THAT
SPECIFICALLY THAT- DID THIS
COULD BE POTENTIALLY IF THERE
WERE MORE. PEOPLE PUT ON
MEDICAL PAROLE GOOD- ENGENDER
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS FOR US
LIKE AGAIN- THE INMATES WHO
RECEIVE MEDICAL CARE HIGH LEVEL
MEDICAL CARE ARE BY FAR THE
MOST EXPENSIVE INMATES-
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. IF THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS PROLIFIC ALSO GO
ON TO. MEDICARE SO IT ACTUALLY
WOULD SAY THE STATE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE MONEY TO BE
ON HEALTHCARE AND BECAUSE THEY-
YEAH I DOES THE ASSUMPTION
WOULD BE THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO FUNCTION WITHOUT MEDICAL
CARE. THEY DON'T REALLY SERVE
MUCH OF A RISK IN TERMS OF- RE
OFFENDING OR- YEAH PUBLISHED BY
HAVE HAVING A PUBLIC SAFETY
RISK. AND THANK ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTER TODD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON A. B.
NINE SIXTY. THANK YOU NINETY WE
COULD DISCUSS THIS THIS THIS
PROBLEM FOR QUITE SOME TIME BUT
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE IN
PRES PRISON WHO DON'T. WHO ARE
NOT A RISK TO SOCIETY AND NEED
SPECIAL CARE THAT WE COULD MOVE
OFF REALLY OFF THE STATE.
BUDGET AND BE ABLE TO BE. TAKEN
CARE OF ON A FEDERAL BUDGET
SAVING. TAXPAYERS MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
CALDERON ON AB NINE SIXTY AT BY
SOME MEMBER TEAM BY MR BONTA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
MEDITERRANEAN'S COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI.
LATINO BARRICADE HAND BARRICADE
HAD AYE QUIRK. I SANTIAGO THEY
ARE TEN OUT THERE TO KNOW WICKS
WICKS HI LI LI I. THE MEASURE
PASSES ARE YOU MAY GO TO YOUR
BILL THANK YOU SO I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE TEN FIFTY
TWELVE TEN HOURS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS ACTUALLY CREATE SEATS
IN THE FINE- THAT. THE REQUIRED
AT LEAST TEN THE COMMISSIONERS
ON THE PAROLE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS COME FROM A VARIETY OF
PROFESSIONS CURRENTLY OF THE
SEVENTEEN FULL TIME
COMMISSIONERS THERE ARE NO.
MANDATES AROUND PROFESSIONAL
EXPERTISE- MOST OF THE MEMBERS
ALMOST ALL THE MEMBERS COME
FROM A LAW ENFORCEMENT
BACKGROUNDS- THE DALLAS MEANS
THAT OTHER BACKGROUNDS AREN'T
INCLUDED SO THE BACKGROUNDS WE
ARE ASKING TO BE INCLUDED THAT
REQUIRE THAT AT LEAST TEN
COMMISSIONERS ON THE BOARD COME
FROM THESE BACKGROUNDS THAT
WOULD BE A MEDICAL DOCTOR WITH
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
GERIATRIC PATIENTS.
PSYCHOLOGISTS OR PSYCHIATRISTS
WAS EXPERIENCING CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA SOCIAL WORKER OR DRUG
TREATMENT COUNSELOR THE
PERSON'S WORK IN THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY REENTRY SERVICES AN
ATTORNEY WHO'S REPRESENTED
INDIVIDUALS FACING DEPORTATION
THE PURE COUNSELOR- WAS
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE WORKING
WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE THE
TRANSGENDER GENDER
NONCONFORMING. INDIVIDUALS BEEN
RELEASED FROM A LIFE SENTENCE
THROUGH CALIFORNIA'S
DISCRETIONARY PAROLE PROCESS SO
THAT JUST GIVES YOU A SENSE OF-
HARD OUR DESIRE TO ADD SOME
PROFESSIONAL GUIDELINES TO THE-
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
TWENTY B. TWELVE TEN WE HAVE A
WITNESSES JULIE HARRIS DIRECTOR
OF CLINICAL SUPPORT AT ON
COMMON LAW AND- JOE HANCOCK A
FORMER ON COMMON LAW CLIENT IN
CURRENT SITE SUPPORT SPECIALIST
AT A HOMELESS. ENCAMPMENT.
THROUGH FAMILY BRIDGES AND
OAKLAND. YOU WOULD MAYBE WHEN A-
YOU'RE READY. YES EACH YEAR A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN SAWYER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JOE HANCOCK I WAS SERVED THE
OAK TREE COMMITTEE CABINS
HOMELESS AND CAME AS A SITE
SUPPORT SPECIALIST I AM
FORMERLY INCARCERATED. AND WAS
RELEASED FROM STATE PRISON TO
DISCRETIONARY PAROLE PROCESS
ABOUT SIX MONTHS SIX MONTHS AGO
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT AB TWELVE PM WHICH
REQUIRE THE COMMISSIONERS ON
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
TO. HAVE MORE DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS THAT ARE RELEVANT
TO ASSIST THE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE'S READINESS FOR RELEASE
FOLLOWED CALIFORNIA COMICAL
DIRECTS THE BOARD TO NORMALLY
GRAPPLE ROLE ONLY 60% OF THE
SCHEDULE CRONIN'S EVERY LITTLE
BIT IN PROGRAMS IN THE PAST
FOUR YEARS. 84% OF APPLICANTS
DENIED. DAVID IS. KEY WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE. BOTTOM EVEN
THOUGH THIS NOT A STATE LAW
INCOME. WITH RESEARCH. THAT
PROBABLY BY THE VERY INSTITUTE
OF JUSTICE ADVOCATE BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER OTHER RESPECTED
RESOURCES. OR SOURCES THAT'S
MATCHING COURSE IS NOT KEEPING
SAFE FROM. AB WOULD REQUIRE THE
FULL ACROSS PERSON BE APPOINTED
TO THE BILL. IT SEEMS FOR ME
BECAUSE RAY IS NEW UNIT
POSITION UNDER WHAT ALREADY
THIS LOOKS LIKE. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE ALREADY GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS. I KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE.
THE PERFECT EXCUSE ME THEY KNOW
WHAT IT IS LIKE TO PROCESS
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA WITHIN ON FROM
THE PRISON ENVIRONMENT. IT CAN
ABILITY TO PASS FARMS TO THE
PAID HOURS A POSITIVE PROGRAM
WE CONNECT ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEW
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS NOTABLY
TRANSFORM THEIR LIVES. ONLY OF
COURSE RATED PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
REHABILITATION LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE THEY EXPERIENCE IT
THEMSELVES THEY SEATED AMONG
MANY OTHERS AND THEIR
COMMUNITY. FORMER WARDENS AND
OTHER CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS MAY
HAVE UNIQUE INSIGHTS ABOUT THE
PRO APPLICANTS GROPED AND
RATINGS WERE RELEASED. LAW
ENFORCEMENT APPOINTEES WHO DO
NOT WORK IN THE COURSE RATED
PEOPLE OFTEN ASK MAKE PUBLIC
SAFETY DECISIONS BASED ON
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT THEY MAY
NOT FULLY UNDERSTAND. THERE ARE
SEVENTY. BORK AND BILL WOULD
ARE A PATHWAY TO MORE ME TO. MY
REQUIRING THAT TEN OF THEM HAVE
MORE DIVERSE PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUNDS- YOUR VOTE YES ON
AB TWELVE DIDN'T BECAUSE
DISCRETIONARY PAROLE PROCESS
NEEDS TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE.
HIS BILL IS A SMALL STEP. BUT
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT WHAT MAKES
CUTS IMPORTANT DECISIONS.
SHOULD MORE ACCURATELY REFLECT
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION. THIS
MEANS MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
WORKERS DOCTORS PEER COUNSELORS
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE I
WOULD EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIN PREJUDICE
IN THIS IMPORTANT BILL I
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU. WHAT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JULIE HALF AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF CLINICAL SUPPORT ON
COMMON LAW I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TEN
A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
SINCE THE PAPER STRANGE
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND. AB
TWELVE TIME WILL REQUIRE THE
APPOINTMENT OF COMMISSIONERS TO
COME FROM PROFESSIONALS THAT
INCLUDES SOCIAL WORK MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
COMMUNITY REENTRY SERVICES AND
MARK. I'M A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AND I'VE SPENT
THE PAST FIVE YEARS SUPPORTING
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES BEFORE THAT. I WORKED
FOR OVER A DECADE WITH CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND TANGLED IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH FOSTER CARE AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE WITH. WE ALL
HAVE AT LEAST ONE THING IN
COMMON. I'M NOT A PROBLEM.
TRUMP IS PRACTICALLY UNIVERSAL
MONTH BECAUSE YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WELL DOCUMENTED TO HAVE
EXPERIENCED ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES OR ETHERNET. AT
HIGHER RATES THAN THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. AFTER 67% OF REQUESTED
OF 97% OF INCARCERATED WOMEN.
I'M NOT. UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPACT OF THE- HOW OFTEN HERE
WE DO PATTERN OR OF INSTRUCTOR
IN BASED THE OUR IS CRUCIAL TO
FORMULATE ANY KIND OF. I HOW
LONG THE DISCRETIONARY FOR
PROFIT AT CLIENTS ALL OVER TO
RETURN TO THE COMMUNITY. THE
TONIGHT COULD CALL
COMMISSIONERS DIDN'T UNDER THE-
OF BUT THEY FACED A CHANCE
PERFORMED FONG STREET AT. OFTEN
SHOWS UP WITH SOME COMMITTEE
TEND CALL BLACK OF INFO. WHICH
APPEARS BE BASED ON IN POT
REACTS IF THEY ARE. WITH THE
PERSON YOU KNOW. NO WAY VERSED
IN THE FACT COM FROM
FUNCTIONING OF BEHAVIOR IT
WOULD BE BECAUSE I DON'T CHIU.
ME YEAH AND PROTECT THE PERSON
POTENTIAL LEVEL FUNCTIONING IN
THE- IT IS CONCERNING TO ME
THAT THE BOARD OF OVER ONE.
WERE BY ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
BECAUSE I HAVE THEM MAKE. BASED
ON FACTORS THAT I DO NOT
BELIEVE THERE- YOU TO VOTE YES
EIGHT TALKED BECAUSE EIGHTY
MEMBERS SOCIAL. DOCTORS AND NOT
HEALTH. I THINK THAT NOT. LIFE
WITH PEOPLE SUCH FROM THE OF
TRAUMA. HI INVESTED IN THE
SOCIETY. EXPELLED HOW THEM MAKE
A PART DECISION A BE INCLUDED
IN THIS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME OKAY. THANK YOU ARE ANY.
ANYONE ROOM FORTY TWO AND
SUPPORT. OPERATOR YOU MAY NOW
GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINES FOR
FOUR SUPPORTER. POINT AB TWELVE
TEN. THANK YOU MAY CHAIR AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
QUESTION OR COMMENT COMES FROM
MINE. THREE FIFTY SIX LINE
THREE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
HAPPENED NEXT DOCTOR SMART AT
THE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE
THREE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY'RE
MAKING ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND ON COMMON LAW IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THREE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS TINA BROWN FROM SAN
JOSE AND I AM AN IMPACTED
FAMILY MEMBER IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWELVE TEN. NINE THREE NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MAYOR
CLARK THEY WANT POLICY
COORDINATOR ACT CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR EXAMPLE BY DAY
FOLLOWING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE SEVENTY SIX
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EDUARDO
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE THREE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS TRINA IN YOU GUYS
FROM HELLO CALIFORNIA AND A
PART OF AB TOPCON. NINE FOUR
ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
SOPHIA MAHONEY CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE ABOLITION WORKING
GROUP OF SUNRISE AREA LOOKING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EASY TALK ON.
NINE THREE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
STELLAR CALLING OUT A SYSTEM
IMPACT THEIR FAMILY MEMBER FROM
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TEN. NINE
THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD ON
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN SUPPORT.
NINE THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
PONDERED AS OF THE AFTER THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO MY NAME IS MARY MORENO
I'M IMPACTED- CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENT IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MUCH NEEDED CHANGE
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GINA
HERNANDEZ- WITH FUEL DROP I'LL
OFTEN INITIATE JUSTICE AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB TOUGHEST. MINE
FOR TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE GENTLEMAN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THREE
SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM TO FOUR
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS THE NAY THE HARDWOOD SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG AND WORD STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TEN THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS KAREN MCDANIEL
REPRESENTING THE PLATES ARE
GREAT AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE TEN THANK YOU. AND
ONE MOMENT FOR A LAST LINE TO
BE GATHERED. NINE FOUR TWELVE
YOUR MIND PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FOUR TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EILEEN COLLINS ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE TEN. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. NOT ANY I DON'T SEE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- SO
GO TO ROOM TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE- MAY GO TO LINE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE
AB TWELVE TENTED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
MISSED POWER K. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER KING SO. I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE CAN
OBVIOUSLY AS THE POLICY MAKING
BODY MAKE THIS POLICY UNTIL THE
GOVERNOR WHO TO PUT ON THIS
COMMISSION BUT CURRENTLY HE
COULD. CREATE A BORDER PATROL
THAT IS MADE UP OF THIS. THESE
PEOPLE RIGHT IT'S DISCRETIONARY
THIS TIME SO ANY UNDERSTANDING
OF WHY. THE WHO MY
UNDERSTANDING I GUESS RENOUNCES
IS CURRENTLY THE BORDER ROLES
IS PROMINENTLY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND WHY WE DON'T HAVE A MORE
DIVERSE MAKE UP MINISTRATION- I
ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW WHY. THAT
IS I JUST I JUST TO
HISTORICALLY THAT HAS BEEN THE
CASE I DON'T KNOW IF- MISS
HARRIS HAS ANY. HYPOTHESIS BUT
I HAVEN'T SPOKEN TO THE
GOVERNOR OR TALK TO THE
PREVIOUS GOVERNOR ABOUT WHY
THAT WHY THAT WAS THE CASE. SO
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS HAS HAS
ANY- MORE INFORMATION ABOUT. I
DON'T BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
RESEARCH THAT AND GET BACK TO
YOUR OFFICE WITH FOLLOW UP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YOU MAY
CLOSE MISTREATING I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
AB TWELVE TO. AND DO IT DO WE
GET A MOTION. SECOND. AND AB
TWELE TEN TWELVE TEN EXCUSE ME
BY SEVEN MEMBER TEAM THE MOTION
IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER BY
CHANCER IRAQI LACKEY NO POWER
CAN. CORK I SAN DIEGO C. R. TO
SAY OUR TURN NOW WICKS WICKS I
LI LI I. QUALITY MEASURES ARE
CALL ME TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
IF YOU. SO WE NOW HAVE. WHILE
WAITING FOR PEOPLE TO TESTIFY
GETTING WITH- IT WOULD BE BONTA
BUT I BELIEVE MR SANTIAGO'S
WILL BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
BONTA A. B. NINE NINE ZERO- MR
GABRIEL AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR YOU'RE NOW UP AFTER THAT
IS AB TEN OH THREE LORENA
GONZALEZ- THEN WE HAVE- AB
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR LEVINE- A.
B. ELEVEN NINETY ONE MCCARTY.
A. B. FIVE FIVE SEVEN
MURATSUCHI. AND IF THEY'RE NOT
HERE PURELY SOON. THEN AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT MR LEE WILL
I WILL GO AFTER HIM AB NINETY
FOUR. OKAY. YEAH.
AS. LATEST
NEWS. HELLO. WE'RE WE'RE
WAITING FOR ANOTHER PRESENTER
FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
WHILE WE
WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO- TO
COME TO PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WILL ALLOW ALLOW AB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT MISTER LEE
SUPERVISED PERSONS RELEASE-
MAKE A PRESENTATION.ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY TEAM
ON OUR LANGUAGE AND GLADLY
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE OF THEM
IT'S PRESENTED TODAY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT SEEKS
TO ESTABLISH A PROCEDURE TO
RELEASE INDIVIDUALS FROM
DETENTION THAT ONLY FACE A
VIOLATION OF PROBATION.
TYPICALLY WHEN YOU ARRESTED AND
CHARGED WITH A CRIME YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO SOME FORM OF PRE
TRIAL RELEASE HOWEVER THIS IS
NOT THE CASE WHEN IT COMES
INDIVIDUALS ARRESTED FOR A
PROBATION VIOLATION OF THE BILL
THANK YOU AS NOTED IN ALICE'S
EXISTING LAWS NOT CLEAR ON
WHETHER OR NOT A PERSON IS
DETAINED FOLLOWING ALLEGATION
OF VIOLATING THEIR PROBATION
HAS A RIGHT TO BAIL AND OPTIONS
FOR LEASE OR NOT DESCRIBED
PROBATION CURRENTLY OPERATES
UNDER A SEPARATE LEGAL SYSTEM
ONE WHERE BASIC CIVIL RIGHTS
LIKE THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE BE DETENTION HEARINGS
AND BURDEN OF PROOF. BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT ARE
DISREGARDED THIS BILL SIX
ADDRESSED THE ISSUE BY
DIRECTING THE COURT TO RELEASE
PEOPLE DETAINED ON A VIOLATION
OF THE PROBATION UNLESS THEY
FIND THAT INDIVIDUAL WOULD POSE
A THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY ORDER
TURN INTO THEIR FLIGHT RISK. AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT ALSO ALIGNS
WITH THE MOST RECENT HUMPHREY'S
DECISION BY THE SUPREME COURT
IN STATES THAT IF BAIL IS SET.
IT MUST BE SET AT A LEVEL
PERSON CAN REASONABLY AFFORD WE
MUST UPHOLD ALL CORNERSTONES OF
A SUPPLY SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
INCLUDING ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
KEEPING SOMEONE DETAINED SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ECONOMIC MEANS TO BE RELEASED
IS DISCRIMINATORY. SUSTAINS A
LEGAL SYSTEM THAT BENEFITS THE
WEALTHY WHILE MARGINALIZING THE
POOR. PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCUSED OF
WRONGDOING SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
HAVE THE OPTION TO CONTINUE
THEIR LIVES OUTSIDE DETENTION
UNTIL COURT CAN APPROPRIATELY
DETERMINE WHETHER VIOLATIONS
OCCURRED. AND WHAT IF ANY
ADDITIONAL PROBATION TERMS ARE
NECESSARY SO I ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT ME. I
SUPPORT THIS RESORT FORM TO
UPHOLD THE CORNERSTONE OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH
IS THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY WITNESSES SUPPORT
DAVID BRIGGS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE THANK YOU. YOU
MAY BEGIN MISTER BRIGGS
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON- YES MY NAME
IS DAVID BRIGGS AND I'M THE CO
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
HI WE ARE A SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL- I'VE BEEN PRACTICING LAW
FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS NOW AND
ALMOST ALL OF THAT DO IN
CRIMINAL DEFENSE WORK- AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT. WOULD MAKE
MUCH NEEDED IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
WAY CALIFORNIA COURTS HANDLE
ALLEGATIONS THAT A PERSON HAS
VIOLATED PROBATION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
PROBATIONERS ARE PEOPLE A JUDGE
HAS DETERMINED DESERVE TO BE
RELEASED INTO SOCIETY DESPITE
HAVING COMMITTED A CRIME.
GENERALLY THE CRIMES INVOLVED-
ARE MISDEMEANORS AND- FELONS.
PROBATION IMPOSES CONDITIONS
INTENDED TO REHABILITATE THE
PROBATIONER SUCH AS DRUG
TESTING FAMILY COUNSELING AND
REPORTING TO A PROBATION
OFFICER. HOWEVER OF
PROBATIONERS LIFE CAN BE
DIFFICULT AND PROBATIONERS NOT
INFREQUENTLY VIOLATE THE
CONDITIONS OF THEIR PROBATION.
VIOLATIONS CAN BE RELATIVELY
MINOR SUCH AS MISSING A
SCHEDULED APPOINTMENT WITH THE
PROBATION OFFICER OR THEY CAN
BE SEVERE SUCH AS COMMISSION OF
A NEW CRIME. AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT DOES NOT DEAL WITH NEW
CARS IN WHICH THERE'S A RIGHT
TO SPEEDY TRIAL BY A JURY. AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT ADDRESSES
PROBATION VIOLATIONS WERE
THERE'S NO RIGHT TO A JURY
TRIAL. NICK IS A BOILING
PROVISION CAN CONTEST THE
CHARGE ONLY IN A NON JURY
HEARING. AND THERE'S NO FIRM
LIMóN ON HOW LONG THE PERSON
MOSTLY FROM THE STEERING.
CURRENTLY NO BAIL PROBATION
HOLDS ARE THE STANDARD
PROCEDURE BECAUSE SO MANY CASES
IN COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND ARE COMMON IN
MISDEMEANOR CASES ALSO. PLEASE
NOTE BILL HOLDS FORCED
PROBATIONERS INTO JAIL FOR
WEEKS OR EVEN MONTHS ON
UNPROVED CHARGES. THEY FAIL TO
CONSIDER THE DEGREE TO WHICH
INCARCERATION WILL INTERFERE
WITH THE WITH THE PROBATIONERS
REHABILITATION. AND A TECHNO
CAL THE SEVERITY OF THE ALLEGED
VIOLATION. SO AB TWO ALTERNATE
WOULD REPLACE THE SYSTEM WITH
WILL FUND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
MENTION THAT IS BECAUSE BASED
ON THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT'S RECENT DECISION IN. IN
RE HOME CORRECT. IT WOULD BE IN
MOST CASES IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT IF ANY BILL'S GOING TO BE
SET IF YOU SET AN AMOUNT THE
PROBATIONER CAN REASONABLY
AFFORD. I THOUGHT IT WOULD
REQUIRE JUDGES PROBATION OUT OF
GUILT FOR THE HEARING. UNLESS
JAIL THE ONLY MEASURE WHICH
WOULD REASONABLY PROTECT PUBLIC
AND REASONABLE YOU'RE SURE OF
THE PERSON'S APPEARANCE IN
COURT. SO AB TO OPEN IT WOULD
KEEP REPLACEMENT HOME WITH
THEIR FAMILIES WORKING AT THEIR
JOBS AND PARTICIPATING IN THE
DRUG TREATMENT PROGRAMS. START
URGE YOU TO FOR THE
REHABILITATION OF PROBATIONERS
BY HOLDING ON. ON AB TWELVE
TWENTY. THANK YOU I SEE NO
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT-
I'LL BRING IT TO ROOM OR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND CNN
I'LL BRING IT TO THE- TO THE
TELEPHONE LINE ON AB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT LEAD. WHAT THIS IS
A SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS SERRA REGNI ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FOUR TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THE NAME THAT
HARDWOOD SILICON VALLEY DE BUG
AND WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXAVAR LINE OF THREE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TOOK A LINE OF TWO SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER GIVEN
THE ANTI DIMARTINO IN STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT
OF A LINE OF FOUR TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HAPPY SHARE OR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. CUNAXA GOAL LINE OF
THREE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT THREE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
FORTY TAYLOR FROM THE YOUNG
WOMAN STREET IN CENTER AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. NXR
CODE SO LINE OF THREE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT GOING TO
SIT AND PRACTICE FAMILY MEMBER
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
NEXT SO GO TO LINE OF THREE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
THREE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DO YOU HAVE A THOUGHT MUTE.
LOCAL ONE THIRTY THREE NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS WITH MAYOR FLORENCE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET CALLING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CANACCORD ARM ON THE HALF
OF THE CAMPAIGN FISCAL PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NEXT TO A PHOTO LINE OF
FOUR OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FOUR ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU-
MARY MORENO AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB TWELVE WE ARE
HERE BY AB TWENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THREE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GO AHEAD
PLEASE HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
FIGURE OUT ON I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF- A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT
FINAL COME FROM POOR THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
FILAMENTOUS WOULD RESTORE
JUSTICE- CALLING ON TRUMP
SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
ARE. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
I'M SITTING FRONT AND IN
OPPOSITION. IN NEW ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN A
ROW. I WILL GO TO TELEPHONE
LINES IF THERE ANY OPPOSITION
TO AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT LEE
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT LEE. A TEAR
IN OPPOSITION OF AB. TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FEAR IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE THEM- NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE YOU MAY
CLOSE PERSONALLY RESPECTFULLY
ASK DRIVE UP. THE JURORS
RECOMMEND I VOTE MAY CALL THE
ROLL. I'M AT TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME MEMBERS LEAD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY. BAUER-KAHAN QUIRK QUIRK
I SANTIAGO THEY ARE TO SAY ARE
TO KNOW WICKS WICKS I LEE LEE I.
THE MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS
ONE NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ. L. B. A. B. TEN OH
THREE WAIT STAFF GRANT THAT.
THANK YOU. GLAD I WON THE COIN
TOSS WITH CHRISTOPHER OR THE
RUSSIAN THOUGH I SHOULD SAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO
START BY SAYING THAT I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL INCREASE THE
THRESHOLD OF GRAND THEFT UNDER
THIS BILL FOR TWO OR MORE
EMPLOYEES AGGREGATED IN A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD. AND
FURTHER CLARIFY THE DEFINITION
OF THEFT OF WAGES TO MEAN THE
INTENTIONAL DEPRIVATION OF
WAGES BY FRAUDULENT OR OTHER
UNLAWFUL MEANS WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THOSE WAGES ARE DUE
TO THE EMPLOYEE UNDER THE LAW
AB TEN OH THREE WILL MAKE THE
INTENTIONAL THEFT OF WAGES OR
COMPENSATION BY EMPLOYERS JUST
PUNISHABLE AS GRAND THEFT FOR
TOO LONG BUSINESSES AND
BUSINESSES HAVE GOTTEN AWAY
WITH CHEATING THEIR WORKERS AND
COMMITTING WAGE THEFT AND
FACING NOTHING MORE THAN A SLAP
ON THE WRIST IN A SMALL FINE
HOWEVER THESE ARE SERIOUS
CRIMES MINIMUM WAGE VIOLATIONS
ALONE COST THIS COUNTRY FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
COMPARED TO TWELVE BILLION IN
LOSSES FROM ROBBERIES. BURGLARY
AND AUTO THEFT COMBINED THIS IS
HARD EARNED MONEY AND BELONGS
TO THE WORKERS AND IT SHOULD.
B. AND THERE. AND NOT THEIR
EMPLOYERS. BUT TO THE BUSINESS
SOMETIMES IT'S JUST A BUSINESS
DECISION- BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY
WOULD PAY LESS IN FINES AND
OTHER. CONSEQUENCES THEN MAKING
THEIR PAYROLL CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH- THE
SYSTEM'S NOT WORKING AND IT'S
TIME TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID OF COMMITTING
INTENTIONAL WEIGHT STAFFED.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME HAVE YOU
EVER SENT THESE ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BEGIN. SORRY
I DID NOT SEE HIM ON THE PHONE
LINE BUT IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO AND I
WILL OPEN AIRLINE STARS ZERO.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES YOU MAY
TESTIFY HELLO. HI- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HAVE YET
NOT THE SONG WITH THE SOUTHWEST
REGIONAL COUNCIL OF CARPENTERS
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I WANNA START THEIR-
I WANT TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY STORY I WAS A VICTIM
OF WAGE THEFT- MY FATHER WAS
TOO I CAME UP IN THE TREAT AS A
CARP. DO WE LOSE MAN I GOT TO
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND- WHAT
WAGE THAT IS LIKE- HERE IN IN
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY-
IT'S BECOME A CULTURE WHERE
WORKERS ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK UP
BECAUSE THE- WORKERS DON'T SEE
ANY ACTION THAT IS. TO HELP
THEM SEOUL SUBWAY THAT CRIMINAL
CONTRACTORS ACT IS THAT THEY
OWN THE WORKER IT'S A CULTURE
WHERE WORLD WORKERS ARE BEING
EXPLOITED AND THERE'S NOBODY
OUT THERE TO HELP YOU KNOW- THE
EXPERIENCES THAT I HAD IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IS STILL
EXPERIENCES THAT WORKERS SEE.
NOW IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHERE
WORKERS WORK FROM SEVEN AM TO
SEVEN PM ON ALL THESE
CONSTRUCTION SITE AND THEY
DON'T GET PAID FOR OVERTIME SO
WHO KEEPS THEIR OVERTIME YOU
KNOW AND THAT'S WHAT I'M HERE
TODAY- IS TO ASK OF EACH ONE OF
THE COMMUNITY LEADERS THAT ARE
HERE TODAY THAT. WE DO WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR WORKING CLASS IN
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW AND- I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING. TO WHAT I
HAVE TO SAY. THANK YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU SIR. AND JUST TO MAKE
I THINK WE HEAR THE WHOLE STORY
BUT HAVE YET IS THAT. BOSS
REQUIRED HIM TO SUBMIT- TO
SEPARATE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS AND WORK UNDER TWO
NUMBERS TO AVOID PAYING
OVERTIME. SO INTENTIONAL THIS
IS A TYPE OF INTENTIONAL- FRAUD
THAT HAPPENS. THANK YOU. THAT'S
CORRECT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO. OPERATOR YOU
MAY NOW GO TO- THE PHONE LINES
ON. AB TEN OH THREE LORENA
GONZALEZ FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR A. B. AND ALL.
THREE HELLO HOPE WE WILL GO
TILL. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BACKGROUND ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE MACHINIST
UTILITY WORKERS I B. T. LOCAL
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE AND THEN
I'LL BE MADE TRANSIT UNION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT UP ONLINE- FOR-
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX NINE
FOUR ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS GAIL STEWART ON
BEHALF OF SUMMER STEPHAN THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF- THREE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME'S JOHN ARE GOOD
YEAH I WORK AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE AND I'M
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY
ARE THERE. IS A WITNESS ANY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION I BELIEVE
WE HAVE. ASHLEY HOFFMAN POLICY
ADVOCATE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ON THE PHONE LINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS ASHLEY HOFFMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR OF FOR THEIR WORK ON
THAT COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ONCE THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED TODAY WE
WILL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE CHAMBER
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION. BUT A
DIFFERENT OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS. I'M SORRY I JUST
RESEARCH AB TEN OH THREE LORENA
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU HAVE HERE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN ALL
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE
UP FOR OLD FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE THIS IS
CAUSING THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION ACTUALLY CALL THE
NUMBER OUT OF THE WRONG NUMBER
BUT ANYWAY I JUST WANT TO CALL
IN SUPPORT OF AB CHANNEL THREE
HARD TO BE A LONG HERE OUT OF
THE- CURRENT YEAR. THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WE'LL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MR QUIRK-
WONDERFUL BILL. ORDINARILY I
DON'T SUPPORT INCREASES IN
PENALTIES HOWEVER THIS IS
TREATING WHITE COLLAR CRIME
LIKE WE WOULD TREAT. THE CRIME
COMMITTED BY POOR AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND I'M BEHIND THAT A
100% THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD. THANK YOU HOW DID
YOU WANT PERSONALLY- ECHO THE
SAME COMMENTS AS SOMEONE
BRICKWORK AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR CALL AUTHORS WOULD LOVE TO
JOIN ON AS CO AUTHORS WHILE.
THANK YOU YOUR COMMENT. YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU- I AM GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THE CHAMBER REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION THIS AS IN IT
THANK YOU FOR HELPING US WORK
THROUGH THE BILL IN A WAY- THAT
IS CLEAR WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THAT YOU KNOW. I DON'T
BELIEVE A LOT OF THE LAWS WE
PASS WILL EVER ACT AS A
DETERRENT IT JUST
UNFORTUNATELY- SO OFTEN AT
EIGHT YOU KNOW CRIMES HAPPEN
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS BUT
THIS IS THAT SPECIFIC CASE
WHERE IF AN INDIVIDUAL KNOWS
THAT THEY COULD BE SUBJECT TO
GOING TO JAIL FOR COMMITTING
ANY- AMOUNT OF WAGE THAT
BASICALLY IT OVER AND OVER IT
WOULD IT WOULD LINE UP. NOT ANY
AMOUNT UP TO NINE FIFTY HAS TO
BE NINE- BUT THE PROCESS BY
WHICH SOMEBODY MAKES A DECISION
TO DO THAT I THINK WILL
SUBSTANCE TO SUBSTANTIVELY
CHANGE WHEN THEY REALIZE THEY
COULD ACTUALLY SERVE TIME IN
JAIL FOR IT NOT JUST- SHUT DOWN
THEIR BUSINESS AND OPEN AND IT
ONESELF WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY ABOUT
THANK YOU CHAIR RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE. CALDERON AND AB ONE
THOUSAND THREE BY LAW IN
ARKANSAS IS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY I OUR CAN. CORK
CORK I SAN DIEGO THEY ARE TOUGH
C. R. TELL I WICKS. WICKS I LI
LI I. THAT MEASURE PASSES. MR
GABRIEL. YOU'RE NOW UP.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I AM I PLEASED TODAY
TO PRESENT AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH IS A COMMONSENSE
EFFORT TO BRING MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND TO ENSURE
THE TAXPAYER RESOURCES ARE
SPENT A MANNER THAT SURELY
ADVANCES JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. AS MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ARE WELL AWARE IN
RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA'S
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF NOTABLE
REFORM STAR CRIMINAL AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS. THESE
REFORMS HAVE AIMED TO REDUCE
MASS INCARCERATION PROMOTE
PATHWAYS TO REHABILITATION AND
MORE EFFECTIVELY ADVANCED
PUBLIC SAFETY. DESPITE THE
SUCCESS OF THESE REFORMS
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD
THE NATION IN SPENDING ON
CORRECTIONS OVER THE PAST
DECADE CDC ARE SPENDING HAS
INCREASED BY OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
PERCENT. AS A RESULT CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY SPENDS MORE ON
CORRECTIONS THAN TEXAS AND NEW
YORK COMBINED. EXCESSIVE
SPENDING ON CORRECTIONS HAS
RESULTED IN DIMINISHED REVENUES
FOR OTHER PUBLIC POLICY
PRIORITIES. INCLUDING EDUCATION
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR BUILT ON BIPARTISAN
MOMENTUM TO PROMOTE FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CALIFORNIA'S
FAILED EXPERIMENT WITH MASS
INCARCERATION. MODELED AFTER
SUCCESSFUL PROTOCOLS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED IN PHILADELPHIA
NORTHERN VIRGINIA AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WILL BRING
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY TO THE
SENTENCING PROCESS AND
INCENTIVIZE PROSECUTORS AND
JUDGES TO CONSIDER THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE MEANS TO ADVANCE
JUSTICE AND PUBLIC SAFETY. TO
BE CLEAR EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR DOES NOT IMPOSE
ANY REAL BURDEN ON PROSECUTORS
RATHER IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THEM
TO TAKE THE AVERAGE ANNUAL COST
OF INCARCERATION OR
SUPERVISION. WHICH WILL BE
TABULATED AND REPORTED BY THE
ALEJO FOR THE B. SEC AND
MULTIPLY THAT BY THE LENGTH OF
THE SENTENCE THEY'RE
RECOMMENDING. JUDGES WILL THEN
HAVE THE OPTION AT THEIR
DISCRETION TO CONSIDER THIS
INFORMATION IN THE MANNER THEY
BELIEVE IS MOST APPROPRIATE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT DIMINISH
OTHER APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING THE
IMPACT OF THE CRIMES THE MOTHER
RATHER MERELY ADD TO ONE
ADDITIONAL DATA POINT FOR THE
JUDGE TO CONSIDER. IF THEY SO
DESIRE. IN SO DOING AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WILL PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE
SENTENCING PROCESS. AND
INCENTIVIZE PROSECUTORS TO
ENSURE THE TAXPAYER RESOURCES
ARE SPENT WISELY. AND IN A
MANNER THAT TRULY ADVANCES
JUSTICE AND PUBLIC SAFETY. HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT HE
BILL IN THE SENTENCING PROCESS
IS CRIMINAL ATTORNEY IN COUNCIL
FOR RESTORE JUSTICE LES GILLIS
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK
YOU I BELIEVE WE HAVE- OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS THE A. GILLIS SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF RESTORE JUSTICE IN
THE COURT AND AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AS A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY WHO HAS
PRACTICED IN BOTH SAN JOAQUIN
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY I HAVE
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN THE
COURT ROOM. AND EXPERIENCE IN
THE FACTORS THAT ARE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION IN THE SENTENCING
PROCESS. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR WILL ADD MUCH NEEDED
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY IN
SENTENCING RECOMMENDATION. THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND
WE THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT I AM HAPPY TO STAY
ON THE LINE AND ASSIST WITH ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THE.
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THIS IS. WITH THE STUDENT
SUPPORT. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- SEEN NONE I WILL GO TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. CNN WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES- AB FORTY
SEVEN FOR GABRIEL ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU HAVE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO TO
LINE UP FOR FORTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FOUR FORTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU HAVE A
SUMMIT. NUMBER MARTINEZ
AFFORDABLE MATERIALS NO-
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL GO LINE
OF FOUR FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PART OF AB FOURTEEN
THEY'RE MAKING MORE ON BEHALF
OF INITIATE JESSICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE UP FOR FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT'S NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
PHOTO LINE OF THREE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THAT HAS AN
INTEREST MARKUPS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE COURT. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF THREE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF FOUR
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF FOUR FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS A CLOSE COSTA ON BEHALF
OF THE GOVERNMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GOAL LINE- FOR FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FOUR FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE
A SUMMIT. SO GO TO LINE OF
THREE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO. YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
COREY TAYLOR FROM THE YOUNG
WOMAN THREE IN CENTER AND WE
ARE A STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
THREE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I HI THIS IS RICHA MARIA
BARNES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
GO TO A LINE OF FOUR THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS MELENDEZ WOULD RESTORE
DEAFNESS CALLING ON BEHALF ARE
GOING TO HAVE A RESTORE JUSTICE
FOR A- STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU NXR GO TO LINE OF FOUR OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SORRY FOR WERE NOT
GIVEN A NUMBER BUT- I AM
CALLING- MY NAME IS MARISSA
MARINO NUMBER SYSTEM IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS IN
STOCK THE BOARD- FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GO TO LINE OF
FOUR FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
MENDOZA AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FELONY MURDER
ELIMINATION PROJECT AS WELL AS
OTHER FAMILIES. ACTED IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ARE NOW WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THE M.
ASSISTANT CHIEF DEPUTY D. A.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY HOPEFULLY I
PRONOUNCED IT CORRECTLY. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SMALL GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY HI
MY NAME IS JANE VALLEJO FROM
THE SACRAMENTO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND THE
VOICES FOR VICTIMS COALITION WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR MONEY SHOULD NOT
HAVE A PLACE IN DECISIONS ABOUT
PUNISHMENT AND JUSTICE.
CHOOSING A CONSTANT SHOULD ONLY
INVOLVE WEIGHT WEIGHING THE
SPECIFIC SITUATION AND NEEDS OF
THE OFFENDER AND THE VICTIM
CARE RESPECTIVE OF BUDGETARY
CONCERNS. PRESSURE TO SAVE
MONEY FOR TAXPAYERS COULD SKEW
JUDICIAL OPENINGS ASKING JUDGES
TO MAKE BUDGETARY DECISIONS
DOES NOT BELONG IN THE
COURTROOM. JUSTICE ISN'T
SUBJECT TO A MATHEMATICAL
FOMULA. IF WE ARE GOING TO PUT
ON THE RECORD THE COSTS OF
INCARCERATION THEN WE SHOULD
ALSO PUT ON THE RECORD THE COST
OF THE CRYING TO THE VICTIM
ACOSTA COUNSELLING FOR RAPE
VICTIM. LOTS OF WAGES FOR
MOTHER ATTENDING COURT TO MAKE
SURE HER SON WHO WAS MURDERED
RECEIVE JUSTICE THE COST TO
BUSINESSES FOR ROBBERIES AND
THAT. DOES JUSTICE COURT DOES A
ONCE WROTE DUE PROCESS IS THE
RIGHT OF BOTH THE ACCUSED AND
THE ACCUSER. WE ARE YOU TO VOTE
NOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO- TO
SEE NONE ARE ANY WITNESSES ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE TO AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU IF AN OPPOSITE OF
EIGHT PORT THIRTY YEAR PRESS
ONE AT THEN THERE. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEN NONE YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST WANTED TO- JUST WANTED TO
RESPOND IF I MIGHT TO US SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE COMMENTS
FROM THE OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW
IN NO WAY IS THIS BILL MEANT TO
DIMINISH THE OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS ALREADY ALREADY
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THEIR
SPECIFIC WAYS THAT ALL THOSE
THINGS HAPPEN IN THE AND THE
VICTIM OF THE IMPACT ON THE
VICTIM OF APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATIONS. BUT THERE IS
ANOTHER PARTY AT PLAY HERE IF
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
VICTIM AND THE PERPETRATOR THIS
IS ALSO ABOUT SOCIETY. AND
THAT'S WHY WHEN WE BRING A
CHARGE AGAINST SOMEBODY. IT'S
NOT THE NAME OF THE VICTIM
BRINGING THE CHARGE THE
ATTORNEY WHO STANDS UP THE
PROSECUTORS REPRESENTING THE
PEOPLE. THE PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO THAT IS
ANOTHER APPROPRIATE
CONSIDERATION HERE. I JUST WANT
TO KNOW THAT THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THIS BIPARTISAN
MOMENTUM AROUND THE COUNTRY FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. THAT'S
WHY YOU'VE SEEN. REPUBLICAN
SOUTHERN GOVERNORS AND THE
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION AND
NEWT GINGRICH AND PEOPLE LIKE
THAT HAVE GOTTEN ON BOARD AND
SAID. WE ARE WASTING MONEY WITH
MASS INCARCERATION. NOT ONLY
ARE THEIR HUMAN LIFE AT STAKE
HUMAN BEINGS ARE CAPABLE OF
REDEMPTION. BUT WE ARE THROWING
MONEY. DOWN THE DRAIN TAXPAYER
MONEY DOWN THE DRAIN. WITH
NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT IN TERMS
OF JUSTICE AND NOTHING TO SHOW
FOR IT IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY. I KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE
IN MY COMMUNITY THEY WORK HARD.
AND THEY EXPECT US WHEN THEY
PAY TAXES TO SPEND THEIR MONEY
OFFICIALLY. AND THEY DON'T CARE
IF WHATEVER ENTITY OF
GOVERNMENT WHETHER IT'S THE DMV
OR THE DA. SHOULD GET A BLANK
CHECK. WE ARE NOT PUTTING ANY
LIMITATIONS ON ANYBODY. WE ARE
SIMPLY SAYING. LISTLESS AND THE
JUDGE CAN CONSIDER IT IF AND
HOW THEY WANT TO AND I THINK.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
PROSECUTOR WHO SPOKE FROM THE
DA. WE HAVE TO TRUST OUR
JUDGES. THE JUDGES ALREADY IN
STRUCTURE IS AND WHAT THEY
SHOULD AND SHOULD NOT CONSIDER.
WE ARE SIMPLY SAYING TO THEM.
IF THERE'S A SAME WAY TO
ADVANCE PUBLIC SAFETY INTO
CHIEF JUSTICE BUT DO IT IN A
WAY THAT CONSERVES. SCARCE
TAXPAYER RESOURCES. LET'S THINK
ABOUT DOING THAT. SO WITH THAT.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU-
J. RECOMMEND I VOTE. CALL THE
ROLL. AND EIGHTY FOURTEENTH
FOUR BY SEVEN MEMBER GABRIEL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER I LACKEY
LACKEY NO BARRICADE CAN
BARRICADE HANNAH I WORK. WORK I
SANTIAGO SAY ARE TO NO C. R.
TURNOUT WICKS WICKS I LI LI I.
THAT MEASURE PASSES REGULATIONS.
I BELIEVE MR SANTIAGO CITY MOVE
BACK AT THREE FORTY FIVE TO
PRESENT THE BONTA BILL IN THE
MEANTIME- WHICHEVER THE LAST
THREE A. B. TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
LEVINE. SPEAK AND HE SHALL
APPEAR. MR LEVINE YOU'RE UP
NEXT. HELLO HELLO. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR.
CREATE A PROCESS FOR
RECONSIDERATION OF A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE FINDING WHERE
RELEVANT FACTORS CAN BE
CONSIDERED INCLUDING FACTORS
THAT MAY HAVE NOT. BEEN
PRESENTED AT TRIAL IN THE
PERSON'S INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIOUR
MATURITY AND GROWTH DURING THE
YEARS OR DECADES SINCE THEIR
CONVICTION. AMONG OTHER FACTORS
THAT WILL BE CONSIDERED FOR THE
PERSON'S AGE AT THE TIME OF THE
OFFENSE AND WHETHER THE PERSON
WAS THE VICTIM OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE. OR SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND IT'S PROFOUND
AFFECT ON THEM. IN ADDITION THE
BILL ESTABLISHES A PRESUMPTION
THAT THE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
FINDING SHOULD BE DISMISSED
WHERE A PERSON HAS SERVE MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE
CRIME. WITHOUT COMMITTING OR
ATTEMPTING TO COMMIT AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST ANY OTHER
PERSON. CALIFORNIA LAW
PROHIBITS A JUDGE FROM STRIKING
A SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE FUNDING
THAT SENSES A PERSON. TO DEATH
OR LIFE WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF PAROLE ITSELF A DEATH
SENTENCE. THERE ARE NO
EXCEPTIONS TO THIS RULE IN THE
COURT UNDER CURRENT LAW HAS NO
POWER TO DISMISS THIS FINDING
ONCE MADE. NOT EVEN FOR
YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS WHO
COMMITTED THE CRIMES. BETWEEN
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD OR FOR A PERSON
WHO IS SUFFERING. A TERMINAL
ILLNESS. THE FINDING OF A
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE HAS BEEN
FRAUGHT WITH RACIAL BIAS AND
HAS BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
USED AGAINST BLACK AND LATINO
CALIFORNIANS THE DEFENDANTS.OF
THE COMBINED FIVE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
PEOPLE. IN CALIFORNIA SENSE
EITHER LIFE. WITHOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE OR TO
DEATH 35% ARE BLACK. AND THIRTY
THREE POINT 4% ARE HISPANIC
COMPARED TO ONLY TWENTY TWO
PERCENT. THAT ARE WHITE UNTIL
THE DEATH PENALTY IS ELIMINATED
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR WILL GIVE
COURTS DISCRETION TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON DEATH ROW.
SAVING TAXPAYERS BILLIONS. AND
ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC RACIAL
BIAS THAT HAS HARMED THE
INTEGRITY OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. FOR
GENERATIONS. AB TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR WILL ALSO ALLOW COURTS TO
CONSIDER WHETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL'S PERFORMANCE
BEHAVIOR GROWTH MATURITY AND
OTHER FACTORS ARISING AFTER
THEIR CONVICTION. OF SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE MURDER
DEMONSTRATES THAT THEY ARE NOT
HOPELESSLY INCORRIGIBLE. AND
THEY SHOULD BE EVALUATED BY THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
CONCERNING THEIR POTENTIAL
SUITABILITY SUITABILITY FOR
PAROLE. IF A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCESDISMISSED THE
PERSONAL BE ELIGIBLE TO BE
EVALUATED FOR PAROLE LIKE ANY
OTHER PERSON SENTENCED TO LIFE
IN PRISON. AFTER A MINIMUM OF A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR SENTENCE IF
NOT SUBSTANTIALLY LONGER
DEPENDING ON THE CRIME. OR
PREVIOUS STRIKES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MR THANK YOU MR LEVINE I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES I
DO UP MICHAEL O'NEILL A FORMER
PAST PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
AND DANIEL FELIZ AUTHORED A
SPECIAL ASSISTANT. DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR.
ALMOST SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON HUNDRED
STANDS THAT REQUIRES THEM TO
DIE IN PRISON. ONE THIRD ARE
LAUGHING THAT 35% ARE BLACK 22%
ARE WHITE. THREE QUARTERS OF
THEM COMMITTED THEIR CRIMES IN
THEIR TWENTIES OR YOUNGER. THEY
MUST DIE IN PRISON BECAUSE
THEIR MURDER CONVICTIONS
INCLUDE A SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE
ALTHOUGH MANY OF THEM NEVER
KILLED ANYONE AND NEVER WANTED
ANYONE TO BE KILLED. SB THIRTY
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
RELATIVELY NEW LEGAL
PHENOMENON. THEY NEVER EXISTED
UNTIL THE LATE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AND WE ARE STILL
LEARNING ABOUT THEIR IMPACT.
THE LAW REQUIRES THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO DIE IN PRISON
BECAUSE THE LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
ANY COURT TO ANSWER DISMISS
CERTAIN. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THE PERSON HAS BEEN
REHABILITATED HAD MATURED AND
GROWN INTO A DIFFERENT PERSON
OR HAVE AFFIRMATIVELY MADE
IMPORTANT AND POSITIVE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OTHERS.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE JUDGE
THE PROSECUTOR OR THE VICTIM'S
FAMILY NO LONGER BELIEVES THEY
SHOULD DIE IN PRISON. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT WHEN THE COURTS
REQUIRE A PERSON TO DIE IN
PRISON IN THE COURTS MUST BE
ABLE TO CONSIDER WHETHER THEIR
LIFE AFTER CONVICTION AND TALK
TO THEIR BACKGROUND THE COURT
NEVER KNEW ABOUT. SHOW THAT THE
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD BE
DISMISSED. THIS BILL WOULD
NEVER REQUIRE ANYONE TO BE
RELEASED IT WOULD HAVE TO ALLOW
WITH THE COURT TO CONSIDER
DISMISSING A SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND IF THE COURT
DID SO THAT WOULD MERELY ALLOW
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS TO
DECIDE WHETHER THE INDIVIDUAL
WAS SUITABLE FOR PAROLE AFTER
SERVING A MINIMUM TERM OF AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOR
MUCH LONGER. IF THE PERSON HAD
PRIOR STRIKE CONVICTIONS WERE
USED A GUN DURING THE CRIME. WE
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE IN FAVOR OF
AB TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
BECAUSE IT IS ONLY FAIR TO
ALLOW THE COURTS TO CONSIDER
THE FULL PICTURE OF A PERSON'S
ENTIRE LIFE. BEFORE REQUIRING
THAT PERSON TO DIE IN PRISON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS.
FISHERMEN MEMBERS DAMSELS AUTO
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. AS WE AUTHORED MY
COLLEAGUES STATED. WHEN A
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES FOUND
THROUGH THE COURT HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO DISCRETION TO
DISMISS THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCE WHICH WILL REQUIRE
THE COURT TO EITHER IMPOSE A
SENTENCE OF DEATH OR LIFE IN
PRISON WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF PAROLE. THIS IS TRUE EVEN
THOUGH A GREAT NUMBER OF THESE
DEFENDANTS ARE STILL MINORS- AT
THE TIME OF THEIR CONVICTION.
BOTH THE COURT AND THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS HAVE ALL FOUND THAT.
MINORS PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE HOW. VERY DIFFERENT
BRAIN ASSIST THEM ADULT.
CHILDREN MINERS HAVE A LACK
MATURITY AND AN UNDEVELOPED STE
UNDERDEVELOPED SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY THIS LACK OF
MATURITY BLACK LEADS THESE
MINORS TO ENGAGE IN MORE
RECKLESS IMPULSIVE AND HEEDLESS
RISK TAKING PARTICULARLY WHEN
IT COMES TO COMMITTING CRIMES.
THERE BEEN MANY EXAMPLES OF
INDIVIDUALS SENTENCED TO L.
WALLOP. WHO HAVE SPENT DECADES
IN PRISON AS MODEL PRISONERS
COMMITTED NO ACTS OF VIOLENCE
HAVING NO DISCIPLINARY PROBLEMS.
THE COURT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CONSIDER ALL OF THE FACTORS
BEFORE AN INDIVIDUAL IS
OBVIOUSLY PUT TO DEATH OR IS
FORCED TO SPEND THE REST OF
THEIR NATURAL LIFE IN PRISON.
THE COURT ISSUES ITS SENTENCE
IT IS DOING SO BASED ON THE
TOTALITY OF THE KNOWLEDGE IT
HAS AT THE TIME HOWEVER TWENTY
YEARS TWENTY FIVE YEARS LATER.
THERE IS MUCH MORE ABOUT THAT
INDIVIDUAL THAT. COULD CROP
SKEWS ME COULD BE POSSIBLY
RELATED TO WHETHER OR NOT.
SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE.
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE IS GOOD PUBLIC POLICY.
INDIVIDUALS DO CHANGE THAT'S
WHY CDCR IS ALL IS NOT ONLY THE
DEPARTMENT CORRECTION BUT
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AS WAS STATED NOTHING IN AB
TOLD TWENTY FOUR WILL EVER
REALLY RESULT IN A DIRECT
RELIEF OF AN INMATE WILL SIMPLY
MAKE INMATES. ELIGIBLE FOR A
PAROLE HEARING AFTER SERVING AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN
STATE PRISON. FOR THESE REASONS
OUR OFFICE IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND FORTY TWO OH TWO IN SUPPORT
OF- AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
LEVINE. ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY FOURTH LEVINE- EIGHTEEN
JOB RATER OPEN THE FLY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP FOR. I'M
SORRY WILL GO TO LINE OF FIVE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOUR FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE OF THREE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SACRAMENTO
PRESS MARK UP THE CALIFORNIA
AND MARK. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
PHOTO LINE OF FOUR SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT NAY BACK
ARE WITH THE LACON BALLY B. BUT
AGAIN WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO CAROLINA
OF FOUR SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MASON THE FLOORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE UP FOR TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FOUR TWENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO
TIMELINE OF THREE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE END OF THE
ROAD ON ON BEHALF OF THE
TECHNICAL PUBLIC DEFENDER AND
TO COURT. THANK YOU AND
ACCESSIBLE TO LINE UP FOR SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
REGIONAL MOBILE READY AND
STRONG SUPPORT A. B. ONE TWO
TWO FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF FOUR SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS DEBORAH COMMENTS I IN SYSTEM
IN PACKAGE. AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT AT THE AB NINE NINETY.%
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MADISON DO COP WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF FOUR SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FOUR SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT'S NOT ZERO
NANDO'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BOB ESPONJA YES ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF THREE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRIS WILL BE GET OFF
FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN ORDER A. B. TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT SO
GO TO LINE UP FOR SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS A FULL BREAKDOWN OF THE
ASSOCIATE WITH THE ELEMENTS
THAT ARE CRYING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
UP FOR FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI TO SEND THE OF ACTIVE
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE TWO TWO
FOUR. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
OF THREE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI WHERE ARE YOU HALF
OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND STRONG
SUPPORT EACH YEAR. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THREE
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME'S
CARLY TAYLOR I'M WITH THE YOUNG
WOMAN STREET IN CENTER AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR SIXTY
SIX LINE IS OPEN. WELL. NINE
FOUR SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BOB. MEXICO CAROLINA FOR
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FORTY SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YEAH GO AHEAD.
THE GREAT SMOKY RUNNING FROM
COURT. EIGHTY NINE NINE ZERO.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP
FOR FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FOUR FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MEXICO CAROLINA FOR
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
PETER YOLI RODRIGUEZ IN
GLENDALE CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF FOUR OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY I'M ON MY
REMAIN WERE IN OFFICE SOME
IMPACTED CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENT
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF FOUR TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- HI THIS IS MICHELLE TRAN-
WITH- FEEL FAMILIES UNITE AND
LYFT WITHOUT AND I- WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT- AB DE TOP. TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF THREE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR INCHES LONG THE COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE UP FOR SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BLANCA MARTHA AND I'M WITH
FAMILY. AND LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE
AND I AM GOING TO QUOTA BUT AB
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
CAROLINA'S OFFENSE. THANK YOU
CONNECT WE'LL GO TO LINE FOURTH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
BECAUSE OTHER- I AM A SYSTEM
IMPACTED CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENTS BANK OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND UNDERGONE
SUPPORT OF AB. TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME WOULD BE BETTER HELP
WITHOUT THE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
TRANSPORT. AB. TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF FOUR EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU JERRY
STILLER WHICH YOU'LL FAMILIES
UNITED TECH AND L. WHAT. I'D
LIKE TO- AND OTHER NAMES AS ONE
MIGHT- CHRISTY DENIM IN SUPPORT
CRISTINA HERO IN SUPPORT G. NAY
HERNANDEZ FROM SUPPORT CRISTINA
ONLY IN SUPPORT I'VE BEEN
COLLAGEN SUPPORT EVELYN
PICKENS. I NEED A XIMENES.
MICHELSBERG DINO DI TOM TO THE
SAN SCORE THAT UPS. DAISY FARM
MARIA MORE AND YOUR FAMILY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CARRYING ON STRONG SUPPORTER A.
B. TWELVE TWENTY FOUR RESPOND
AND POCKET. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO OF LINE THREE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS TINA BROWN FROM
SATURDAY AND I AM. EIGHT IT'S
AN IMPACT A FAMILY MEMBER. AND
SUPPORT FROM RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP AT THREE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON A LITTLE WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER TO ONE OF FOUR FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FOUR FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A SOME MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE. MEXICO
CAROLINA FOUR EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI YES MY NAME IS
GINA HERNANDEZ I'M WITH FUEL
BOB I WALKED ANNIE WHITE TO A
LOVED ONE WHO IS SERVING AND I
WALKED AND CONSENT THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE AND NINETEEN NINETY
THREE MY HUSBAND'S BEEN
DISCIPLINARY FREE FOR TWENTY
YEARS I BELIEVE PEOPLE ARE
REDEEMABLE CAN AND DO CHANGE
AND- EVOLVE AFFECTING. YOU I
MISSED THE PART OF EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF FOUR EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING BACK AS FOR ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE UP FOR EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT THIS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE UP FOR EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI RICKY HOWARD
FROM KERN COUNTY PARTICIPATORY
DEFENSE IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS TO GET THIS DONE
THREE YEARS I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR PM AND FOR
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WE NOW HEAR FROM
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION LEADER
MORE CD A. I DO NOT SEE HIM ON
THE PHONE LINE BUT IF YOU ARE
ON THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS STAR
ZERO. AND I WILL OPEN YOUR LINE
STARS ZERO. MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHARLIE SAVAGE
RODRIGUEZ AS A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED LOL AS LIKE TO BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
CAN ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WARY. I DO NOT
SHOW LARRY ON THE PHONE LINE.
LET'S LET'S DO THE ROOM AND
THEN THE PHONE TO MAYBE CAN
HE'LL COME IN DURING THAT TIME
OR ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM SEEING NONE LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION FOR TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR OF AB TWELVE TWENTY FOUR
LEVINE AND IF- MISTER MORRIS
COMES ON. WE GIVE A LITTLE MORE
TIME. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
FOR TWELVE TWENTY FOUR ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF FOUR FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT SURE FIVE
FOUR I DON'T KNOW I MEAN I
DON'T SEE A NUMBER BUT I AM IN
OPPOSITION MY NAME IS KAREN
GARDNER I AM- ONE OF THE- ALLEN
BEING WELL LISTEN MEMBERS OF.
FOR VICTIMS I AM A VICTIM OF A
CRIME IS THE TIME FOR MY
TESTIMONY THAT I START SHARING
OR OR WE UNFORTUNATELY ONLY HAD
LARRY MORSE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET HIM TO
COME IN AND SPEAK OTHERWISE
IT'S NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
WHICH YOU'VE DONE AND THANK YOU-
OKAY WHAT I WOULD CALL THAT
I'LL HAVE TO THREE MINUTES TO
SHARE MY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION FOR A B. TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR. AND. ARE THERE
WILL GET THE GO AHEAD DID YOU
YOU DID WILL SUBSTITUTE YOU FOR
MISTER MORRIS GO AHEAD. YES AS
I SAID MY NAME IS KAREN GARDNER
I AM- THE VICTIM OF A VIOLENT
CRIME- I AM A LITTLE- MISTER
JOHN R. JOHNSON WHO WAS
MURDERED IN TWENTY. TWO
THOUSAND SIX. MEETING WHEN WE
WERE OUT- AT A RESTAURANT AND-
HELP WELCOME FORMULA AND- THE
PERSON WHO MURDERED MY HUSBAND
WAS. CONVICTED BY A JUDGE AND A
JURY OR DEATH BY LETHAL
INJECTION AND- HE WAS ON A
MURDEROUS SHOOTING SPREE THAT
EVENING- CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST PEOPLE SUCH AS THAT-
SHOULD NOT EVEN BE ENTERTAINED
TO. ALLOW THEM TO WALK AROUND
THREE- IT WAS A PREMEDITATED
MURDER A SITUATION- HE HE GOT
MURDERED ONE PERSON AND THEN
WALK. AND HIS. MURDER SHOOTING
SPREE HE HAPPENED UPON US MY
HUSBAND WAS- FROM THE LAST
WORDS I HEARD HIM SAY WITH
HONEY THIS IS GOING TO BE A
GREAT YEAR AND TWO HOURS LATER.
HE WAS DEAD. DID IT BECAUSE
SOMEONE. PREMEDITATED AND
PLANNED TO MURDER PEOPLE IN THE
CITY WHERE I WAS LIVING. WHEN I
HEAR ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IT WHAT IF I FOR ME TO KNOW
THAT THIS PERSON AND PEOPLE
LIKE HIM WILL SOME DAY THEY
WERE CONVICTED BY JUDGE AND
JURY AND THAT THEY WOULD BE
HAVE DEATH BY LETHAL INJECTION
OKAY IF THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVEYEAH THEY SHOULD HAVE LIFE
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO WALK
THE STREETS EVER AGAIN. IN MY
OPINION- I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO BE A VICTIM BECAUSE I WAS
THERE I WENT THROUGH THE HORROR
OF THAT NIGHT THE DAYS THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS MY FAMILY WAS
RIPPED APART AND MY HUSBAND'S
LIFE WAS RIPPED APART BY NO
FAULT OF OUR OWN WE WOULD JUST
HAPPEN TO BE IN THE WRONG PLACE
AT THE WRONG TIME. AND YOU
COULD BE WALKING TO THE GROCERY
STORE YOU COULD BE AT A PARK
YOU COULD BE WERE EVER AND
SOMEONE STARTS SHOOTING. YOU
HAVE TO HAVE. GO THROUGH THAT
WITH YOUR LOVED ONE IS GONE BUT
REALLY IT'S NOT THE CRIMINALS-
THE LIFE SENTENCE IT'S REALLY
AREN'T BECAUSE THIS CAR IS
ALWAYS BEAR THE SCARS WILL
NEVER LEAVE WE HAVE TO ACCEPT
IT AND WE HAVE TO MOVE ON AND
THAT'S WHAT I'VE DONE BUT I AM.
BECAUSE OUR LOVED ONE. I HAVE A
FULL BECAUSE IT EIGHT CANNOT.
TAKE ON THEIR BEHALF. SPEAKING
AND- CRIME AND I I'M NOT I'M
AND I'M HOPING I MEAN IF YOU'VE
NEVER GOTTEN EXPERIENCE LIKE
THIS IT'S PROBABLY MAYBE
DIFFICULT TO HAVE EMPATHY FOR-
FAMILIES FOR VICTIMS OF- SUCH
VIOLENT VIOLENT CRIMES BUT- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PARTICULARS
OF THIS BILL IS GOING TO A
SCHOOL GOING TO LOOK LIKE. IN
IN SITUATIONS SUCH AS THAT I AM
IN. OPPOSITION OF THIS DEAL
BEEN AMENDED OR OR PASSED. SHE
THANK YOU MA'AM. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON THE LINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR. WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FOUR
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS PATRICK ESPINOSA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO- AB TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER TO ONE
OF FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ROCHELLE
BEARDSLEY FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STAND WITH THE
VICTIMS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
TERRIBLE TERRIBLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
FIVE ALL THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE ALL THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES GO AHEAD- MY
NAME IS MOST ALL OF OUR STORIES
I WAS AS WELL LIKE KAREN
SUPPOSED TO SHARE MY STORY FOR
A COUPLE MINUTES AND I LOVE TO
DO THAT ARE NOW. I WAS. GIVEN
TWO OR THREE MINUTES IT WILL.
NO UPS BUT FORTUNATELY NO YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. OKAY MY
NAME IS MOST ALL OF OUR STORIES
I AM WITH THE VOICES PREDICTIVE
COLLATION AND THE BOARD
PRESIDENT OF THE DANIEL OVER
FOUNDATION AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO MORE OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. K. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MR LACKEY. YEAH I
DON'T REALLY HAVE A QUESTION I
JUST HAVE A COMMENT THAT. I
FIND THIS BILL ALARMING. AND
ACTUALLY SHOCKING THAT HOW
DISMISSES VICTIMS SUFFERING.
THESE ARE OVERTLY BRUTAL
MURDERS QUALIFY FOR SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS IS THE
WORST OF THE WORST. BUT YET.
WE'RE FINDING A WAY. TO- FORGET
DEGREE JUST NATURE BY WHICH
PEOPLE HAVE DIED THIS IS DEATH.
THIS IS VERY FINAL THEY DON'T
GET REHABILITATED. THEY DON'T
GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THEIR
FAMILY TO WALK FREELY. WHILE
I'M UNFORTUNATELY GOING TO POST
THIS STRONGLY. THANK YOU MISTER
LUCKY MR QUIRK- SO OFTEN WHAT
SEASON BEEN MOVED YEAH YEAH-
THE CONCERN I HAVE IS WHEN YOU
MAKE IT AUTOMATIC IN THE FACT.
AND I DON'T THINK YOU CAN GET
TWO THIRDS VOTE ON THE FLOOR
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU DO THIS I
THINK IT TO A- I THINK YOU'VE
GOT TO RECONSIDER THAT- FOR. IT
JUST THERE HAS TO BE SOME
DISCRETION HERE. THANK YOU.
YEAH I THINK THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK IN AND CAUGHT A PASSION
FROM SOME NUMBER LACK YEARS
WELL- I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR
FOR. FOR YOU IS AS VOTING
MEMBERS BUT ALSO FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE OBSERVING THE WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE. NOTHING HERE IS
AUTOMATIC NOTHING AND- WHAT
THIS DOES MERELY. IS ALLOWING
THE COURT TO CONSIDER THE
POSSIBILITY. OF- OF DISMISSING
THE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCE THAT'S
ALL IT IS- THAT'S NOT OUR
REGION TO BE HELD OKAY I MEAN
IT SAYS- YOU KNOW IT SHALL BE
PRESUMED TO SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES FINDING WILL BE
DISMISSED. AND IT GOES TO THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS.
UNLESS THE PROSECUTION
DEMONSTRATES BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT THE DEFENDANT
WILL COMMIT A FUTURE FILE IN
FACT IMMEDIATE SALAS AUTOMATIC
YEAH I'M NOT A LAWYER. THAT'S
THAT'S MY CONCERN THANK YOU
OKAY SO. IT WHERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I THINK IF YOU
CLARIFY THAT YEAH I THINK THERE
WILL AT LEAST HELP MR QUIRK DID
YOU HAVE ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY.
COMMENT YES MISTER. OUR RECORD
OUR K. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I HAVE TO SAY THAT I CONCUR
WITH MY COLLEAGUE MISTER KIRK
WHICH IS- I MEAN I DO BELIEVE
THAT GIVING JUDICIAL
DESTRUCTION TO DECIDE WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE IS WHAT WE DO EVERY
DAY ROOMS AND WHEN IT COMES TO
SENTENCING AND SAID THAT I
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH I
DON'T KNOW WHY SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE DIFFERENCE
AND THAT THE JUDGE WE CAN TRUST
JUDGES EVERY DAY TO DECIDE WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE SENTENCES. BUT
I AGREE WITH MR QUIRK THAT THE
SECTION THAT TALKS ABOUT IF THE
OFFENSE WAS COMMITTED TWENTY
YEARS OR MORE BEFORE THERE'S
BEEN NO ACTIVE ISLANDS AND
THERE ISN'T A DEFINITION OF
ACTIVE VIOLENCE EITHER WHICH I
THINK LEAVES A FAIRLY VAGUE
CIRCUMSTANCES SAYS IT SHALL BE
PRESUMED AND THE FINDING WILL
BE DISMISSED SO I DON'T THINK
THAT LEAVES DISCRETION TO THE
COURT TO DISMISS THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I THINK
THAT'S- PROBLEMATIC. SO I DON'T
I MEAN I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AT LEAST- FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
HOPE FOR MISSION AS IF IT'S-
THERE ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH I
THINK YOU- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
EXPRESSING THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU HAVE AS WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO. ON FIGURE OUT HOW TO SERVE
JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS
IS A QUITE A DAY AS WE THINK
ABOUT HOW TO PURSUE JUSTICE.
AND I DON'T THINK IT EVERYONE
CAN COME TO THEIR CONCLUSION
WHEREVER THEY ARE. HOWEVER THEY
GET TO THAT. BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THERE'S A REAL FINE LINE
AND WE LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
THINGS BEING CLOSE YOU CAN
CROSS THAT LINE IT'S REALLY
FINE I DON'T THINK THERE IS A
LINE HERE. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT REASONABLE PEOPLE WANT TO
DO AND HOW REGIONAL PEOPLE
CREATE POLICY PARTICULARLY HERE
IN THIS VERY SENSITIVE DELICATE
AREA. WHERE STOCK SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES- HERE ARE OUR
APPLY TO PEOPLE WHO DON'T
ACTUALLY COMMIT THE MURDER. BUT
THEY CAN BE FOUND UPON PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN IN
THAT CRIME THEY DIDN'T COMMIT
THE MURDER ITSELF AND- YOUR OF
COURSE MY HEART IS- FOR
VICTIMS- IT'S WE WANT JUSTICE.
AND HERE WE ALSO WANT.
REHABILITATION AND THIRTY YEARS
AGO. REASONABLE PEOPLE. I FELT
LIKE YOU CAN LOCK THEM UP AND
THROW AWAY THE KEY A PARTICULAR
AS YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND THEY
LOOK LIKE THERE IS A RACIAL
LENS THAT IS APPLIED AND WE
KNOW THAT HAS BEEN APPLIED TO
DATA TELLS US THAT WE JUST READ
THE WORDS. AND YOU CAN KNOW
THAT- THERE IT THERE'S A NET
THIS IS THE TYPE OF PERSON ARE
GONNA CATCH AND THAT'S NOT BUT
IF YOULOOK A DIFFERENT WAY.
YOU YOU MIGHT NOT. GET CAUGHT.
THIRTY YEARS LATER IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT A FINE LINE IS JUST
REGIONAL PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT
THIS AND SAY WE DID NOT APPLY
THIS IN A WAY THAT TRULY
PURSUES JUSTICE. AND
RECOGNIZING WHAT JUSTICE CAN BE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. THAT IT'S MORE
OF A- YOU KNOW LIKE IF YOU
SHARE. A LOT LINE WITH THE
NEIGHBOR AND THE FENCES AND
RIGHT ON THAT LINE AND YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE BETWEEN YOUR HOUSES
YOU'RE CROSSING IT ALL THE TIME.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE FIND
OURSELVES TODAY REALIZING THAT
THIRTY YEARS AGO. WE CROSSED IT
IN A WAY. THAT HAS HARMED A
SIGNIFICANT POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN A WAY THAT WAS
NOT JUST. AND SO TODAY I ASK
YOU. A TO PURSUE JUSTICE THANK
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. TWO
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD THE
CONCERT AND HOPEFULLY- FORGET
THIS BILL OUT HERE TODAY THAT
YOU WILL COMMIT. TO POLICE TO
COUPLE THE MEMBERS ON HERE THAT
TO CLARIFY THAT- IS NOT
AUTOMATIC- IF I KNOW IT I KNOW.
I KNOW THIS THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. DOES NOT ****
NILLY LET ANYONE OUT IT IS VERY.
VERY CHALLENGING- ESPECIALLY
COMMITTED A HEINOUS CRIME IS
VERY CHALLENGING IN A LOT OF
HOOPS YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH IT
IS A LOT OF STEPS YOU HAVE TO
GO TO. BEFORE THEY RECONSIDER-
ANY VIOLATION MUCH LESS THAN
THE MOST HEINOUS. ESPECIALLY
ONES WHICH TORE FAMILIES APART
AND VICTIMS OF REALLY REALLY.
STILL HURTING- DECADES LIKE I
COMMITTED THAT MISTER CHAIR AND%
I THINK THAT ANY PROCESS NEEDS
TO TAKE A LOT OF THINGS IN THE
CONSIDERATION THAT NO TWO
CASES- IS LOOK AT THE SAME WAY.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE YOU FROM
WHERE YOU'RE GOING YEAH I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE. THAT- OF. WE
CAN AT LEAST AGREE ON ON ON
THAT AND WE CAN HOPEFULLY MOVE
FORWARDJEFF RECOMMENDED I
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND I'M AT TWELVE TWENTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER LEVINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY
LACKEY NO POWER CAN. BARRICADE
HAD NOT VOTING CORK HI CORK
ACCENT VEHICLE SANTIAGO I SEE
R. TWO NO C. R. TO KNOW WICKS.
WICKS I LI LI I. THE MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TWENTY. BOB MR SANTIAGO BOX
BONTA BARGES SANTIAGO CALVO.
WE'LL CALL YOU BEYOND BELIEF.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW BERMAN BONTA
YES. I WANT TO BE A- I THINK
YOU MISTER FOR LAWMAKER PRESENT
ON THIS BILL TAKE THE MASK OFF
AND WE WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- AND THANK
MR BONTA CHAIR FOR ALL HER HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL I SIMPLY PUT
WE WANT TO SEE IS NINE NINETY-
AB NINE NINETY. THANK YOU. YES
PLEASE NOT REFLECTED THAT YET
NONETHELESS. WANTED BASICALLY
STATUS AND STRENGTH IN THE
VISITATION- FOR INMATES IS A
RIGHT- IN THE DISTILLED AS A
COUPLE SIMPLE THINGS. IT MAKES
IT A MINIMUM OF FOUR DAYS TO
ALLOW FOR THE DICTATION DOESN'T
MANDATE CAME OUT HOURS- AND IT
ALLOWS FOR EMERGENCY CONTACT
INFORMATION ONCE A YEAR TO BE
UPDATED- BY ANY INMATE WHICH
WOULD. SOUND LIKE COMMON SENSE.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS.
THAT IS WHEN YOU ELIMINATE
VISITATION NOT ONLY HARM THE
INMATES- MENTAL HEALTH BUT YOU
ALSO HARM FAMILIES WHO DEPEND
ON. SEEING IT MAKES IT. WHEN I
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AND DECIDE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE BILL YOU
I THOUGHT ABOUT FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT THE IMPACT
ON FAMILIES. AND THE
DEVASTATION THAT IT WOULD HAVE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. I AND
LIKEWISE. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE-
THEREFORE TALK ABOUT
REHABILITATING PEOPLE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
KEY THAT IS MENTAL HEALTH IN
THE RELATIONSHIP AND THE- AND
THE CONNECTION THAT THEY HAVE
THE OUTSIDE THAT I THINK IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND THE
REASON I TO THE BILL AND I HOPE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE WOULD.
ALLOW THE BUILDER CONTINUE AND
WE HAVE TO WITNESSES MISTER
CHAIR. BUT WILL ALSO BE BRIEF-
MISTER CAMPAIGN OUTSIDE
CAMPAIGN FOR WHO IS ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF WOMEN AND NINE
BINARY- SERVICES ANTI RACISM
COALITION AND WE HAVE- ERIC-
MORRISON SMITH- PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FROM POLICY LINK AN
ALLIANCE OF. BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR. WHEN EVER WITNESSES ARE
READY TO TESTIFY YOU CAN BEGIN.
THANK YOU M. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS THAT NORMAL- JOHN AND I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE NINETY. I SPENT
EIGHTEEN YEARS INCARCERATED AT
THE FORMER LIFE PRISONER. WHEN
I STARTED MY JOURNEY I WAS
PREGNANT WITH MY SON. WHEN I
ARRIVED AT STATE PRISON MY SON
ANTHONY WAS ABOUT TWO YEARS
OLD. AND AT THAT TIME THERE
WERE VISIT FOUR DAYS A WEEK AND
MY DAD WOULD BRING ALBANY ON
THURSDAY EVENING. BECAUSE THE
AVAILABILITY OF FOR VISITING
DAYS I WASABLE TO HAVE A REAL
RAW AND HONEST CONVERSATIONS
WITH MY CHILD. IT'S FAITH TO
OUR LIVES AND OUR RELATIONSHIPS.
HAVING MORE VISITING DAYS
AVAILABLE ALL VISITS WERE MORE
GRANDPARENT AND CHILD CENTERED
BECAUSE THERE WERE LESS PEOPLE
VISITING LESS CROWDING MORE
SPACE. MORE CHILDREN'S BOOKS TO
READ AVAILABLE AND JUST MORE
BREEDING BROWN SHOULD JUST BE A
CHILD IN A DIFFICULT
ENVIRONMENT. WHEN VISITS WERE
CUT TO VISITING PER WEEK THAT'S
WHEN VISITS BEGAN TO GET
TERMINATED DUE TO OVERCROWDING
AND A LOT OF FAMILY SUFFERED
BECAUSE OF THAT. IN CARBURETION
ALREADY SEPARATE FAMILY AT THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PERSON I
KNOW FIRST HAND WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO STICK WITH YOUR
MISTAKES AND POOR CHOICES AND
WANT SOMETHING BETTER WANT TO
SAY YOU'RE SORRY WHAT THE MAKE
A MAN. VISITS EXIST TO BRING
HEALING TO OUR FAMILIES TO
DISRUPT THE INTERGENERATIONAL
TRAUMA WE NEED MORE ACCESS TO
THEM. MY SON GROW UP IN THE
VISITING ROOM WITH OUR
COMMUNITY OF INCARCERATED WOMEN
THAT HE GREW TO LOVE AND
CHERISH. WE WITNESSED A LOT OF
UNFAIRNESS WHILE THEIR PEOPLE
BEING DENIED THE VISIT FOR
NEGLECTING SOMETHING ON THEIR
APPLICATION FOR WEARING A
FLOWERED SHIRT AND BEING TOLD
THERE WAS TOO MUCH GREEN IN THE
LEAVES GREEN BEING AT THE
FALLOUT COLOR FOR VISITORS TO
WEAR. WHEN I CALLED MY SON WAS
ATSEVENTEEN AND A HALF ALREADY
ENLISTED IN BOOT CAMP. AND WE
WEREN'T REUNITED UNTIL HE
RETURNED FROM A TOUR IN
AFGHANISTAN. HE CAME BACK WITH
A PURPLE HEART AND LEFT THE
MILITARY AS A SERGEANT AT
NINETEEN YEARS OLD. TODAY HE IS
ATTENDING SMU IN DALLAS TEXAS.
MY ENTIRE INCARCERATION THE ONE
THING I WORKED HARD AT THESE
VISIT WHAT THE HOPE THAT ONE
DAY MY SON WOULD GROW UP TO BE
A GOOD MAN. I'M SO INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL AND REALLY IT'S QUITE
A PRIVILEGE THAT THAT WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE ALL AND
MAINTAIN A RELATIONSHIP. IN THE
VISITING WELL. TODAY I CAN TO
YOU WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT.
HELPED YOUR ALLAH AND TODAY
MIGHT THEM LIFE AND HE IS A GUY
MAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LETTING ME BE TODAY PRECIADO.
THANK YOU NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON
OUT OF THE CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THANK YOU YOUR HI FOR
MAKING SPACE BE MY STORY AT THE
LATE STAGE NINE NINE MY NAME
ERIC MORTON MET I'M APPALLED
ASSOCIATE APPALLS ME CAN BE A
LOT WHITMAN. AND I'M ALL THE
KIND OF J. MORSE WHO ENCOURAGED
WHICH FIVE A TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
OF MY LIFE. CDC ARE BOTH MY
FATHER THE COUNTRY CALIFORNIA.
AND A FEW YEARS LATER FURTHER
TO NORTHERN. I DO NOT THE IMAGE.
IT'S ABOUT EIGHTEEN. MY AT WORK
TO DO JOB IMPACTED BY. AN EIGHT
TO TEN HOURS THE IMAM. WITH
NEARLY UP. WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. FOURTEEN YEAR I'VE
BEEN GET THE MOP UP. TOUCH MY
BODY. WILL BUILD THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE BOTH NEED
AND WANTED. AT THAT TIME I MISS
MY FATHER AND- MEANT FOR UNCLE
OR FAMILY FOR. CARPLAY THE
LEVEL FELT WERE TO GET. FOR
PEACE FOR THE LEAD WEEK THE
ONLY COULD TEACH ME. BUT THAT
COULD BE RECONNECTED WITH
FAMILY IN THE ONE DAY. WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS THE CASE WILL
STILL OF OUR- LOW MONEY. WHICH
IS WHY FOR THE TAKE MUST BECOME
OF THE WRITING. WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THAT FRIENDS OF ACT. INTO
BILL BY BROUGH ONES AND- AB
NINE NINETY WILL JUST THAT.
WHAT DO YOU CARE ABOUT HEALTHY
FAN. THE KILLING AND- OF THE
CUSTOMER PEOPLE WHAT STATE. THE
BILL AT. EACH OF THESE ISSUES.
IF I WORK WITH- THE MY NOT
TOGETHER AND MY MOM WORKED TWO
TO THREE JOBS THEY BE MY THE
ABLE TO VISIT HIM NOW THEY- I'M
NOT SURE MY FATHER OF THE TODAY.
THAT'S EXACTLY RE ENTRY THE
HAPPENFOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
LAUGHTER UP WITH THE LAW CRYPTO
ALWAYS THAT WITH VISION THE
PEOPLE PERISH. FOR MY FAMILY
AND SOME OTHER THAT THE AGENT
IS ARE FOUND. WITH AB NINE NINE
WE AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK YOUR
CAR LOVE ONE HI A VISION. COURT
IN THE CHAMBER. FORTY TWO OH
TWO ARGUED ANY WITNESSES ON
AT&T ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF BONTA AB NINE. NINE
ZERO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE NINE
ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE NOW AND
THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF FOUR TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HI THIS IS MICHELLE
TRAN AND I AM- WITH FEEL-
FAMILIES UNITED CAN- LIKE THE
TOP AND WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF FIVE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM GIVING
A VERY HIGH ON IT FROM SILICON
VALLEY DE BUG AND I THINK TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN GO TO LINE OF FIVE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS I'M ABOUT THE
MYTHICAL OPEN THE WHOLE
REASONABLE CERVANTES CHAU MARIA
LAWS ARGUE LIST AND WE ARE
ENFORCEABLE. A. B. NINE NINETY.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO A LINE
OF THREE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS EDUARDO
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB. NINE NINETY. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE OF FIVE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GERMANY
NEVER ADDED ON TOP OF WHAT THE
NEW FAMILY ENERGY. A ONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THIS IS KAREN MAKE DANIEL ON
BEHALF OF THE PLATES FOR GRACE
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTY NINE
NINETY. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THREE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NUMBER THE COMMITTEE AS
LONDONERS ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AXOGUARD SO LINE OF THREE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
BIGELOW AND I'M CALLING IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE ZERO.
THANK YOU NEXT SOKOTO LINE OF
THREE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TINA BROWN FROM
PANEL DAY I AM THE SYSTEM
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER AN
ADVOCATE WITH THE COMBAT LEVY
THAT. I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE NINE ZERO BECAUSE
VISITING NEED TO BE A RIGHT NOT
A PRIVILEGE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP
FOR SEVENTY ONE YEAR LINES OPEN.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD PLEASE JOINT
OPEN. APRIL BREAK THEN HUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE YOUNG ONES YOUR
GENDER WE ARE IN STOCK FOR
IMPROPER COLD FINANCES OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF FOUR OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FOUR ZERO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY HEAR ME
YES. GREAT AMEREN LUCK WITH
THEM IMPACTED- CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENT IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TIMELINE OF
FOUR THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FOUR THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE. I AM VIRGINIA TO
FLORIDA AND- I'M COMPOSERS
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINETY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
OF THREE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S
ESTELLA CORNEA AND THE PORT.
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE OF THREE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS MOST
MAYOR FARMS CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CUNAXA GO TO
LINE OF THREE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MARCO GEORGE AND THE
HALF OFTHE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT A. B. NINE NINE
ZERO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE UP FIVE THIRTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ANGELIQUE BANKS I'M
CALLING IN FROM LOS ANGELES I'M
CALLING ON THE PART OF EIGHTY
NINE NINETY. THANK YOU AN
EXCELLENT GO TO LINE OF THREE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE A MUTE HELLO.
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM LISA LUNA FROM THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND I
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE NINETY AND
I AM SYSTEM IMPACTED AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA FOR NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS MONICA
AGUILAR I'M IN CRESCENT CITY
CALIFORNIA I'M A SYSTEM IMPACT
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINETY.
THANK YOU NEXT SO GO TO LINE OF
TWO SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME'S I'M NOT
GLORIA AND I'M CALLING ON BOTH
SUPPORT OF AB. NINE NINETY.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THREE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME TO LEARN ABOUT
THEM AND PUTTING THEM THE CARD-
EIGHTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO SO LINE OF
THREE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ERICA AND I'M
WITH THE OTHER BOYS I AM NINE
YEARS OLD AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHT. NINE NINE. MY MOM HI
I'M RENEE BENEFITTED CLEAR
WHITE IS ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB NINE NINETY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXTDOOR
BOTTOM LINE OF A FIVE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS%
IS CHANDRU FRIEND THE MOTHER OF
MICHAEL RYAN- YOU WITH EIGHT
YEARS OLD WHEN EIGHT MICHAEL
WHY AND HE WAS KIDNAPPED AND
MURDERED IN YUBA CITY AND AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL AB. ONE TWO
TWO FOUR. OKAY THANK YOU WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF FOUR SIXTY A LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS TRINA
MEDINA I AM A VICTIM IMPACT A
FAMILY MEMBER AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINETY. NINE
FIVE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CARRIE ARE
DOCTORS NUMBER OF TRIED CHIU
AND NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
IMPACTED FAMILIES AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
NINETY COULD MAKE RESIDENT A
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CLAUDIA
GUTIERREZ IBM IN THE CITY OF
RESITA AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE NINE ZERO I AM
FAMILY MEMBER IMPACTED BY IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF FIVE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS TASHA
DURANT FROM BELOW CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE NINETY.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF FIVE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA
AND WE SUPPORTERS I'M IN THE
CITY OF VICTORVILLE CALIFORNIA
I AM ALSO SYSTEM INFECTED AND I
AM CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT. OF
EIGHTY NINE NINETY. THANK YOU
AN EXTRA GO TO LINE OF FOUR
NINETY SIX. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS GRACE MY IN STATE
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I AM A SYSTEM IMPACT FAMILY
MEMBER AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT
AT A. B. NINE NINE THERE ARE.
THANK THANK YOU. AND MEXICO TO
ALIGN OF FIVE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MY NAME IS AARON
CALLING AND I AM WITH ANY SHE
JUST AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS TO GO TO A
LINE OF FIVE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
WHAT THE CHURCH PERMISSION MAY
I PLEASE READ ALL WITH THE
ORGANIZATION FOR HER AND FOR AN
EIGHTY NINE I THINK YES. THANK
YOUNG MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
MENDOZA AND AS FAR AS
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE. OTHER
CALIFORNIA ACLU ALL OF US ARE
NINE BAKERSFIELD ALL ABOUT FOR
NINE LOS ANGELES IN LONG BEACH.
ALL OF US ARE NOT ORANGE COUNTY
ALL OF US OR NONE SAN DIEGO
ANCHOR OF HOPE INTERNATIONAL
MINISTRIES INC. AS VOLUNTARY
COLLECTIVE. JOHN CAUGHT.
BLAMELESS AND FOREVER MINISTRY
OF. HEALTH COALITION AND LEARN.
CALIFORNIANS ARE FOR SPEAKING
IN. FOLLOW THANK ENDS UP THERE
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR WITH
PARTY. THANK HER FOR EMPLOYMENT
ON THANK DONNA THERE FAMILIES.
BASE AND THE VALLEY FAMILY THE
GATE FREE BURNING NOW INDICATES.
IN GARDEN. JAPANESE PLACE
ADVOCACY GROUP JESUS MINISTRY.
LUCKING EMAILS RESOURCE CENTER
LONG BEACH WITHOUT ASIAN AND
NEED SUPPORT PATIENT COLLECTIVE
LOS ANGELES PEDOPHILE LAWYERS
THINK. MOGO COMMUNITY ADVOCATE
FOR JUSTICE AND MORAL DEBORAH.
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
PROPOSAL OFFICE PRISONER
CONGRESS STRIKE BOLLETTIERI
COALITION MEMBER ANNA DINO
BABERS. SO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CHUCK BUT FOURTEEN SEPARATE
PUBLIC THE OFFICE SANTA CRUZ
BARI OPENED B. O. SOCIAL WORKER
FOR EQUALITY IN LEADERSHIP.
STOP AND PUT IN. THIRTY MAR ANY
THAT ADHD PRISON WHY. TELL THE
CHILDREN. THANKS MAYBE UNDER
COMMON LONG. UNDERGROUND CALL.
WE ARE ALL WE GOT J. M. W.
FOUNDATION WE THE PEOPLE AND
FEES AND THE WITH THE- FROM THE
UNDERGROUND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU EXTROVERT SO LINE OF FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT OVER THE LINE O
FIVE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RECUSED HER OF THE
APPOINT THE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF EIGHTY
NINE NINETY THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE UP FIVE TO
SEVENTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT DO YOU
HAVE A SUMMIT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS CARLA JONES SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER. AFFECTED IMPACTED
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINE NINETY. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA OF FIVE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU HEAR ME.
YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME
IS THE ONLY A LOT HERNANDEZ I
AM FROM WOULD LIKE CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK FOR MY FAMILY AND
MY- FAMILY WE ARE. THE FAMILY
AND WE ARE RIGHT SUPPORTERS OF
AB NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO SO LINE OF
FIVE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AND I THINK
IT'S I MEAN STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAX OVER TO A LINE OF
FIVE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO I'M LISA COLLINS IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTY NINE
NINETY. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE OF FOUR TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN- HI
MY NAME IS CLARA GARCIA I'M
FROM ANTI GUN SYSTEM IMPACTED
FAMILY MEMBER AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE NINETY. THANK YOU
EXTROVERT THE LINE UP FOR FIFTY
THREE YEAR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FOUR FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A TIME YOU.
OKAY NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FOUR FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DIANA CRUZ
I AM AN EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER
WITH PRIDE INTRIGUED
ORGANIZATION ASSIST THEM
IMPACTED FACULTY MEMBER I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN BACK
NEXT ZERO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE UP FOR SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO OR
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD HI MY
NAME IS NOT COME UP WITH FAMILY
UNITED AND BLACK WITHOUT PAROLE
IN MIAMI CONSEQUAT OF EIGHTY
NINE NINETY I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON EIGHTY NINE NINETY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
UP FOR SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FOUR SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TEXTILE GO TO LINE OF
FOUR EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THERE WOULD BE HOWARD
FROM KERN COUNTY PUSHED BEFORE
DEFENSE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE NINETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
FOUR EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FINE FOR EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO TO LINE A
FIVE ON THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FINE FIVE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU WANT ME OF
LINE FIVE SIXTEEN. IVANO
GONZALEZ FROM PITTSBURG
CALIFORNIA IN FULL SUPPORT OF
AB NINE NINETY. THANK YOU.
EXTROVERT TO LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS MARTHA GONZALEZ
SANTANA CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING AT THE PORT EIGHTY NINE
NINETY THEIR- THANK YOU. MEXICO
TO LINE OF FIVE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LOU
SETTLE FLORA'S I MESSAGED HIM
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINETY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE UP FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND FRESNO AND
ALSO SYSTEM IN PAKISTAN
REMEMBER IN STRONG SUPPORTER
EIGHTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO THE
LINE OF FIVE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KEVIN MCCARTY I'M CALLING
THE SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINE
NINETY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL'S
SPONSOR COALITION FOR FAMILY
UNITY. AND OUR COALITION
MEMBERS AND CO SPONSORS AND A
WAY OF LIFE REENTRY PROJECT.
ALL OF US ARE NON ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. ON THE
FAMILIES AGAINST SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES RIGHTS.
CALIFORNIA THEM TACTIC FAMILIES
PROJECT. COMMUNITY WORK
UNIONIDAE DO NOT DIFFER
RESTORED OF YOUTH JUSTICE.
CONGREGATIONS ORGANIZED FOR
MORE PROPHETIC ENGAGEMENT.
DROPPED L. WHAT. EAST BAY
FAMILY DEFENDERS. FTG SCRAP AT
THE JUSTICE GROUP. FATHERS AND
FAMILIES OF SAN JOAQUIN. COUNTY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT.
FAMILIES UNITED K. AND L. WHAT
HOME IS ILLEGAL. LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
VERY MAC. NORMALS DOLLARS OF
THE COMMUNITY PLACE FOR GREAT
POLICY LINKS TIED WITH. RIBBON
FROM THE INSIDE OUT
INCORPORATED RESTORED JUSTICE.
REBOUND ILICON VALLEY DE BUG.
STARTING OVER A CORPORATE. AND
YOUNG WOMEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE FIVE THERE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DEANNA READ AND ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY TWO
YEAR OLD SON I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINETY I'M
CALLING FROM KERN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE UP FIVE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CASSANDRA AGAIN
S. AND I'M CALLING FROM TOUGH
AND CALIFORNIA AND I AND MY
FAMILY OUR SYSTEM IMPACTED AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. EIGHTY
NINE NINETY. THANK YOU NEXT
SOKOTO LINE OF FIVE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FABIAN
PERALES I'M STOCKTON IN
NINETEEN STRONG SUPPORT OVER OF
AB NINE NINETY. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE UP FOR FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FOUR FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR CHRISTIAN. I STILL
GO TO LINE OF FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. UNDER WATER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE NINETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE UP FIVE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FIVE FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HELLO. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME OF
MY ACCOUNT AND I'M ON STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE ZERO.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE OF FIVE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
JESSE BY THE CINNAMON NATIVE A
SAN FRANCISCO- AND ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND OTHERS IMPACTED
FAMILIES. WITHOUT THE STATUS
RIGHT TO VISIT FAMILIES
INCARCERATED PERSONS I
DISCOURAGE BIDDING BECAUSE OF
INCONSISTENT UNPREDICTABLE
VISITING THERE ARE. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT OVER THE LINE- FOR
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOUR FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HAVE ASSIGNMENTS WE ARE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. EXCELL GO
TO LINE OF FIVE FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JACKSON RIVERA
CENTRAL VALLEY MY KIDS AND I OR
SYSTEM IN PACKAGE AND ARE
CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY NINE NINETY. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF FIVE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ALL. MAKERERE LEVERAGE
CALIFORNIA I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU MEXICO
TO FIVE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS LI OF ALL CALLING
FROM THE CITY OF TURLOCK I AM
ASSISTANT IMPACTED FAMILY
MEMBER AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
NINETY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NEXT STORY PHOTO LINE OF FIVE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS GINA HERNANDEZ AND
I'M A SYSTEM IMPACTED FAMILY
MEMBER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE NINETY. THANK YOU
XO BOTTLE LINE OF. FIVE FIVE
SEVEN FIVE FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE NAME
VARCHAR I'M AN ORGANIZER AND
SYSTEM IN WITH THE CONVALLIS
BIBENDUM ARE PROBLEMS SPONSORS
AND WE'RE BOTH AT EIGHTY NINE
NINETY THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF
FIVE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOT TO GO TO A LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BYE FELICIA GOMEZ ON BEHALF OF
AT THE JUSTICE THREE POINT IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS A CO SPONSOR
OF EIGHTY NINE NINETY. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TIFFANY CURRY
ALL FROM NORTHRIDGE CALIFORNIA
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINE NINE ZERO. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER TO LINE OF FIVE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR AVAILABLE ACCOUNT BALANCE
THANK IN STOCK BURKE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. SO IN THE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE. WE JUST WENT
THROUGH ALL THAT SO ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION- BEEN A LONG DAY AB
R. A. B. NINE NINE ZERO BONTA.
I DON'T SEE ANY ON THE WITNESS
LIST- DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION AND I DON'T
NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
A. B. NINE NINE ZERO BONTA
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION AT&T
OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE NINE
ZERO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF THREE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE THREE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO
YOU HAVE IT ON MUTE. LINE THREE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAMBER
MEMBERS FINANCIAL MODE BUT
SHERIFF'S LOCATION WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BASED
ON THE INCREASED COSTS AND
INCREASE STAFFING NEEDS- THAT
WILL BE REQUIRED TO MEET
MANDATES BOB EDWARDS RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE NEXT DOOR GO TO
LINE. OF THE FOUR FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU
HAVE A SOME MUTE. THANKS OVER
TO LINE UP FOR SEVENTY YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. FOUR SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO TO LINE UP
FOR EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LOS RIGHT ON. FOUR EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR LINE OF OPEN
OKAY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY
SAYS HELLO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE PROVISIONS REGARDING THE
LIMITATIONS OF ONE VISITATION
MAY BE SUSPENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE SIX
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
SIX HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
DO YOU HAVE A SOME YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M CALLING
FROM LIVING IN CALIFORNIA AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS. BILL I
AM CURRENTLY IMPRISONMENT ACTED
I HAVE NOT LOOKING. EXTROVERTS
NINE OF THREE ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LIKE THREE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIX OH THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO- CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY HI
EVERYONE MY NAME IS STRONG I AM
A YOU KNOW A STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS- YEAH. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF SIX OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SIX OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THREE ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A SUMMIT.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER-
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU WE NOW BRING IT
TO THE COMMITTEE YOU HAVE ANY
ANY QUESTIONS. MR QUIRK. SO
GOOD BIT OF THE OPPOSITION
TALKS ABOUT THINGS THAT YOU'VE
ACTUALLY BONTA FIGHTING YOUR
BILL OF SUCH AS GOING TO FOUR
DAYS A WEEK RATHER THAN SEVEN
ARE NOT LISTED EXPLICIT HOURS
AND ALSO ALLOWING FOR- MORE
DISCRETION I BELIEVE ON THE
PART OF- THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS IN. THE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHICH THEY'VE WORKED- DENY-
VISITATION CETACEAN YES
SOMETIMES THE WORDS DON'T COME
WOULD YOU SPEAK TO THAT A BIT
MORE YEAH I KNOW AND I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT THAT UP BECAUSE I
DID NOTICE THAT AS WELL WE'RE
NOT PRESCRIBING WHAT HOURS WERE
IN THE WORD NOT DESCRIBING WHAT
DAYS WERE SAYING- FOUR DAYS I
THE ISSUE OF COST WAS BROUGHT
UP AS WELL SO TO GO TO PUT ON
THE TABLE BUT WE'RE NOT
DISCUSSING COST AND IN THE
POLICY COMMITTEE WOULD WHICH
WILL DEAL WITH- DOWN THE LINE.
SO BUT BUT TO YOUR POINT- SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED THANKS TO THE WORK
THAT THE CHAIR HAD- AND
COMMITTEE STAFF AND HELPED US
TO- TO OVERCOME BUT I CAN'T
STAY IN THE CAN'T STATE ENOUGH
THE NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY
OUTSIDE OF SATURDAY AND SUNDAY
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE. WELL SOME
PEOPLE JUST DON'T HAVE SATURDAY
AND SUNDAY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT TO VISIT SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT UP AND I
APPRECIATE OKAY WHAT ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF DISCRETION BY THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. IN
DENYING IT- AGAIN THE UP. THE
SAME YOU'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW
IT I THINK YOU DO BUT- WE'RE
JUST ON A DRESS THAT LOOKS. THE
ISSUE OF DENYING- VISITATION
RIGHTS WOULD BE LIMITED AS I
UNDERSTAND IT TO THE COMMITTEES
MAMMOTH THE- IF CERTAIN- IF
RULES ARE BROKEN DURING THOSE
PARTICULAR VISITATION RIGHT-
DURING THE VISIT WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS YOU JUST CAN'T TAKE
IT AWAY FOR EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENS OUTSIDE OF THOSE-
OUTSIDE OF THE VISITATION SO
LET'S SAY- YOU AND I ARE
VISITING SOMEBODY OR VISITING
OURSELVES ONE OF US- IS
INCARCERATED IF WE DO SOMETHING
TO VIOLATE THE RULES OF THAT.
PARTICULAR VISITATION AND THEN
SIR THEY'RE DISTRIBUTED
DISCUSSION THERE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT BUT- BECAUSE I HAVE
MORE THAN FIVE DOLLARS IN MY
POCKET. AT ANY GIVEN TIME-
WHILE I AM EXERCISING OR DOING
SOMETHING ELSE. THAT WOULD BE
TAKEN OFF LIMITS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ACTUAL VISITATION WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF VISITATION- AND I
THINK THAT'S WERE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DRAW ON THE LINE AND IN
REGARDS THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY. THANK YOU THAT'S VERY
HELPFUL- HAS THE BILL HAS A
BEEN A MOTION. RIGHT NOW MOVES
TO BAIL AND ASKED TO BE ADDED
TO SCOTT WALKER WITH MY
PLEASURE. THANK YOU YES. MISS
BAR K. Q. Q. WITH THE SENATE
YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
THINK THIS REALLY AND I KNOW
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THIS HERE
IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT I DO
THINK THEY TOUCH ON PUBLIC
SAFETY I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO HERE'S REALLY
CRITICAL I MEAN ALL THE DATA
IT'S OVERWHELMING TO SHOW THAT
ALLOWING ACCESS TO ONE'S FAMILY
IN VISITATION IMPROVES OUTCOMES
WHEN PEOPLE COME OUT OF JAIL
AND IT REDUCES RECIDIVISM RATES
WHICH AGAIN WE SAY EVERY
HEARING IS ONE OF OUR GOALS AND
I THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE-
I DO THINK AND I URGE THE
CHECKS I KNOW HE SAID ON. AND
THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THAT
DEALS WITH THIS THAT WE DON'T
TAKE RESOURCES IF WE DO THIS
WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT RESOURCES
MY FEAR IS IT WILL TAKE
RESOURCES AWAY FROM THE REST OF
THE POPULATION AND ALREADY I
THINK WE ARE UNDER. OUR INMATES
ARE UNDER CERTAIN ARE GETTING
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
SUCCEED AND SO I DO THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THESE ACTIVITIES ARE FUN IS
THAT WE'RE NOT REDUCING
SERVICES ELSEWHERE IN ORDER TO
DO THIS BECAUSE- THAT'S
CRITICAL IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE SUCCESSFUL SO I JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT ON THE TABLE AND- I
HOPE THAT THE BUDGETS THAT WILL
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION. MRS
HERE TO THANK YOU EACH. SON OF
THIS IT MAKES IT A CIVIL RIGHT.
CORRECT IT MAKES IT WELL WE'RE
SAYING THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
RIGHT TO WRITE A BILL SEVERAL
GRADUAL IT'S A CIVIL RIGHT AS I
WON YEARS WITH THE RIGHT YES
OKAY SO UNDER CIVIL RIGHT YOU
CAN FILE YOUR LAWSUITS. IF
YOU'RE NOT GETTING YOUR CIVIL
RIGHT TO HAVE THIS THIS
VISITATION. AND WHAT I GUESS
THE QUESTION COMES IN WHEN-
LIKE ONE OF THE SPEAKERS HAD
HAD POINTED OUT. THEY
TRANSFERRED HIS DAD UP TO
TWELVE NORTH. AND IS THAT GOING
TO BE A DETERMINING FACTOR IN
WHETHER THEY CONTRAST FROM UP
NORTH THEY FILE A SUIT TO SAY
HEY WE CAN'T VISIT ANYMORE
BECAUSE IT'S TOO FAR WELL THE
NUMBER NOTHING IN THE BILL SAYS
I NAY AND LET'S LET'S OF GERMAN
TWO SIDES OF THAT SAME POINT
YOU'VE JUST SAID NUMBER ONE IS
THE ABILITY TO VISIT- THE
ABILITY TO VISIT IS NOT IS NOT-
ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL THE
ABILITY TO HAVE VISITATION
RIGHTS IT. SO I DON'T SEE A
LINK BETWEEN THIS IN THE
ABILITY- TO HAVE ANY LEGAL
ACTION BECAUSE WHETHER THE
WHETHER THE PERSON CAR SERRATED
IS- HOW TO SPEAK CITIES FOR THE
HECK OF IT RIGHT WHETHER
THEY'RE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHETHER THEY'RE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA-
BY THE WAY I LOOK AT THE
QUESTION THAT WAS POSED IF THEY
HAVE THE IF THEY HAVE THE- THE
OF THE ABILITY TO RECEIVE-
VISITATIONS- THEN YOUR QUESTION
OR THE QUESTION THAT I HEARD
ANYWAYS- IS MOOT IT'S. IT'S ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN.
RIGHT SO. ANYTHING BEYOND THAT
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT IT FROM
ONE OF THE ISSUES ALSO IS THE
ISSUE OF MANAGEMENT OF A PRISON
AND MANAGEMENT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN THE PRESENT AND-
WHEN. YOU MAKE THESE
LIMITATIONS ARE THE BILL MAKES
THESE LIMITATIONS ON USING IT
AS- A DETERRENT FROM. ACTING
OUT SAY SOMEBODY'S STABS
ROOMMATE- CELLMATE. I'D
PROBABLY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THAT KIND OF ACTION
BY SAYING TO SOMEBODY OR AT
LEAST HAVING TO HOLD OVER THEIR
HEAD THAT HEY YOU KNOW WHAT IF
YOU DO STUFF LIKE THAT YOU'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE VISITATIONS THIS
WEEK OR THIS MONTH. BECAUSE OF
THE VALUE THAT VISITATION THAT
MONTH THEY WON'T DO THAT. SO
TAKING AWAY THAT INCENTIVE.
SEEMS TO ME TO BE A BACKWARDS
WAY OF TRYING TO YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET PEOPLE TO. HAVE
THE- SAFER ENVIRONMENT IN A
PRISON. IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
INCENTIVE TO DO THAT THAT MAKES.
AND THAT MEANS SOMETHING TO
OFFER THAT MAKES IT SAFE. AND
SO YEAH IT'S YOU KNOW I KIND OF
STRUGGLED A LOT WITH THIS- YOU
KNOW BECAUSE I THINK THEY
ALREADY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
VISIT. I HAVE FRIENDS THAT HAVE
YOU KNOW RELATIVES THAT ARE IN
JAIL NAY GO VISIT THEM. AND I
KNOW NOT EVERYBODY CAN DO IT
BUT THAT'S A LOT OF TIMES YOU
KNOW THAT'S BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
MANAGE THEIR LIVES TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT. SURE- SO ANYWAY I
GUESS I STRUGGLE WITH BEING
ABLE TO SUPPORT BECAUSE OF HER
MISTER CHAIRMAN I RESPOND TO
YOU. YES WELL LOOK I CAN
UNDERSTAND. I CAN I CAN SEE THE
STRUGGLE WITHIN YOU. SEVEN AND
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW I WOULD ARE
I WOULD ARGUE WOULD HAVE
ALREADY DID YOU KNOW THAT THAT
IT'S THE MOST HUMANE THING TO
DO IS TO ALLOW- VISITATION
RIGHTS AND TO DO IT IN A WAY.
THAT IS ACCESSIBLE- THE FOLKS
BECAUSE NOT EVERYBODY HAS THEM
MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY NINE TO
FIVE AB PARTICULAR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES FAST FOOD IDEA. THE
RETAIL SECTOR THAT THERE'S NOT
JOBS OR PRESCRIBER PEOPLE CAN
DO THAT SO I WAS THAT WAS THAT.
BUT IF YOU'RE STRUGGLING WITH
THAT I WOULD I WOULD SAY I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU LEAD WITH
YOUR HEART AND TO THINK ABOUT
THE HUMANE THING TO DO IN. A
SITUATION LIKE THIS. WHERE
WHERE YOU KNOW LIKE DOESN'T FIT
IN AND I AM I REALIZE I NOT
ANSWERED EXACTLY YOU'RE SAYING
BUT I BUT I LIKE SET A NUT LIKE
DOESN'T FIT NICE LITTLE BOXES
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE. THE
HUMANE THING TO DO- WHAT WHEN
IT COMES TO FAMILIES IN THE
HUMANE THING TO DO- WHEN IT
COMES TO REHABILITATION IS TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE THAT SORT
OF CONTACT. AND NOTHING CAN
MAKE A SITUATION MORE MORE
DANGEROUS. THE EVENT AT THEN
TAKE. THEM TO REMOVE THE BITS
OF HUMANITY. THAT A PERSON MAY
HAVE. A WINNER CARCERI AND THAT
COME FROM THAT VISIBLE CONTACT
IN THAT LOVE- THAT CAN ONLY
THEY CAN ONLY BE FELT IN
MOMENTS- BOTH FROM A CHILD ARE
BOTH FROM. A PERSON CUT ITS
CARCERI. I LOOK A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY YOU WE WANT TO HAVE
EVERY INCENTIVE. TO BEHAVE WELL
AND HAVE A GOOD TIME EARNED AND
TO BE RELEASED- FROM THAT
INCARCERATED SITUATION. ON TIME
MORE OR LESS TIME. IF YOU KNOW
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING OUT
THERE THAT YOU HAVE THAT YOU
WANT A LITTLE BIT YOU WANT TO.
THE EVENT THAT YOU WANT TO GET
BACK HOME TO. AND SO YOU CAN
LOOK AT IT BOTH WITH BOTH WAYS
RIGHT BUT I'M GONNA CHOOSE TO
LOOK AT TE SAY. THE MOST
HUMANE THING TO DO. IT IS HIS
TO LEAD WITH YOUR HEART WHEN I
THIS ISSUE. THEY ALREADY HAVE
THAT RIGHT. WELL I SPENT THIRTY
FOR YEARS LEADING WITH MY HEART
AND SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
ARE PRESENT ARE THERE BECAUSE I
WAS ABLE TO HELP THEM. SO I
THINK THEY HAVE THE RIGHT I
JUST THINK WHAT WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT. TAKING AWAY THE
ABILITY OF OUR PRISON- THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS TO DO
THEIR JOB. AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN PRISON AND
EACH ONE OF THEM GET TO. FOUR
VISITS A WEEK THAT'S THAT'S
FOUR THOUSAND VISITS POTENTIAL
VISITS A WEEK THAT THEY HAVE TO
STAFF. AND THAT MAKES THE REST
OF THE PRISON NOT A STATE.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT AND I DON'T
WANT ALL THAT ALREADY SAVE.
OKAY STABBING YEAH. YEAH SO
LET'S. YOU HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION WHICH IS THERE TO HELP
I'M DONE THANK YOU OKAY. COOLEY
AND YOU SAY THIS IS A BILL I
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING UP TO
TAKE IT AS R. E. G. R. A MEMBER
OF OUR COLLEAGUES TO BECOME THE
AGING IS A BILL ACTUALLY I WAS
THINKING ABOUT TAKING AS WELL.
SO IF YOU HAVE THE ROOM TO DO
IT I WOULD LOVE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR WITH THIS. A BILL WITH
YOU MY PLEASURE. IT FIFTY PM IN
OPPOSITION OR SOMETHING YEAH.
AFTER SURE I'M I'M GETTING A
CALL THAT EVIDENTLY CCPOA WAS
ON TE LINE AND SOMEHOW THEY
DID NOT COME THROUGH SO WE'LL
GIVE THEM A COUPLE OF MINUTES
MINUTES TO- HAVE THEIR
OPPOSITION. MACKEY STREET. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- NINETY MAGICALLY BECOME
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND NOT
UNFORTUNATELY WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL- BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH THANK YOU ASIAN
APPRECIATE THE REQUIREMENT THAT
DEFINITELY MADE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE BILL- I'M
NOT GONNA GO TOO LONG IN THIS
BECAUSE I KNOW I. THINK THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OCTOBER MAKING
MANY OF OUR POINTS THAT. NOT
THAT I IN IN OPPOSITION. BUT-
YOU KNOW OUR MOST OF OUR
OPPOSITION NOW JUST REVOLVES
AROUND THE RESTRICTED NATURE-
BUT THE LIST THAT. WE AGREED ON
THAT EDUCATION CAN BE DENIED.
BUT I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN DEFINITELY WORK ON
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU SIR. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE
I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
HAVE A ROBUST DEBATE ABOUT THIS
MISTER CHAIR FOR PROVIDING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS HOW TO
MAKE THIS BILL STRONGER AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ADULT AND
MET THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW
PRISON **** ARE VERY IMPORTANT-
I HOPEFULLY CAN WORK OUT
SOMETHING SO THAT IT'S
MANAGEABLE- CONTEST IS WHAT WE
DO HERE ON THE POLICY SIDE-
OBVIOUSLY HAVE SOME WORK TO DO
ON FUNDING THIS ARM. THE GOOD
THING IS WE DO HAVE SURPLUS
LIKE WE'VE NEVER HAD BEFORE SO
THAT THAT SHOULD NOT BE A
PROBLEM BUT IMPLEMENTATION IS
VERY IMPORTANT WITHOUT A DOUBT
WITHOUT A DOUBT SILVA HOPEFULLY
WE CAN WE CAN CREATE ESPECIALLY
USING TECHNOLOGY WE CAN CREATE
A SPACE WHERE. EVERYONE CAN BE
ABLE TO GET THIS DONE WITHOUT-
MUSIC TOO MANY RESOURCES. AND
USING THE RESOURCES THAT WE MAY
COME IN TO. SO RESEARCHERS
RECOMMEND AND I. THANKS THIS ON
A. B. NINE NINETY- BY SOME
MEMBER BONTA BY SANTIAGO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY LACKEY NOT VOTING
BARRICADE HAN ERA CAN I WORK
HARD WORK I SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO
I SAY OUR TO. SEE OUR TURNOVER
WICKS. LEE LEE I. THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANKS MR MCCARTY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- HERE TO
PRESENT A. B. ONE ONE NINE ONE
A BILL THAT WOULD JUMPSTART
CALIFORNIANS OWN CRIME. GUN
CRIME- TRACING PROGRAM AS HE
KNOWS AS YOU KNOW A CRIME I'M
EXCUSE ME THAT CAN CRIME A
CRIME GUN CRIME GUN AS A
FIREARM THAT IS ILLEGALLY
POSSESSED USED IN A CRIME. OR
SUSPECTED BE TO BE USED IN A
CRIME CALIFORNIA TODAY WE HAVE
THE AUTOMATED FIRE SYSTEM THAT
APPROXIMATELY 75% OF ALL CRIME
GUNS AGAINST GUNS- THAT WERE
USED IN CRIMES CALIFORNIA
ORIGINATE FROM WITHIN THE STATE
WHILE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BEER AND ALCOHOL TOBACCO
FIREARMS EXPLOSIVE COLLECTS
DATA. ON FIREARM ACQUISITION OF
REGISTRATION THEY DON'T CONDUCT
A COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS ON ON
THAT SEIZED GOD OF THE BILL. I
JUST WANT FACT IT'S JUST
OVERWHELMING THAT I JUST WANT
TO GET OUT TO BE FOREVER
WITNESSES SPEAK IS THERE ARE A
LOT OF RESPECTABLE GUN DEALERS
IN CALIFORNIA. THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO OWN GUNS IN OUR
STATE- OUR LEGAL GUN OWNERS AND
DON'T CREATE PROBLEMS WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A SMALL MINORITY
OF GUN DEALERS. THAT JUST WRECK
HAVOC ABOUT 5% OF GUN DEALERS
IN OUR STATE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ABOUT 90% OF RECOVERED.
CRIME GUNS NATIONWIDE. SO AGAIN
A FEW OF THESE BAD DEALERS-
CREATE DANGEROUS CONDITIONS IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS PREDOMINATELY
ARE BROWN AND BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS WE KNOW THAT. AND
BY HAVING THIS UNITS PROVIDE
ANALYSIS ON HOW CRIME GUNS ARE
BEING DIVERTED FROM THE LEGAL
MARKET. AND IDENTIFYING YOUR
RESPONSIBLE DEALERS WE CAN
PROPERLY PROTECT OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS OUR COMMUNITIES
AND GET TO THE ROOT CAUSE OF
GUN VIOLENCE I WITH ME TODAY.
ARE THE BRADY CAMPAIGN AGAINST
GUN VIOLENCE. IN IT AND THE
OAKLAND- COMBATING CRIME GUNS
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. AND YOUR
WITNESSES. ERICA REIFF
COMBATING CRIME GUNS INITIATIVE
AND MADDY SCOTT BRADY UNITED
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ERICA WRITES
IN AND STICKING ON BEHALF OF
FREDDIE AND NATIONAL GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ORGANIZATION I'M A PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE COMBATING CRIME
CONVENTION EVENT OAKLAND A CITY
WITH NO BRICK AND MORTAR GUN
STORES BUT ONE DEEPLY IMPACTED
BY EVERYDAY GUN VIOLENCE
FINANCING IN A SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE. THE PROGRAM
MANAGER WITH BRADY THE MAJORITY
OF MY WORK HAPPENED ON THE
COMMUNITY- OF ALL SOCIAL WORKER
BY TRADE AND A HUGE BELIEVER IN
PAYING AS MUCH ATTENTION TO A
PERSON'S ENVIRONMENT I THANK
YOU THEIR BEHAVIOR I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF LEARNING FROM FRONT
LINE WORKERS DURING VIOLENCE
DOING VIOLENCE PREVENTION
INTERVENTION WORK AND HAVE BEEN
ALARMED BY HELPFULLY PUT LEAD
THE DISCUSSION TURNS TO
FIREARMS. AND THEIR INCREASED
ACCEPTABILITY AND THE LAST YEAR
VERY GOOD BIKE EVERYONE HAVE A
GUN IN THE STREETS RIGHT NOW OR
NOT COMMENTS WHICH IS WHY THE
TIME IS NOW TO FOCUS ON SUPPLY
SOLUTIONS. AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO
INITIATE ITS OWN CRIME COUNTRY
THINK PROGRAM AND ALLOW THE
CALIFORNIA DOJ TO PROPERLY
ANALYZE EVALUATE AND REPORT ON
THE AVAILABLE DATA AND
INFORMATION REGARDING GUN
DEALERS AND CRIME DROWNED IN. A
MEANINGFUL AND LYFT STATE IN
PLAY. THE PROGRAM WHAT. ANY
VALUE INSIGHTS AT UNDER. OF HOW
CRY GUNS BEING DONE. INTO
CRIMINAL MARKET. BY ERROR. OR
NEGLIGENT FIREARM DEALERS THAT
PRIORITIZE. OVER PUBLIC SAFETY
CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATOR BUDGET.
WAITER CAN PROPERLY ADDRESS A
GROUP BECAUSE OF GUN VIOLENCE
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. PILOTS
PREVENTION INTERVENTION ON THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL IS AND WILL
REMAIN A VITAL PART OF
PRODUCING ON MY LINE. HARPER I
BELIEVE HOLDING THOSE WHO
PROFIT FROM COMBINED
ACCOUNTABLE IN THE SAME WAY WE
HOPE THOSE WHO CALLS HARM IS
ESSENTIAL AND COP AND
COMPLEMENT THE ME AND PRIOR TO
PURCHASE. FOR THIS REASON PRIOR
TO THE PAST A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. MATTIE SCOTT NECKS.
SHE WAS ON ALREADY SCOTT IF YOU
ARE ON YOU CAN PRESS. STARS.
ZERO MATTIE SCOTT YOU CAN PRESS
STAR ZERO FEARON THERE SHE IS
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO EVERYONE MY
NAME IS MADDIE SCOTT AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR ALLOW ME
TO SPEAK TODAY- MY SPIRIT UP A
LITTLE. A SHOP RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THE VERDICT BUT I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF FILLING
FIVE POUNDS IN THE NATION AND
ON BEHALF OF BRADY CALIFORNIA
AND- MANY FAMILIES AND PACKED
BY GUN VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
IS SUPPORT A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE. ALL OF MY YOUNGEST SON'S
NORTH BEACH GOT AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR FATHER OF TWO YOUNG
BLACK BOYS DOWN BALLOT ON JULY
SEVENTEENTH. NINETEEN NINETY
SIX. HI MY HAVE DEDICATED MY
LIFE TO PREVENTING GUN VIOLENCE
AND TO HELP THE COMMUNITY. BUT
ON BALANCE. I UNDERSTAND ONE
DOES BOB THE WITH THE O'CLOCK
ME AND MY FAMILY THANK YOU HI
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES. I
KNOW THAT WE CANNOT. SIMPLY
PICK ACTION. AFTER THE VIOLENCE
WE MUST DO WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE BEFORE
IT HAPPENS IN THE PAST YEAR
I'VE SEEN GUN VIOLENCE ARE
ROCKETING FISCAL AND HERE IN
OAKLAND BUT WE NOW HAVE FORTY
FOUR HOMICIDES AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT MOST
CRIMES ON NEWS COME FROM
OUTSIDE OF PHILLY. AND IN SOME
CASES OUTSIDE OUT EIGHT EIGHT
ELEVEN NINETY ONE GRANDPA
ABOARD THE STATE WILL
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW GUNS ARE
MAKING THEIR WAY INTO OUR
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN TAKE
ACTION TO CURB FIREARMS
TRAFFICKING I KEEP BILL GUN OUT
OF BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS CAN'T PREVENTING GUN
VIOLENCE WHAT'S THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT BLACK
CALIFORNIA WON'T CALIFORNIA AT.
ALL PEOPLE AND CALIFORNIA. BOB
BEING HERE. THE JUDGE TODAY HE
DID TODAY LIKE THEY DID TODAY.
MCGEORGE COURT W. JUSTICE AND-
URGING YOU TO VOTE FOR AB HELLO
NINETY ONE ON BEHALF OF MY SON
AND YOU KNOW OF CASES THAT THE
MAIN ON. BY MY- THANK YOU. SO
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
CHAMBERS FORTY TWO OH TWO AND
ANY WITNESSES ON THE LINE FROM
LINE TO AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
MCCARTY. IF YOU ARE A PART OF
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE. ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF. FIVE FIFTY NINE FIVE
FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WINDS FIVE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE
BUTTON. WILL MOVE ONTO THE NEXT
LINE OF AT SIX FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A-
MEAL SIX FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN WE HAVE NO
FURTHER. SUPPORT AND KILL THANK
YOU- I SEE THERE I DON'T SEE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON ON
RECORD SO- THE OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. AND IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE FOR A.
B. ELEVEN NINETY ONE MCCARTY.
THANK YOU HAVE BEEN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE
HAVE ONE QUEUING UP. AND
THAT'LL COME FROM LINE AT SIX
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOW
ARE GOOD EVENING SURE MEMBERS
ARE WERE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT
THIS IS MICHELLE THOMAS SHALIT
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE JUST I
COULDN'T GET THROUGH THE
SUPPORT LINE SO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN NINETY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU BRING ABOUT TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE
SEATTLE. SO THE DOJ ALREADY
COLLECTS A LOT OF THIS DATA
CORRECT AND THEY HAVE A REPORT
THAT THEY HAVE TO FILE. AT THE
END OF THE YEAR. DOES THIS ADD
TO THAT DATA DOES THIS USE THAT
DATA AND ADD ANOTHER REPORT
CARD. AND WHAT THEY NEED FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BILL BE ADDED
TO THE EXISTING REPORT YEAH
THANK YOU GOOD QUESTION AND
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR ASK THAT
EARLIER SO I COULD LET TRY TO
GET A RESPONSE YEAH- ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY DO HAVE
IT. BUT IT'S BUT IT'S ONLY- ONE
FIREARM SEARCH AT A TIME SO
THIS WILL ALLOW THEM TO BETTER
AGGREGATE- DATA. AND AS WE
OFTEN HEAR WHEN WE SEE A GUN
CRIME WHETHER IT'S ONE
INDIVIDUAL OR A MASS SHOOTING
IT'S WHO IS THE SHOOTER WHERE
THEY GET THE GUN HOW THEY GET
IT AND SO THIS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO DO OUR
OWN TO KIND OF- GUN CRIME.
ANALYSIS AND FIGURE OUT TRENDS-
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ORGANIZED OPPOSITION WE HAVE-
GUN REFORM GROUPS WE HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUPPORTING BECAUSE
WE THINK IT MAKES SENSE IT GOES
TO YOU KNOW CRIME ANALYSIS TO
HELP US MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. MISTER QUESTIONS YOU MAY
CLOSE MCCARTY I THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU- CHURCH RECOGNIZED
VOTE TO MAKE CULTURAL. I'M AT
ELEVEN NINETY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER MCCARTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI BLACKIE. WACKYOKAY
OUR CAN COURT ARTWORK I SAN
DIEGO. THEY ARE TOO HIGH THEY
ARE TOUGH HI WICKS. LEE LEE I
THAT MEASURE THAT MEASURE
PASSES- WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION NUMBER TWENTY
THREE FUNNY ITEM LIST FOR AB
TWO SIX SIX COOPER VIOLENT
FELONIES IN HATE CRIMES
EVIDENTLY WHEN WE I POUNDED
DOWN BEFORE GAVEL DOWN BEFORE
WE- WE VOTED WE VOTED YES BUT
TO MAKE THIS OFFICIAL WE NEED
TO GET AN AYE VOTE DO WE HAVE
ENOUGH DO WE HAVE A MOTION. SO
OUR SECOND. AND I DON'T THINK
MURATSUCHI CAN SECOND GOT
THIRTY. ALSEK IT. IT YEAH I
KNOW I DID THE VOICES SO MUCH
ALIKE I KNOW WE SOUND ALL THE
SAME. EIGHT GIVE ME A AB TWO
SIX SIX AYE MR ON THE MOTION TO
RECONSIDER JEFF SAWYER HI
JOHNSON I LACK LACKEY I HAN
CORK. COURSE I SAID DIEGO. CA
TOO HIGH TWO I. LEE AT LEAST I.
THE MOTION IS GRANTED FOR
RECONSIDER. YOU MAY BEGIN THANK
YOU MISTER. TODAY A GOOD DAY
FOR DOING IS. AND SO I'M PER
VISIT BECAUSE A BILL. TO ASK
OUR DEPART OF JUSTICE. TO A
THIS RECENT SPY AND HATE CRIMES.
YOU KNOW EVEN BEFORE THE WE
KNOW THE TO HATE AND HATE
INCIDENTS. WE'RE ON THE RISE
THIS PASS DECADE. BEFORE THE
PEN. THERE WAS A SPIKE. AGAINST
THE JEWISH. THEN THERE WAS A
SPIKE. AGAINST THE L. COMMUNITY.
WE'VE SEEN RIDE. AND COMMITTEE
OF COLOR. BUT RECENTLY EVER SEE
THE PANDA A STAR. WE THAT THERE
IS BEEN US. IN ANTI AGING AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HATE. THERE IS
A GOOD NUMBER. THAT STARTED. A
EFFORT CALLED STOP A. A. P. I
HATE .COM. AND- THEY PROVIDE AN
OP. FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
REPORT. YOU KNOW INCIDENTS OF
HATE CRIMES AS WELL AS- KATE
INCIDENTS THAT MAY NOT RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF A CRIME. BUT STILL
IS EVIDENCE OF ALL THIS HATE
THAT- HAS BEEN INCREASING IN
OUR COUNTRY. THIS STOP AP I
HATE RECEIVED OVER THIRTY EIGHT
HUNDRED REPORTS NATIONALLY.
SINCE THE PANDEMIC STARTED WITH
ALMOST HALF OF THOSE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THE STOP áP
I HATE HAS HELPED BRING
NATIONAL ATTENTION. TO THIS
ALARMING TREND. IT HAS HELPED
US TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF THE
NATURE AND THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
PROBLEM. BUT IT'S ALSO HELPED
AND HELPING GETTING VICTIMS.
SUPPORT COMMUNITY SUPPORT FROM
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
AS WELL AS THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. BY MAKING IT AT AS
EASY AND AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE TO
REPORT THESE HATE CRIMES AND
HATE INCIDENTS. WE KNOW WE HAVE
A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT A MAJORITY OF HATE CRIMES.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE GOES UNREPORTED. AND
WE KNOW THAT MANY PEOPLE. FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE AND REPORTING
HATE CRIMES AND HATE INCIDENTS.
AT OF FEAR OF RETALIATION. THE
FEAR OF INTERACTING WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND SO THE
GOAL OF AB FIVE FIVE SEVEN THE
REPRESENTING ALONG WITH- MY
JOIN AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU. WHO FIRST PRESENTED
THIS BILL I BELIEVE TWO YEARS
AGO OR OR TWO TERMS AGO. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU MR LACKEY.
IS TO MAKE IT AS EASY AND SAFE
TO REPORT HATE CRIMES AND HATE
INCIDENTS AS POSSIBLE SO THAT
WITH SO THAT WE CAN REPORT AND
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY AND GET
VICTIMS THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED. I'M PROUD THAT-
THIS BILL IS BEING SPONSORED.
BY THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
A LEADER IN THIS IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST HATE CRIMES FOR
DECADES. REPRESENTING THE ADL
IS BETH HOLTZMAN. AND WE ALSO
HAVE- SECOND SUPPORTING WITNESS
YET MARSHALL WITH THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
PUBLIC AFFAIRS. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. OPERATOR. YES I'M
LOOKING FOR THEM I DO NOT SEE
THEM ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU
ARE ON THE PHONE LINE. PLEASE
PRESS ZERO- STARS. ZERO START
THERE ALL ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FIVE HUNDRED M. HEAT MARSHALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL THANK YOU
FOR THAT MY NAME ARE AT
NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF EIGHT THE
CITY CENTER AND MATT PUBLIC
AFFAIRS TO SOCIAL. THAT KNOWN
AS A PAPA IN NATIONAL OKAY
CAPCO IN SACRAMENTO POSE THIRTY
CHAPTER MOSTLY BASED INCOME.
I'M A IS EMPOWER ASIAN WHO
EDUCATE LEADERS ON IT. AGE
FIFTY OKAY FORM AND ASIAN ACT
FORCED TO ADDRESS THE ALARM
EIGHT AGAINST H. AND AT THAT
TIME HOWEVER REQUEST FOR NAY
NIGHT HAVE CORRECT AND- WHAT
IMPLEMENTED. TODAY DUE TO THE
CARPET MAKING COMBAT
ALLEGATIONS THE FOURTH PLUS
PEOPLE IN BY STOP. EIGHT LET'S
NOT ACT REFLECT THE AND
REPORTED NUMBER DALY INSTEAD OF
I THOUGHT BETTER ACCOUNT
AGAINST OUT. BLAMING US FOR THE.
COACH ADDED AND LANGUAGE. THERE
ARE. GOING GREATER HATE CRIME
AGAINST PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE.
IN ADDITION MOMENT BECAUSE THE
AGE AMERICAN COMMUNITY CANNOT
AND SPEAK UP BUT HOW OFTEN IT
DON'T BEGIN OPTIONAL NEARLY
GROUPS STATE AND HATE CRIME LAW
BECAUSE OF DEADLY. AND
ACCORDING TO THE COURT OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY BY
SAYING ENOUGH IS ENOUGH. APAKAH
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED THE PACKAGE
UP IT'S LIKE YOU SAID SHE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. EMBED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS BOB HOPE MEN
AND I THIRD AT THE WESTERN
STATE CIVIL RIGHTS COUNCIL FOR
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND
REPRESENTS AT LP FIVE
CALIFORNIA OFFICES EIGHTY OUT
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB FIVE
FIVE SEVEN WHICH REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
TO ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN AN
ACCEPTABLE TOLL FREE HOTLINE
NUMBER AND AN ONLINE FORM FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO REPORT HATE
CRIMES AND HATE INCIDENTS.
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN THIRTEEN
AND RESPOND TO AN ESCALATING
CRIME AND ANTI SEMITISM AND
BIGOTRY ADL HAS NOW BECOME A
LEADING ANTI HE ORGANIZATION
ADL DRAFTED THE FIRST NATION
FIRST MODEL HATE CRIME STATUTE
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES
AND NINETEEN THIRTIES LATE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES REPORTED OVER ONE
THOUSAND HATE CRIMES TO THE DOJ
OF FOUR POINT 8% DECREASE FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT FAR FROM
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN HISTORIC
LOW OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT. MAJORITY OF HATE CRIMES
GO UNREPORTED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOWEVER A FEDERAL
BROUGH OBJECTS JUSTICE
STATISTICS REPORT FOUND THAT
84% OF HATE CRIMES BETWEEN
TWENTY ELEVEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOR NOT REPORTING IT
THERE ARE MANY REASONS TARGETED
INDIVIDUALS MAY NOT REPORT HATE
CRIME LAW ENFORCEMENT MOST
COMMONLY THEY MAY BE FEARFUL OF
BEING REJECTED MIND OR EVEN
IGNORED THERE ARE ALSO SOCIAL
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC
BARRIERS THAT CONTINUE TO
DISCOURAGE MANY FROM REPORTING
A CRIME DIRECTLY TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AN ALTERNATIVE
METHOD TO COLLECT ACCURATE HE
CRIME DATA AND THE STATE'S
IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS
ESTABLISHING AN ADDITIONAL
REPORTING METHOD THROUGH THE
DOJ WILL IMPROVE DATA
COLLECTION LEADING TO BETTER
RESOURCE ALLOCATION AND OTHER
EFFORTS TO ASSIST TARGETED
COMMUNITIES THE HOT LINE AN
ONLINE REPORTING FORMAL
ALTRUISTIC INDIVIDUALS AND
TRAINING RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
SERVICES LOCALLY THIS APPROACH
HAS BEEN ADOPTED IN
JURISDICTIONS JURISDICTIONS
SUCH AS SAN FRANCISCO AND
ALAMEDA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICES AND THE STATE THE
MASSACHUSETTS AND. NEW YORK ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE NEW NO
ACT WHICH WAS JUST THREE
ENTERED. WITHOUT FUNDING STATE
CREATE FARM HE CLAIMED HE TAKE
CRIME REPORTING HOT. I WISH AND
ANY WE ARE SADLY. A CAN TRY IN
BIG AND BIAS MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE. NOTABLY ANTI ASIAN
SCAPEGOATING AND RHETORIC SINCE
THE START OF THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS RESULTED AND
ALARMING SPIKE IN VERBAL AND
PHYSICAL ASSAULTS AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS WE NEED MORE TOOLS TO
HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM AND
INSTEAD IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
FOR THESE REASONS ADL PROBABLY
SUPPORT. AB. FIVE FIVE SEVEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU BYE
BYE. THANK YOU- ANY WITNESSES
IN FORTY TWO OH TWO. SEEING
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS
FOR AB FIVE FIVE SEVEN
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN THE OFF
YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE
FIVE SEVEN. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF SIX EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU COUNTY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. IN MY MOMENT MISTER CHAIR
WHY WE GATHER THEIR LINE
NUMBERS. WE ARE ON A. B. FIVE
FIVE SEVEN FOUR SUPPORT. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP FIVE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
IT CAN NOW BE WEEK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF ANY KIND A LOCKET.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
SIX TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BOB MISTER SHERMAN
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU AB BC NO
ONE RIGHT IN OPPOSITION.
EVERYONE IN THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION AND IT'S OUR ANYONE
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION. GIVEN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. OF AB. FIVE
FIVE SEVEN. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. MISTER
LUCKY. YEAH I REALLY I WANT TO
FIRST SAY THAT- I LOVE THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL AND I
SUPPORTED- THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
VERSION BY CHU IS AB EIGHT
HUNDRED I BELIEVE. HOWEVER I
HAVE A REAL BURNING QUESTION-
IT IN THE BILL IT TALKS ABOUT.
IDENTIFYING BEING ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THE NATIVE LANGUAGE
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT SPEAK ENGLISH.
AND THERE ARE AN AWFUL LOT OF
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES THAT TO
HAVE A- MOVED INTO CALIFORNIA
HOW MANY CERTIFIED TRANSLATORS
DO YOU EXPECT TO BE ON THE HOT
LINE. WELL I- YOU KNOW THE
DETAILS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
LIKE- MANY OF OUR- BILLS WE
WOULD LIKE WE WOULD LIKE TO A
DEFER TO THE AGENCY. IN THIS
CASE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BUT- THE GOLAN INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS FOR THE DOJ TO PARTNER.
WITH AS MANY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- TO- HELP WITH
THE- THE- SUPPORT SERVICES LIKE
TRANSLATIONS- AND SO YOU KNOW I
THINK WE WANT TO. ENCOURAGE
THAT- TRANSLATORS NOT JUST YOU
KNOW BE HIRED IN HOUSE WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- BUT
THAT- THEY MAY HAVE THE OPTION
OF CONTRACTING- WITH- COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES. I THINK THAT'S A
VERY NOBLE GO I THINK IT'S
GONNA BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
IDENTIFY- WHAT LANGUAGES YOU
SHOULD AND SHOULDN'T HAVE THERE
AND IT'S GOING TO BE. PRETTY
COSTLY BUT- I WISH YOU LUCK
WITH THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT I
MEAN IT'S A WORTHY. GOAL TWO TO
ACHIEVE TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THOSE WHO FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE A VICTIM OF A CRIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU IF I MAY. I
SHOP PERHAPS- YOU KNOW LIKE
MANY- PUBLIC SERVICES WE CAN.
DISCUSS WHETHER WE- WOULD-
WOULD WANT TO LIMIT IT TO THE
MOST COMMON. OF FOREIGN
LANGUAGES THAT ARE REPRESENTED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT-
WELL. WORTH LEVELS TO A LOT OF
THOSE TWO. THANK YOU. AND IT UP
SO THIS WORKS MICHAEL THIS.
ALRIGHT I JUST WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL IT'S A
HUGELY IMPORTANT TOPIC I THINK
A CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
SOLUTION ON THE NOT OBVIOUSLY
THE ENTIRE SOLUTION AND I'D
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
LEE. BASILAR RESEARCH YOUR
THANK YOU FOR LEISURE BRING
THIS BACK IN THE AUTHORSHIP OF
THIS OBVIOUSLY RIGHT NOW. ASIAN
AMERICANS WERE. IN THE
SPOTLIGHT RIGHT NOW BUT WE ARE
ALL TOGETHER IN A RISING TIDE
OF HATRED SO. HAVING A HOT LINE
THIS EXCESS WILL EVERYONE OF
EVERY BACKGROUND IS GONNA BE
HUGELY IMPORTANT RIGHT BECAUSE
WE SEE. THE SAME TRENDS THE
SAME KIND OF. PRESSURE THAT
EXISTS AND HAVING IT. I'M
HOPING YOU KNOW WITH THE- NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL YOU KNOW
THEY'LL BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS
POSSIBLE RIGHT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IS KIND OF THE POINT. IS A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO. DON'T FEEL
AT HOME HERE EVEN THOUGH THEY
MADE THEIR HOME HERE- DON'T
FEEL THAT THEY CAN TRUST THE
GOVERNMENT THEY CAN BE. THEY
CAN COME FOR WITH THEIR HATE
INCIDENTS. BUT THE MORE WE KNOW
ABOUT IT AND THE MORE WE CAN WE
CAN ANALYZE IT AND FIGURE IT
OUT THE MORE WE CAN RESULT
THESE THINGS RIGHT SO
HOPEFULLY. WE WILL BE AS
EFFECTIVE AS MANY EXPENSE OF
LANGUAGES AND CULTURES WHICH I
AM SUPPORT OF- IN THIS HOT
LINES MUCH AS POSSIBLE- SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO
THAT WITH OUR HUGE BUDGET
SURPLUS AS WELL. AND I'D ALSO
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AS WELL AND HOPEFULLY THE REST
OF ARCHITECT OFFICE WILL SAID.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR LEE. CHRIS BARKING. IN THE
MISTER CORK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I TOO WANT TO THANK
YOU MISTER MOORE SUED YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL I THINK-
THAT. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO ALWAYS REMEMBER IS THAT.
THESE ARE UNDER REPORTED THEIR
UNDER PORTER FOR A LOT OF
REASONS YOU KNOW RECENTLY THERE
WAS. INTERESTING PRESS BEING
DONE ABOUT WHY IT IS SO HARD TO
TRY TO HATE CRIME IN THE ASIAN
AMERICAN INCIDENTS BECAUSE
THERE AREN'T. SWASTIKAS OR
OTHER IDENTIFIABLE. THINGS THAT
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT IT'S A HATE
CRIME EVEN IF. IT'S SORT OF
UNDERSTANDABLE TO THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN THAT IT IS THE BURDEN
OF PROOF IN A COURT OF LAW IS
SUCH THAT THAT'S A REALLY
CHALLENGING THINGS TO DO AND SO
THE US. DOESN'T GET CHARGED HE
CRIME. IS IN CANADA AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT HAVE THESE OTHER
METRICS TO REALLY COUNT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE AS A
LEGISLATURE. AND YOU KNOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN USE OUR
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THEY
WERE EDUCATING PEOPLE WHO WE'RE
FIGHTING THIS AT EVERY LEVEL BE
IN EDUCATION- IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. BUT WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO AND I THINK
THAT'S VERY APPARENT RIGHT. NOW
ESPECIALLY. YOU KNOW- MY BILL
TODAY ON HIS CRIMES IS PULLED
BY CAN. AND WOULD ALLOW. FOR
JUST CHARGING- AND YOU KNOW-
TWO WEEKS AGO I BELIEVE ANOTHER
HATE CRIME BILL WAS. AND DIDN'T
PASS UT OF THIS COMMITTEE. AND
SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATIONS OF HOW WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO FIGHT. THIS RISE IN HATE
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE JUST HAVE
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY AND I
SPOKE ABOUT. HOW THIS IS HOW IT
STARTS IT DOESN'T START WITH-
GENOCIDE IT STARTS WITH THE
HATRED. AND SMALL ACTS OF
VIOLENCE AND IT GOES FROM THERE
AND IT'S INCUMBENT ON US TO
STEP UP NOW AND STOP ITSO I
APPRECIATED NINETY WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE CLERK.
POPULAR BILL- I'M ALREADY A CO
AUTHOR- JUST TO TALK ABOUT THE
TRANSLATION YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HIGHER AMONG TRANSLATOR OR
OTHER FOLKS. OUR WHO WHAT WHO
SPEAK THE MANY LANGUAGES OF
ASIA I MEAN THERE ARE HUNDREDS
OF LANGUAGES JUST IN INDIA. BUT
WHAT YOU CAN DO FOR A LOT OF
THESE IS- AS HE SAID CONTACT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS-
THERE'S ALSO PEOPLE WORK ITS
CONTRACTORS FOR THIS. SO WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO HIT EVERY
INDIAN LANGUAGE BUT I THINK
THAT- IT'S NOT NEED TO BE
EXCESSIVELY COSTLY THANKS AND I
CAN'T IMAGINE THIS SMALL PASS
AND GET SIGNED. MORE QUESTIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE ALL THE-
THE COMMENTS- RAISING CONCERNS
AS WELL AS IT DOES IN SUPPORT-
WANTED TO RESPOND TO A- MISTER
LEE'S COMMENTS- YOU KNOW I
THINK- TODAY'S EVENTS SHOWS
THAT TO. YOU KNOW A ATTORNEY
GENERAL KEITH ELLISON AND- THE
MINNESOTA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
CAN BE- A GREAT FORCE AND-
PROVIDING JUSTICE FOR
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW I KNOW
THAT I'M I'M HEARING SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT YOU KNOW WHETHER
THIS SHOULD BE- HOUSE IN A YOU
KNOW IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- YOU KNOW IS THAT TO GO
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT- BUT- THAT THAT'S
WHY I WANTED TO- GETTING BACK
TO MISS A LACK IS CALM AND I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT. THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE PUT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS- CAN CAN
REALLY PROVIDE A VITAL SERVICE-
AND- SUPPORTING THE VICTIMS AS
WELL AS SEEKING TO GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO READ TO REPORT
AND I WANTED TO-
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS BAUER K. AND A
COMMENT TO ME YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS DURING THE HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY YOU KNOW I
REMEMBER THAT HOW IT ALL
STARTED WITH YOU KNOW THESE
THOSE RANDOM SEEMINGLY RANDOM
INCIDENTS AND ISOLATED
INCIDENTS OF HATE- AND- YOU
KNOW I THINK THIS KIND OF IT I
HATE LINE- HOTLINE THAT- WOULD.
THAT MAKE IT EASY AND SAFE FOR
PEOPLE TO REPORT A WILL HELP
IDENTIFY AGAIN THE NATURE ON
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM
BEFORE IT BECOMES TOO LATE-
SERVICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND- WITH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR HAVE. THE TEACHERS
RECOMMEND I CAN CALL THE ROLL.
AN EIGHTY FIVE FIVE SEVEN NICE
MEMBER HAVE TO G. THE MEASURE
AS A DEEP TO THE APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI LACKEY I PARA QUE
HAN. BAUER-KAHAN I WORK. WORK I
SAN DIEGO. THEY ARE TOO ZERO
TWO FIVE WEEKS WEEKS I LI LI I.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THANKS.
RIGHT WE WILL. USUALLY MEMBER
DOES WEIRD. WE'RE READY FOR AB
NINETY FOUR THANK YOU OUR FIRST
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT
DUE TO THE LATE AUTHOR'S
AMENDMENT THE PUBLISHED IN
ALICE'S- DOES NOT CURRENTLY
REFLECT THE BILL IMPRINT I'VE
MADE AMENDMENTS- AND I WOULD
LIKE TO START OFF BY REALLY
APOLOGIZING TO CCPOA TO
CORRECTION OFFICERS IN THE
ORIGINAL VERSION BECAUSE THAT
WAS NOT MY INTENT. IS PROP THE
PEOPLE WHO HELPED WRITE THAT-
PROBABLY THOUGHT IT WAS A
COUPLE OF MANY REASONS WHY I
WANTED TO GO IN THAT DIRECTION
WAS NOT TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
FIRED I WAS NOT TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE'S RECORDS- BEING HARD.
TO THEM. MY BUT MY NAME IS ON
THE DOOR. AND SO I TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT. BOB
WHAT STARTED THIS WAS A
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SURVEY OF CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS PUBLISHED
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THEY FOUND
THE OFFICERS ARE EXPOSED TO
VIOLENCE AT RATES COMPARABLE TO
MILITARY VETERANS AND THAT THE
JOB IS LINKED TO HEALTH
PROBLEMS. DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS NINE STATE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS KILLED
THEMSELVES LAST YEAR ALONE.
ACCORDING TO THE FIGURES OF
CCPOA TO CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS AND
JUST LAST YEAR THERE WAS A
YOUNG MAN. VALENTINO RICK
RODRIGUEZ JUNIOR THIRTY WHO
COMMITTED SUICIDE. BOB OFFICERS
DURING THAT INCIDENT REPEATEDLY
CALL RODRIGUEZ JUNIOR A GAY
SLUR MAKE FUN OF HIS WEIGHT AND
TAUNTED HIM SAYING THAT HIS
WIFE WAS CHEATING ON HIM WITH
BLACK MEN ACCORDING TO TEXAS
CHANGES ON HIS PHONE. RODRIGUEZ
SAID IN TEXT THAT THE
HARASSMENT CAME EVEN AS HE
WORKED HARDER THAN HIS
COWORKERS AND PERFORMED HIS
WORK WELL I WISH I'D DONE THIS
BILL. A YEAR AGO WE COULD HAVE
PROBABLY SAVED THIS YOUNG MAN'S
LIFE. IF IT HAD TO KIND OF HELP
YOU NEED. TO BE CLEAR AB NINETY
FOUR AS AMENDED ONLY REQUIRES
THAT CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
RECEIVE A YEARLY MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION WITH NO FURTHER
ACTION TO BE TAKEN BY ANY
DEPARTMENT. I LIKE THE PREVIOUS
VERSION VERSION THIS BILL DOES
NOT PLACE ANY INFORMATION IN
THE OFFICER'S PERSONNEL
FOXFIRE. NOR DOES IT REMOVE
THEM FROM DIRECT SUPERVISION OF
INCARCERATED FOLKS AB NINETY
FOUR SIMPLY MAKES OFFICERS
AWARE. OF ANY CONDITIONS THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEEK HELP FOR
INSURE AND ENSURE THEY ARE
GIVEN INFORMATION OR RESOURCES
THAT CAN VOLUNTARILY BE
ACCESSED. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
CURRENTLY REQUIRED ALL PEACE
OFFICERS TO UNDERGO A PRE
EMPLOYMENT MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE FREE OF ANY CONDITION THAT
WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO PERFORM THE
ESSENTIAL JOB DUTIES HOWEVER
THERE'S NO OBLIGATION FOR THE
SAME CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS TO
RECEIVE A FOLLOW UP AT ANY
TIME. THIS IS DESPITE DATA
SHOWING CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
REGULARLY EXPERIENCED PILOT
WORK AT PRIVATE EVENTS AT WORK
AND ONE IN ONE IN THREE OF
OFFICERS REPORT AT LEAST ONE
SYMPTOM OF PTSD POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER AND NO
DISRESPECT TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HERE. I DO
BELIEVE THEY PROBABLY WORKED
THE HARDEST BEAT- UP IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU HAVE TO
WORK TO RECHARGE IT WORKED OF
CELLS. CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ARE HIGH STRESSED IN OUR IN A
HIGH STRESS ENVIRONMENT. THAT
IMPACTS THE WELL BEING NOT ONLY
OF THE OFFICERS BUT ALSO THE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES TO WHOM THEY RETURN
HOME. TO ADDRESS THE EFFECTS OF
TRAUMA AND STRESS RELATED
SYMPTOMS WE MUST TACKLE IT HEAD
ON AND THIS FIRST STEP IS EARLY
IDENTIFICATION. WHEN THE
SUICIDE RATES ARE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS ARE 39% HIGHER. THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION AT THE
SAME OFFICES ARE TELLING US
THEY WANT TO LEARN HOW TO
MANAGE STRESS AND COPE WITH
PTSD BUT ARE SCARED. OF
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT IT'S CLEAR THAT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING.
THE TOXIC CULTURE IN OUR
PRISONS TODAY HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO A GROWING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT WILL HAVE LONG
LASTING HEALTH IMPLICATIONS. AB
NINETY FOUR REQUIRES ALL
CORRECTION OFFICER TO RECEIVE
ANNUAL MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATIONS. INSURERS ARE GIVEN
INFORMATION TO ACCESS CRITICAL
RESOURCES AND CLARIFIED THAT
THESE EVALUATIONS SHOWN BOTH BE
KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AND NEVER BE
USED AS A CASE FOR DISCIPLINARY
ACTION. BY DOING THIS AB NINETY
FOUR WE WILL DE STIGMATIZED
MENTAL HEALTH AND PROMOTE THE
WELL BEING OF EVERYONE INVOLVED
IN CALIFORNIA'S CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEM WITH ME TODAY DIVIDE
THAT TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IS HOPE JOSE BARRERA FORMER
MARION COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. DO WE HAVE JOSE BUT A
LOT ON THE LINE. AT&T OPERATOR.
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE WAITING TO
HEAR FROM JOSE PADILLA FROM THE
CPT A. I GUESS WE CAN'T.
INTERFERE IN A MATTER OF OUR
PRIDE WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY MY NAME'S JOSE
KERALA AS WAS NOTIFIED CHAIR-
JONES SAWYER- I AM THE FORMER
MEMBER A PUBLIC DEFENDER MARIN
COUNTY- AND I'D BE GLAD TO BE
HERE TO SPEAK ON THE BILL- IT
THIS AFTERNOON THAT TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF AB- NINETY
FOUR AB NINETEEN NINETY FOUR IS
A WELL THOUGHT OUT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT SEEKS
PROACTIVELY TO SUPPORT NOT ONLY
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN
STATE PRISONS BUT THE PRISON
GUARDS WERE DOING THEIR JOB-
DIDN'T IT AS WAS NOTED BY THE
CHAIR INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND THE GOAL OF
THIS LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE A STABLE
MINDSET AND SUPPORT NECESSARY
TO OVERCOME THE OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT THAT IDEA THE ONLY
STRESS I CAN TOP INCOME AND THE
JOB IS STATE PRISON IS REALLY
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE ALL
LOOKING FORWARD TO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I HAVE WORKED IN IS
AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER I WORKED-
FIRSTHAND WITH CORRECTIONAL
CRISTINA GARCIA DONNA STATE
PRISON BECAUSE I DID THE PRISON
CASES WHEN I WORKED WITH TWO
OTHER SUPPORT. THANK YOU
PROVIDES ATTORNEYS IN MARIN
COUNTY BOARD DRESSING CASES OUT
OF SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON AND
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT GUARDS ARE
UNDER TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
STRESS AND THE BRUTALITY CAN
SOMETIMES COME OUT WHEN PEOPLE
ARE UNDER THAT KIND OF STRESS
IS AS NOTED BY- CHAIR- DURING
STORY VERY MUCH LIKE IN
MILITARY COMBAT IT'S A VERY
VERY DIFFICULT JOB I HAVE KNOWN
MEMBERS OF THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS UNION WITH QUICK AND
THEY TOLD ME LATER THAT THEY
JUST COULDN'T LIVE WITH THE
THREAT THAT THEY WERE HAVING TO
TAKE HOME AND UNDERGO HE ADDS
SOME OF THE PEER GROUP PRESSURE
THAT THEY HAVE TO. SORT OF
INDOOR IF ANYTHING WAS OUT OF
STEP THE WAIT THERE THE WAITER
PRESENTED THEMSELVES ANYTHING
IT'S A VERY VERY TOUGH
CIRCUMSTANCE. TO WORK UNDER
INDEED MANY IF- MEMBERS OF- THE
CORRECTIONAL. ARE BUT-
COMMUNITY WELL FINE THEMSELVES
WITH OF. MENTAL HEALTH
BREAKDOWN AND ALL. THAT CAN
SOMETIMES BLENDING INTO
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY I RECALL THE
CASE OF SAN DIEGO WE'RE PRISON
GUARD WHO SEEM FINE ON HIS
FACE. WHAT THE VETS WERE CAUGHT
STEALING THE IDENTITY OF A
PUBLIC DEFENDER AND A QUIET
CREDIT ARDS AND OTHER THINGS
USING A STOLEN IDENTITY. WHEN
HE WAS FINALLY CAUGHT HE
BASICALLY SAID THAT THERE WAS
THE STRESS OF THE JOB IS
INABILITY TO DEAL WITH MAJOR
DAILY STRESSORS. THAT CAUSED
HIM TO JUST GO THIS ROUTE.
STRESSED DAILY CONTACT WITH
HUNDREDS OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND THE DAILY
POSSIBILITY OF BODILY HARM PUTS
BOTH THE INCARCERATED AND A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AT
HEIGHTENED LEVELS. FOR
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH BREAKDOWN. AB NINETY
FOUR ENSURES THE HUMANE
TREATMENT OF AND SAFETY OF
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED AND
PROTECTS THE SAFETY OF ALL WHO
WORK AND MORE HOUSE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS. FOR
THAT REASON- CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IS IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB. NINETY FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR OPERATOR WE
HAVE ANY OTHER A WINTER'S ON
THE- I WOULD LIKE TO- IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO PAR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE ZERO YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINETY FOUR. AND WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL THEN HEAR
FROM MATTHEW EASILY- SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION. HE'S FROM CCPOA.
THANK THANK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND START WITH ROBERT GARCIA'S
REPRESENTING THE CCPOA BENEFIT
TRUST FUND AND THEN I'LL GO
AHEAD AND FOLLOW HIM. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS ROBERT
MARCELLO GARCIA. I SIXTEEN
YEARS SERVICE AS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER. CURRENTLY WORKING AT
AVENAL STATE PRISON. I'M ALSO
THE ELECTED VICE CHAIR OF THE
CDP AWAY BENEFIT TRUST FUND.
THE BILL BECAUSE DEDICATED TO
THE WELL BEING OF OUR MEMBERS.
THAT INCLUDES THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF OUR MEMBERS WELL. MEDOFF HAS
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
PRIORITY. THE BENEFITS PRESS
ONE OF ADVOCATES OF ONGOING
RESILIENCY TRAINING AND
AWARENESS INITIATIVE. WE HAVE
AN ONGOING MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS PROGRAM. BOASTING A
WIDE BAND BOTH ARE ALSO WANTED
TO PROMOTE AVAILABLE PORT
SERVICES. THANK THAT PRESS ONE
RECENTLY STARTED OFFERING REACT
WITH THAT I CRIED THAT. WHICH
CONNECTING INDIVIDUAL TO TRAIN
PROFESSIONAL TO OFFER HELP. THE
CURRENT AMENDED VERSION EIGHTY
NINETY FOUR PEERS LESS HARMFUL
THAN THE PREVIOUS VERSION THE
BILL LEGAL MUCH TO BE DESIRED.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO SIT DOWN AND TALK. WE CAN
WORK TOWARD IMPACTFUL
LEGISLATION. I ALSO WANT TO
PERSONALLY LET YOU KNOW THAT
OUR DOORS ARE OPEN. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE'RE GOING TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB NINETY
FOUR AT RISK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MATTHEW. RIGHT NOW MY NAME
IS BADLY REPRESENTING CCPOA AND
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
NINE FOUR WELL WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE LATEST ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL- WHICH
REMOVED MANY OF THE MOST
OBJECTIVE OBJECTIONABLE
PROVISIONS THAT WE STILL MUST
UNFORTUNATELY REMAIN OPPOSED
THREE YEARS THE ASSOCIATION AT
THE PORTED IMPROVEMENTS FOR
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES FOR OUR MEMBERS.
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS HAVE A
VERY DIFFICULT JOB THAT
INDISPUTABLY THE HIGH LEVELS OF
STRESS AND CONTEMPLATE THEM IN
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS BUT
THEY'RE FORCED TO COPE WITH.
ALONG WITH OUR BENEFIT TRUST
WITH SPONSORED LETTERS
LEGISLATION INSTITUTING
IMPORTANT PEER SUPPORT PROGRAM
TO ASSIST OUR OFFICERS. FOR
COPING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. WELL THESE THAT
WELL THE THAT EFFORTS WERE
ULTIMATELY VETOED WE'VE
RECENTLY BEEN ABLE TO MAKE SOME
GREAT STRIDES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT MORE DIRECTLY. THIS
VALUABLE RESOURCE ALLOWS
DOCTORS TO RECEIVE HELP FROM
THOSE THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH AND ENCOURAGING THEM TO
SEEK HELP WHENEVER NEEDED. IN
ADDITION TO THE PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAM WE'VE WORKED WITH YOU
SEE OUR TO RECENTLY BEGAN USING
AN APP CALLED PORTICO. THE
APPLICATION ALLOWS DOCTORS IN
NEED TO SEEK HELP
CONFIDENTIALLY WELL BEING
CONNECTED TO RELEVANT RESOURCES
WITHOUT FEAR OF REPERCUSSIONS
OR NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT. UNFORTUNATELY
EIGHTY NINETY FOUR WILL LIKELY
HAVE THE OPPOSITE EFFECT AND
INDEED URGING UP FROM THE
KNOWLEDGE IN ANY MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THEY MAY BE STRUGGLING
WITH. DESPITE THE MUCH IMPROVED
CONFIDENTIALITY PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL IT CREATES PERCEPTION
OF FEAR THAT THE DEPARTMENT MAY
FIND OUT YOU TAKE ACTION
AGAINST THEM. WILL THAT BE
TODAY OR SOMEDAY IN THE FUTURE.
AND GIVEN THAT THE BILL NOW HAS
NO DIRECT CONSEQUENCES FOR
OFFICERS AND MAKE NO ACTUAL
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO OUR
MEMBERS. I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT
NEED THE STATED OBJECTIVES. IT
PASSED THERE WILL BE A VERY
LARGE EXPENSE ASSOCIATED WITH
HIRING OR CONTRACTING WITH
ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
TO PERFORM OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DEVALUATIONS PER YEAR.
WITH NO DIRECT BENEFIT COURSE
ISN'T ACTUALLY PROVIDED TO
THOSE STRUGGLING WITH THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. THE FUND COULD
BE BETTER UTILIZED BY IMPROVING
THE RESOURCES OFFICERS NEED TO
DEAL WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
WE CAN BE SUPPORTING OUR
EXPANDING OUR NEW PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAM OR OFFERING YOU PATH TO
HEALING. MIDDLE HEALTH IS BEEN
A PRIORITY FOR THE ASSOCIATION
FOR YEARS. AND WE'RE FINALLY
BEGINNING TO GET SOME TRACTION
AND MAKE PROGRESS. THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY UNDO MANY OF
THESE GAMES AND DISCOURAGE
DOCTORS FROM SEEKING HELP. FOR
THESE REASONS WE WERE WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MISTER. THANK
YOU. AN OPERATOR TO HAVE ANY
OTHER. CALLERS ON THE LINE THE
ELECTRICS PRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR OPPOSITION OF AB
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FIVE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING WITH
YOUR BIKE SHARING MEMBERS THIS
IS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA-
WE DIDN'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL WE DID SHARE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT- RETRIBUTION.
BASED ON A MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION AND PERPETUATING
STIGMA THAT MAY HAVE RESULTED
FROM THE PREVIOUS ITERATION OF
THE BILL BUT WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT THE AUTHORS OFFICE HAS
CONTINUED TO WORK WITH US AND-
AS THE BILL WAS RECENTLY
AMENDED. IT REMOVES A GOOD DEAL
OF OUR CONCERNS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HIS OFFICE THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE CALL. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF SIX TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT CHAIR-
AS FUNDING AS OF THE HAPPENED
AT THAT WOULD DELIVER THEM
COALITION I APOLOGIZE- I TRY TO
CALL IN AND SUPPORT BUT MISTER-
YES THE TIMING OF IT SO BUT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
FOUR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK IN WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY
IN THE- THE ROOM IN HERE THOUGH
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
OKAY IT DOESN'T LOOKS LIKE
THAT'S THE CASE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM WE HAVE ANYBODY
HAVE BEEN THE FIRST ONE TODAY.
OKAY APPARENTLY NOT. OKAY HOW
ABOUT- COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. MISTER CLARK FIRST
AND THEN MR CHERYL OKAY- I KNOW
WHY YOU DID THIS YOU'RE DOING
IT BECAUSE YOU'RE TRYING TO
HELP THE PRISON GUARDS. AND I
HOPE THAT WELL IT'S ONLY GOING
TO MAKE SENSE TO KEEP THE BILL
GOING IF WE CAN BRING THEM ON
BOARD- THAT BEING SAID- WE'VE
ALREADY HAD A MOTION- I'LL
CERTAINLY BE VOTING IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL. AND I HOPE WE CAN GET
TO THE POINT WHERE- WHERE THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT- THAT THE
PRISON GUARDS CAN SUPPORT
BECAUSE OTHERWISE IT DOESN'T
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE TO BRING
UP. BEYOND THAT. THANKS THE
CHARLOTTE. SO THIS IS SOMETHING
I MEAN THIS REALLY DIVE ONE OF
THE MORE DIFFICULT DECISION AND
SUBJECT MATTERS. WE'VE DEALT
WITH THIS BEFORE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY- JUST DO IN- YEARLY
WELLNESS PHYSICALS- FOR A
DEPARTMENT A LARGE APARTMENT
LIKE- L. A. COUNTY- FIRE. WE
WENT THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF
TRYING. TO GETTING PEOPLE ON
BOARD. TO ENTER AND THEY WENT
THROUGH THE LET'S MAKE IT
MANDATORY AND THAT THAT DIDN'T
THAT DIDN'T GO WELL- WE GOT
MORE RESISTANCE FROM TRYING TO
DO THAT IN TRYING TO GET THE
MEMBERS THEMSELVES TO DEVELOP
THE PROGRAM AND THEN WE GIVE.
THEM THE RESOURCES TO DO WHAT
THEY TO DO- TO BE ABLE TO DO
THEIR- AND IN OUR CASE IT WAS.
YOU KNOW TOO MANY GUYS IT WE'RE
HAVING MAY WASTE. ARE ON FOR
ONE OF THOSE IS NOT WE DID NOT
ADDING HEALTH. GAIL THIS THING
TO THE PHYSICAL WELLNESS
PROGRAM RIGHT RIGHT AND NOW I
THINK IN RETROSPECT I THINK
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE
TO INCLUDE. BUT IT ALL COMES
DOWN TO PROVIDING THE RESOURCES
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
THE WAY THEY NEED TO DO IT. IF
WE DON'T HAVE CLIENTS FROM THEM.
IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFICULT- FOR
A PROGRAM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST BE TOO
MUCH RESISTANCE. AND. AND IT
MIGHT NOT BE IN THE FORM THAT
THEY NEED- SO THAT'S WHAT MY
STRUGGLE IS AT THIS BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT. TRYING TO
HELP BECAUSE THAT IS IT'S A
HORRIBLE SITUATION- IT.
TERMINATES ALL ACROSS PUBLIC
SAFETY THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
FIRE DEPARTMENTS. ACTIONAL
FACILITIES AND- SO YOU KNOW IT
WAS. MY I THINK WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED. AND FORCING THEIR
RESOURCES I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
APPROACH IS GOING TO WORK AND
THAT'S MY CONCERN. SO ANYWAY
JURY'S OUT I HOPE WE KEEP
WORKING WITH THE WITH STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY BARTER
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. TO FIND
OUT WHAT PROGRAM THEY THINK
WILL WORK AND HOW WE CAN HELP
THEM BY FUNDING ARE CREATING
THE FUNDING FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE A PROGRAM WORKED IT'S A
FACT OF. THAT STOPS THE SUIT
CORRECT SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
JUST WANNA MAKE ONE REMARK REAL
QUICKLY THAT- INTENT OF THIS
BILLS NOBLE- I THINK
UNFORTUNATELY THE PART I
STRUGGLE WITH THE SIMILAR TO
WHAT OF MY COLLEAGUE JUST
STATED ABOUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
BY AND BY THE ORGANIZATION AND
I THINK THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING BARGAINING IS
PROBABLY AN IMPORTANT AVENUE TO
BE INCLUDED SOMEWHERE IN THIS.
ASSESS AND IT SHOULD BE
RESPECTED ALSO- BUT I'M HOPING
THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THESE- CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
ONES IMPACTED THEY UNDERSTAND
THE NUANCES IN WHAT WOULD. BE
MORE LIKELY TO WORK WHAT ISN'T
AND SO I'M JUST PROBABLY GOING
TO BE LAYING OFF TODAY BUT I'LL
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO CLOSER.
THANK YOU SO. CORRECTIONS
OFFICERS ARE DYING. WHAT
THEY'RE DOING NOW. IS NOT
WORKING. AND YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S A SEVERAL MEMBERS ON
HERE YOU'VE ASKED ME TO TRY TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT BECAUSE-
COLONEL JUSTICE REFORM ISN'T
WORKING THE WAY THAT YOU THINK
IT SHOULD WE TRY SOME
EXPERIMENTS- I LOOK AT THIS AS-
WELL. GIVING THEM MORE MONEY.
AND NOT DOING ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES WHETHER NOT THOSE
PROGRAMS WORK- LIKE I PROBABLY
COULDN'T DO THAT SELL THAT
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY. THEY'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO THINK I'M
TRYING TO TAKE IT AWAY WHEN IN
FACT. I ACTUALLY DO WORK WITH
NONPROFITS TO FIND OUT WHAT
ACTUALLY WORKS I ACTUALLY WANT
TO GO INTO DEPARTMENTS TO FIND
OUT WHAT ACTUALLY WORKS. AND IF
WE HAVE TO MOVE MONEY. TO
PROGRAMS THAT ACTUALLY WORK AND
MAKE IT MAKE A DIFFERENCE WE
SHOULD AND THE ONES THAT DON'T
WE NEED TO GET RID OF. SO I
WOULD LOVE. TO SIT DOWN. WITH
WHATEVER THESE BENEFITS GROUP
IS. M. FIND OUT WHAT EXACTLY
THEY DO BUT I CAN YOU KNOW IS
GOD WE TRUST ON BOTH SIDES TO-
OBVIOUSLY BOTH HAVE TWO MAIN
REASONS WHY WE DON'T TRUST EACH
OTHER. BUT THIS IS JUST TOO
IMPORTANT. IT'S JUST TOO
IMPORTANT NOT. TO MAKE A MAKE A
TRY BOB OTHERWISE THEY'RE GOING
TO START DROPPING LIKE FLIES
AND DYING THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HAVING ALCOHOL PROBLEMS DRUG
PROBLEMS SELF MEDICATING.
BECAUSE THAT ENVIRONMENT IS SO
INTENSE- I DON'T KNOW IF AND IF
YOU'VE EVER WALKED INTO A
PRISON ONCE YOU GET THROUGH THE
GATES. IT IS OPPRESSIVE I MEAN
IT'S- AT THE END THAT'S WHAT.
KIND OF GOT ME WANTING TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS BECAUSE I
SITTING ON BUDGET SUB FIVE. I
CAN ADVOCATE FOR MORE RESOURCES
I CAN ADVOCATE FOR MORE MONEY
SO THAT WE CAN SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. AND WE NEED TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S- AND
WE NEED TO LET PEOPLE KNOW BUT
AT SOME POINT. AS MANY VIEW OF
APOSTLES SAID- WITH THIS. DRUG
REHAB PROGRAM OR WHATEVER.
HAVING P. SO. IDENTIFY AND GO
THROUGH PROGRAMS SOMETIMES
THOSE DON'T WORK SO WE IS
PROBABLY- WE'VE GOT TO COME
TOGETHER AND SAY WHAT WORKS
WHAT DOESN'T AND THEN WE
PROVIDE MORE AVENUES FOR FOLKS
TO GO THROUGH SO THEY CAN GET
ON TO THE HELP THEY NEED WHAT
DISCUSSES SAYS. I CAN HELP YOU
IDENTIFY YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH ANY OF THESE STORES
HAVE TO TAKE ANY OF THESE- HELP
HELPFUL HINTS. MATTHEWS SIT
THERE LIKE LIKE A MUMMY AND
DISCO. ALL DAY. WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOUR ARMS CROSSED.
BUT AT LEAST WE GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAYBE GET THE
HELP THEY NEED THIS IS WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THERE'S
NOTHING OUT THAT'S ALL IT IS
OTHERWISE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A BUNCH OF FOLK. NOT SEEKING
THE HELP THEY NEED AND IF AND
FAMILIES INMATES OTHERS. ARE
GOING TO BE THE WORST FOR.
SOLAR SPECTER ASKED REVIVAL AND
I WILL. EVEN THAT THEY HAVEN'T
REACHED OUT TO ME I WILL REACH
OUT TO US TO PRESENCE DOES DALY
AND SAY WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO
FOR. FOR YOUR MEMBERS WHAT CAN
WE DO FOR THE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOSHE'S SECOND AGAINST WILL
CALL FOR THE QUESTION. I'M AB
NINETY FOUR BY THE MEMBER JONES
SAWYER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
EXCUSE ME DO PASSED TO THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE. JONES
SAWYER. HI JONES SAWYER IRAQI
NOT VOTING LACKEY NOT BODING
BARRICADE HAND BACKHAND I WORK.
CORK I SANTIAGO. THEY ARE TO.
THERE ARE TWO NOT VOTING WICKS
WICKS I LI LI I. THAT MEASURE
PASSES GOOD JOB THANK YOU. YEAH
YEAH YOU KNOW WHAT. I'M GOING
TO THE STATE. CHAU OKAY. OKAY.
NEXT WE WILL DO ANY ADD ONS OR
BOTH CHANGES MADAM SECRETARY
AND THE ON CALL NY ARTICLES
UHHUH MA'AM SUBJECT PLEASE GO
THROUGH ALL THE MEASURES TAKEN
UP TODAY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BARRICADE. TACKY HAD I
DON'T NUMBER ONE WASN'T CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER TWO WAS PULLED BY
COMMITTEE. I REMEMBER. THREE
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY NINE MR BONTA
AND TEAM SANTIAGO. ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY NINE NINETY
BY BONTA BY SANTIAGO MISTAKES.
MISS WICKS I. AB NINE THREE
NINE ITEM NUMBER FIVE WAS
PULLED BY COMMITTEE I DON'T
NUMBER SIX WAS ON CONSENT. I
DON'T NUMBER SEVEN YEARS AGO.
WE ARE WAITING FOR MR SANTIAGO.
I AM NUMBER EIGHT WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR. I DON'T NUMBER NINE
AB ONE THOUSAND THREE PILOT
AMERICANS SALAS BARRICADE HAN
BARRICADE HAD AYE SANTIAGO
STILL PENDING. ON AB NINETY
FOUR. I DON'T ATTEND SANTIAGO
STILL PENDING ON ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN WAS ON CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL AB ONE TWENTY FOUR BY
SEVEN EXCUSE ME SENATOR COM
AKHIR BARRICADE HAND BARRACK HE
HAD AYE WICKS WICKS HI THAT
MEASURE PASSES SIX TWO. I ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR COM LONGER
BARRICADE HAN. BARRICADE HANNAH
I SIX TWO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY WAS ON
CONSENT. I DON'T NUMBER FIFTEEN
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL AB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEAD. LACKEY
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAN
BARRICADE HAD AYE SANTIAGO
STILL ENDING. ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
THAT PASSED OUT FIVE TWO. ITEM
NUMBER. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. BARRICADE HAN
BARRICADE HAD ICE SANTIAGO
STILL PENDING WICKS WICKS I.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN BY SOME
MEMBER MURATSUCHI SANTIAGO
STILL PENDING ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EXCUSE ME I DON'T NUMBER
NINETEEN WAS ON CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
AB TWELVE TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE
HAD ICE SANTIAGO STILL PENDING
BUT THIS MEASURE PASSES. ITEM
NUMBER. TWENTY TWO AB TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE AS AN CONSENT. THE
I AM TWENTY THREE MOTION TO
RECONSIDER ON AB TWO SIX SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER BARRICADE
HAN. IT'S JUST THE MOTION TO
RECONSIDER. IS THAT I SANTIAGO
PENDING WICKS. THE MYSTICS OF.
SO WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR. IN
ORDER.
I'M YEAH. BUT IT IS NOT
INTENDED REQUESTED WITH OUR.
YEAH. THE RIVER- YEAH. WHAT
MIGHT BE RIGHT NOW YOU DON'T.
THAT WOULD THEY CALL ME THE
PRICE. HI I EVERY CONSIDERATION.
ON AB TWO SIXTIETH TO SIXTY SIX
THE MOTION TO RECONSIDER WICKS
I.
NEWMAN.
YEAH YEAH. OKAY OKAY
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
OKAY. I AM
NUMBER ONE WITH SOME CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER TWO IS PULLED BY
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY BONTA BY TEEN
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. I DON'T
NUMBER FOUR HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER SIX
IS ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY GABRIEL SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. AT A NUMBER EIGHT
WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB. ONE THOUSAND
THREE BELLADONNA GONZALEZ THANK
YOU. SAN DIEGO I REMEMBER TEN
AB NINETY FOUR BY JONES SAWYER
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I AM NMBER
ELEVEN WITH A CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. I DON'T NUMBER
THIRTEEN HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH. ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
WITHOUT CONSENT. I REMEMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
BY SUMMER LEAGUE SANTIAGO FOR
THEIR CALL I. I DON'T NUMBER
SIXTEEN HAVE BEEN DISPENSED
WITH ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE BY MCCARTY
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I. I DON'T
NUMBER EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE SEVEN BY SOME REMOTE TO
CHEAT SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I DON'T
NUMBER NINETEEN WAS A CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB TWELVE TEN BY
SOME ROUTINE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I. ADAM TWENTY TWO WAS ON
CONSENT ITEM TWENTY THREE THIS
IS THE MOTION TO RECONSIDER AB
TWO SIX SIX SANTIAGO. CLICK TO
SEE THE MOTION TO RECONSIDER ON
AB TWO SIXES. SANTIAGO I.
BUSINESS MISTER CHAIRMAN RIGHT
THAT CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE.